STATE SENATOR.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY IN THE
JUDICIARY WILL NOW AND CONVENE --
WHAT'S TO ROLL CALL [inaudible]
CENTER SKINNER.
SENATOR MORLOCK.
CENTER BELL.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM -- THE
AGENDA BEFORE YOU LET ME -- AND
NOW IT'S A FEW CHANGES.
WE ARE PULLING ITEMS FIVE AND
ITEMS TWENTY SIX AND MOVING THEM.
TO DISCUSSION.
WE ARE ALSO PULLING ITEM.
SEVEN AND ITEM EIGHT ISSUE SEVEN
ISSUE.
EIGHT N. MOVING THEM TO
DISCUSSION -- OTHERWISE.
THE REMAINING VOTE ONLY ITEMS
WILL STAY AS IS.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION.
ON ISSUES ONE THROUGH
[inaudible] FOR WHICH IS THE
TATTOO REMOVAL PROGRAM THE
SUPPORT FOR VICTIMS SERVICES.
THE SIGN LANGUAGE INTERPRETER
SERVICES IN THE WORKFORCE
INNOVATION AND OPPORTUNITY ACT
DATA SHARING.
GREAT SEVEN MOTION LET'S DO A
ROLL CALL [inaudible]
CENTER SKINNER.
BY SENATOR MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
SENATOR ABOUT.
OKAY.
AND ISSUE -- FIVE I WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE A MOTION AND THAT IS
HOLD ON A MINUTE IT'S ONLY GOT
IT'S AN ACRONYM RIGHT NOW AND I
WANT TO SAY IT OUT.
ALSO IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
REAPPROPRIATION -- THAT WAS
PULLED UP SORRY SORRY YOUR AGE I
WAS TOLD CORRECT.
OKAY -- THEN LET SAID.
I NOTES THAT EVEN OKAY -- WE
WILL I WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION
ON ISSUE [inaudible] SIX GREAT
AND THIS IS THE MEDICAL
ADJUSTMENT FOR RE ENTRY
FACILITIES -- LET'S TO ROLL CALL
[inaudible]
SENATOR SKINNER.
BY CENTER MORE LOCK.
SENATOR BELL.
ALL RIGHT GREAT AND THEN -- I
WOULD LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
ON ISSUE SEVEN WHICH IS THE
RECEIVERS MEDICAL CLASSIFICATION --
WE PULL THAT WE PULLED EIGHT
YOU'RE RIGHT WE PULLED THAT JUST.
NINETY NINE GREAT OKAY WE HAVE
MOTION NOW AN ISSUE NINE AND TEN
AS INDICATED -- THE ACTION IS
INDICATED IN OUR AGENDA -- ROLL
CALL.
CENTER SKINNER HI SENATOR
MORLOCK CENTER BELL.
OKAY GREAT NOW LET'S SEE WHERE
WE AT WITH [inaudible]
ELEVEN EXCELLENT -- SO NOW WE
HAVE A MOTION ON ISSUE ELEVEN
WHICH IS TROUT COURT RESERVES
TWELVE WHICH IS TRIAL COURT
EMPLOYEES BENEFITS ADJUSTMENT
AND THIRTEEN WHICH IS THE TRIAL
COURT TRUST FUND REVENUE
SHORTFALL.
IN THESE ARE -- APPROVED AS
BUDGETED.
ROLL CALL [inaudible]
CENTER SKINNER.
HI CENTER MORE LOCK.
SENATOR BELL.
RIGHT NOW.
ISSUE FOURTEEN IS NOT PULLED FOR
DISCUSSION BUT I'D LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON FOURTEEN
WHICH IS -- INCREASING THE
ALLOCATION TO OUR NONPROFIT
LEGAL AID GROUPS.
THE MOVIE.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION ON
ISSUE FOURTEEN IT'S PROVE IS
BUDGETED ROLL CALL.
WE HAVE TO PULL IT FOR
DISCUSSION.
DO I GUESS SUPPORT FOR
DISCUSSION [inaudible]
OKAY -- GOOD FOR THE I AM
[inaudible]
I HAVE [inaudible] FOURTEEN
WE'RE IT WAS ON VOTE ONLY ON THE
ORIGINAL AGENDA BUT WE CAN PUT.
FOUR HOURS BUT NO I FIND A JOB
THIS ITEM OKAY -- ON THE HOLD.
WE WENT FOR A DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
HE SAID.
WELL IF YOU WANT TO TALK.
OKAY SO YOU HAD ORIGINALLY WAS
NO ANSWER THE REQUESTED SCHOOL
SENATE-ROOM [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
ALL HAVE [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WITH I'M PERFECTLY WILLING TO DO.
OKAY RIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON IT -- ROLL CALL PLEASE THIS
IS APPROVALS BUDGETED IT'S ON
THIS GENDER BEFORE YOU WHICH
ISSUE FOURTEEN IT'S INCREASING
THE ALLOCATION TO THE NONPROFIT
LEGAL AID GROUPS.
ROLL CALL CENTERS SKINNER I
CENTER MOCK.
CENTER BELL.
OKAY NOW ISSUE -- I'LL ENTERTAIN
A MOTION ON ISSUES -- FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN THESE ARE.
ON THE DEPEND CITY COUNCIL TITLE
FOR EASY FINDING THE COURT OF
APPEAL WORKLOAD AND THE LANGUAGE
AXIS EXPANSION IN EACH
CALIFORNIA COURT.
A MADE. FOR THE OKAY FOR THOSE
[inaudible]
THREE GREAT [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
ROLL CALL.
THIS FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THIRTY SURE
SURE SURE.
AND USUALLY THESE WERE NOT.
ACTING ON THE JUDGESHIPS SORRY
[inaudible]
MY APOLOGIES.
OR THE JUDGESHIPS WE ARE HAVING
AS A DISCUSSION ITEM
[inaudible]
SURE.
NO WORRIES -- THE STORE THIS IS --
THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE THE
MOTION ON ARE UNDER -- ITEMS
ZERO TWO FIFTY THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH THERE FIFTEEN THE
DEPENDENCY COUNCIL TITLE FOR E.
FUNDING.
THEY ARE SIXTEEN THE COURT OF
APPEALS WORK LOAD AND THEIR
SEVENTEEN THE LANGUAGE ACCESS
EXPANSION IN EACH CALIFORNIA
COURT IT'S INTERPRETERS THAT.
SEVENTEEN AND THEY ARE --
APPROVE IS BUDGETED.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THAT --
LET'S DO ROLL CALL [inaudible]
CENTER SKINNER.
I CENTER MOLOCH [inaudible]
CENTRE BELL.
ALL RIGHT NOW.
WE'LL GO TO ITEM EIGHT ONE
TWENTY WHICH IS THE COMMISSION
ON PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING.
AND THIS IS ISSUE EIGHTEEN THE
STATE PENALTY FINE TRAILER BILL.
LANGUAGE.
ND IT IS APPROVALS FOR POST.
I CAN ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THAT
[inaudible]
ONE GREAT.
LET'S DO ROLL CALL [inaudible]
CENTER SKINNER.
HI THERE MORE LOCK.
SENATOR BELL.
EXCELLENT.
NOW WE ARE GOING -- TO ITEM.
ZERO EIGHT TWENTY WHICH IS
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND I'LL ENTERTAIN A OTION ON
ITEM.
NINETEEN WHERE ISSUE NINETEEN
SKEWS ME ISSUE.
NINETEEN GREAT AND THIS IS THE
PEACE OFFICERS VIDEO ON AUTO
AUDIO RECORDINGS IT'S THE
FUNDING ALLOCATION FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB.
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT WE HAVE A
MOTION ROLL CALL.
SENATOR SKINNER HI CENTER MORE
LOCK.
CENTER BELL.
RATHER IS STAFF RECOMMENDATION
APOLOGIES AND THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT.
THAN WHAT THE BCP WAS
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
I'M.
THANK YOU FOR CORRECTING ME MISS.
SENATOR BREAUX LET'S GO -- TO
THIS IS NOW HAVE STILL UNDER
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IT'S ISSUE
TWENTY THE DISPOSITIONS WORKLOAD
INCREASE.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A
SEPARATE MOTION ON DAD.
AND THE MOTION IS -- TO REJECT
THAT PROPOSAL [inaudible]
THE MOVE.
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION ON ITEM
TWENTY THE DISPOSITION WORKLOAD
INCREASED TO REJECT THE PROPOSAL
ROLL CALL.
SENATOR SKINNER.
I CENTER MORE LOCK [inaudible]
CENTRE BELL.
ALRIGHT THEN WE'RE GONNA GO --
TO I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
ISSUE.
TWENTY ONE WHICH IS FUNDING FOR
THE NEW AND EXPANDED -- CRIMES.
AND THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS
REJECT THE PROPOSAL.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION.
ON THAT ITEM AS I INDICATED TO
ROLL CALL.
CENTERS SKINNER I SENATOR
MORLOCK.
CENTRE BELL.
OKAY -- THAT PASSES WE'LL NOW GO
TO ISSUE.
TWENTY TWO WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA INTERNET CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND NET NEUTRALITY
ACT -- ALLOCATIONS FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE.
AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADOPT
THE LA OWES RECOMMENDATION AND
TO MODIFY THE PROPOSAL BY
ADOPTING THE BUDGET LANGUAGE
SPECIFYING THE FUNDING CAN ONLY
BE USED.
IF THE COURT PROHIBITIONS
PREVENTING IMPLEMENTATION OR
ENFORCEMENT HAVE EXPIRED -- BEEN
REMOVED -- BUT MOTION GREAT SO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THAT AS I
JUST READ [inaudible]
ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER HI CENTER MODOC
[inaudible]
CENTRE BELL.
OKAY THAT MOTION PASSES.
AND NOW -- ALL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ITEMS.
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY FOUR FOR
TWENTY THREE THIS IS THE CRIME
PREVENTION INVESTIGATION
INFORMATIONAL DATABASES.
AND THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS
TO MODIFY THE PROPOSAL AND
APPROVE ONE NEW PERMANENT FIELD
WRAPPED -- AS PER THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS ANALYSIS AND THEN
ISSUE TWENTY FOUR IS THE
CRIMINAL LAW DNA COLLECTION OF
MINORS.
AND THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS TO
REJECT THE PROPOSAL AS THE BILL
WAS KEYED IN ON FISCAL BY BOTH
HOUSES.
GREAT SWEAR MOTION NOW -- WITH --
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THE MOTION
OR AS I READ.
AND WE WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL ON
THOSE TWO ISSUES.
CENTER SKINNER I CENTER MORE
LOCK [inaudible]
CENTRE BELL [inaudible]
OKAY.
NOW WE WILL GO TO ISSUE
[inaudible] TWENTY FIVE THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT INVESTIGATION
EVIDENCE KIDS AND IT WAS EIGHT
ALLOCATION. FOR THE PREPARATION
OF THE REPORT.
AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
REJECT THE PROPOSAL.
IN A MOTION REMOVED.
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION ON THAT.
ONE ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER I CENTER MORE
LOCK.
CENTRE BELL.
OKAY AND ISSUE [inaudible]
TWENTY SIX SIX WE ARE NOW HOLD
FOR DISCUSSION.
WITH FOR FURTHER DISCUSSION WE
DIDN'T WE'RE DOING SOMETHING.
NOT HERE NOT ACCORDING. TWENTY
SIX ONE THAT HAVE -- I GET IT
OKAY YOU HAD.
TO YES IT'S FOR DISCUSSION.
WITH THAT THAT'S RIGHT CORRECT
CORRECT THROUGH THE FOLDER FOR
DISCUSSIONS -- IN THAT SEVEN
WELL WE'LL GET TO IT SO.
WE WILL NOW GO -- TO DURING THE
START TIME OR MEMBER DEPARTMENT.
YEAH YEAH YEAH WE'LL GO BACK
OKAY SO.
WE'VE NOW ACTED ON ALL THE VOTE
ONLY.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK.
TO THE BEGINNING OF THE AGENDA
AND START WITH THOSE THINGS THAT
WE PULLED FOR DISCUSSION.
SO WE WON'T START WITH WHAT'S
LISTED AS OUR DISCUSSION ITEMS
BUT RATHER WE'RE GOING TO RETURN
TO THOSE THINGS THAT WERE ON
VOTE ONLY THAT WE PULLED FOR
DISCUSSION.
AND THE FIRST ITEM THAT WE
PULLED FOR DISCUSSION IS UNDER --
ITEM.
FIVE TWO TWO FIVE CDC ARE.
AND IT IS ISSUE
.
FIVE RIGHT SO -- THIS.
ITEM IS FROM COUNSEL IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
REAPPROPRIATION -- IT'S
REGARDING RE APPROPRIATING.
OF FOREIGNERS. FIFTEEN THOUSAND
FROM PROP SIXTY THREE MONIES.
FOR THAT CAMINO JUSTICE IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THREE
APPROPRIATIONS -- STAFF IF YOU
WANT TO PRESENT AND THEN --
CENTER MORE LACKEY AND IF YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS PLEASE GO AHEAD
STAFF YEAH GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS ERIC SWANSON I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF CDC OURS OFFICE OF
FISCAL SERVICES.
ARE THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU IS A
ONE TIME REAPPROPRIATION OF FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE ACT
FUNDS -- THIS WAS PROVIDED IN
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT FOURTEEN
BUDGET ACT.
BUT REMAINS ON SPENT WERE ASKING
FOR REAPPROPRIATION TO SPEND IT
IN BUDGET WE YEAR.
WITH ME TODAY IS STEPHANIE WELCH
WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE C. C. G. BEACH AREA.
AND SHE CAN DESCRIBE WHAT THOSE
FUNDS WILL BE USED.
FOR THANK YOU -- LAST YEAR WE
WERE LUCKY ENOUGH TO RECEIVE
THESE FUNDS AS PART OF THE
BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS -- AND THE
PURPOSE OF THE FUNDS IS FOR US
TO DEVELOP A COMPETITIVE --
PROCESS WHERE PEOPLE CAN BID FOR
CONTRACT -- FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE
OF EMPOWERING PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN
FORMALLY INCARCERATED AND LIVING
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS TO PROVIDE
INPUT INTO.
HOW TO IMPROVE OUR SERVICES SO
FOR EXAMPLE WHILE WE HAVE?
SOME OF THE THINGS WE'VE HEARD
SO FAR.
THAT ARE NEEDED WOULD BE A FROM
THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE OF OF FOR
THE FROM THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE
ON MENTAL ILLNESS.
A GROUP THAT REPRESENTS FAMILIES
WHO HAVE LOVED ONES WHO HAVE
MENTAL ILLNESS THAT THERE IS A
NEED FOR MORE TRAINING FOR
FAMILIES IS TO KNOW WHAT TO DO
WHEN THEIR LOVED ONE IS ARRESTED.
SO FOR EXAMPLE THEY COULD BID ON
A POTENTIAL CONTRACT THAT WOULD
DEVELOP A TOOL KIT TO HELP THESE
FAMILIES STATEWIDE.
BECAUSE THESE ARE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT DOLLARS IN THIS
CONTRACT HAS NEVER EXISTED
BEFORE AND IN FACT THERE ISN'T
CURRENTLY A CONTRACT LIKE THIS
PARTICULARLY TARGETING PEOPLE
WITH -- FORMAL FORMER JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT WE FELT IT WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO FOLLOW THE
GUIDANCE FROM THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT WHICH IS TO HAVE A
VERY ROBUST STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
TO THE FUNDS THAT WE HAVE USED
DURING CURRENT YEAR.
HAVE LAUNCHED A STATEWIDE A
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT PROCESS
THAT PROCESS -- BEGAN WITH A
JUVENILE JUSTICE ROUNDTABLE AND
CONTINUES THROUGHOUT THE SUMMER
WITH LISTENING SESSIONS AROUND
THE STATE.
CAN FORM INTERVIEWS AS WELLAS
FOCUS GROUPS THE PURPOSE OF THIS
IS TO HEAR FROM THE COMMUNITY AS
TO HOW WE SHOULD MOST
THOUGHTFULLY EXPENDITURES FUNDS --
IT IS A VERY SMALL AMOUNT OF
MONEY ON AN ON AN ONGOING BASIS
IT'S ABOUT A SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS STATE
WIDE TO COVER ISSUES -- THAT ARE
FOR CHILDREN YOUTH ADULTS SIX
ADDRESS WE FEEL IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO HEAR FROM THE
COMMUNITY AS TO HOW THEY WANTED
US TO STRUCTURE.
THE CONTRACTS DID THEY WANT AS
THE STRUCTURE.
THE CONTRACTS AT ON A REGIONAL
BASIS DID THEY WANT THEM TO BE A
SPECIFIC TO CERTAIN TARGET
POPULATIONS THAT HAVE HIGH NEEDS
FOR EXAMPLE IN OUR ROUND TABLE A
FEW WEEKS AGO WE HEARD THAT.
CHILDREN WHO HAVE PARENTS ARE
INCARCERATED HAVE A PARTICULAR
HIGH NEED.
SO THAT'S REALLY THE PURPOSE OF
RIGHT NOW AND SO WE FELT WE
WANTED TO ENSURE THAT WE HAD A
ROBUST PROCESS AND OF COURSE --
WE APPROPRIATE THE FUNDS FOR THE
FUTURE YEARS SAID THAT WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO AWARD.
ABOUT ONE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN CONTRACTS IN THE
FIRST YEAR.
SO I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE -- MORE
LOOK.
WHICH THE MONEY WAS NOT SPENT SO.
THIS DOES THAT MEAN THAT IF YOU
DIDN'T SPEND IT YOU LOSE IT.
AT THAT IS CORRECT THE MONEY
WOULD REVERT TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT FUN.
HERE SO I DIDN'T GO INTO RESERVE.
NO THOUGH THAT -- THESE ARE
STATE ADMIN MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
THROUGH A REAPPROPRIATION YOU'RE
YOU'RE GONNA TRY IT AGAIN.
ARE YOU GONNA SPEND IT THIS YEAR.
YES WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO PUT
THE MONEY OUT FOR BID SO
NORMALLY WE WOULD ONLY HAVE SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO PUT OUT TO BID IN A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS. FOR THE
FIRST YEAR WHICH WE INTEND TO
HAVE A THREE YEAR CONTRACTS
WE'LL BE ABLE TO PUT OUT TO BID
ONE POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
SO THAT'S HOW WE INTEND TO SPEND
THE MONEY NEXT YEAR JUST JUST A
I'M SORRY -- JUST ONE MORE THING
I THINK WHAT'S HARD ABOUT THIS
ISSUE AND IN SOME OF THESE
ISSUES THAT COME UP LATE IN THE
BUDGET ACT AS WE DIDN'T HAVE
SORT OF MONTHS TO PLAN AHEAD HOW --
TO HOW -- TO DO A COMPETITIVE
BID FOR THESE GRANTS IT WAS SORT
OF A LAST MINUTE ADD TO THE
BUDGET ACT AND THAT'S WHY THERE
WAS A DELAY IN.
GETTING ALL THE FUNDING OW OKAY
SO THAT WOULD EXPLAIN WHY.
THEY DIDN'T GET ACCOMPLISHED
BEFORE THE END OF THE FISCAL
YEAR -- YOU'RE EXPECTING YOU
YOU'RE CALLING IT A ONE TIME BUT
YOU WILL YOU HOPE TO GET IT FOR
THE NEXT TWO YEARS AS WELL SO
YOU'RE SAYING.
OF THESE ARE ONGOING FUNDS AND
SO -- WE INTEND TO FOLLOW A
SIMILAR PROCESS THAT THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY HAS FOLLOWED WITH
THEIR STAKEHOLDER CONTRACTS THAT
THEY EXECUTE FIRST FOR SPECIAL
POPULATIONS LIKE VETERANS GROUPS.
WHICH IS -- TO ISSUE THREE YEAR
CONTRACTS AND THEN ASSESS HOW
THOSE CONTRACTS WENT USING OUR
OUR STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THAT
WE'VE BUILT A LOOK AT THE
OUTCOMES OF THOSE.
POTENTIALLY PRIORITIES WILL
SHIFT THE COMMUNITY MAY IDENTIFY
THAT THE NEEDS OF OF OF CHILDREN
WHO HAVE INCARCERATED PARENTS IS
THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY FOR THE
FIRST YEAR.
FIRST THREE YEARS OF CONTRACTS
BUT MAY DETERMINE THAT SOME
OTHER PRIORITY IS HOW WE SHOULD
PUT OUT AN RFP THREE YEARS FROM
NOW.
SO FOR EXAMPLE MAYBE THE
PRIORITY THREE YEARS FROM NOW
WOULD BE TO REALLY FOCUS ON
RECEIVING OF BIDS FROM.
RE ENTRY COUNCILS TO TRY TO WORK
WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED TO HELP THEM BETTER
ACCESS LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
SO THIS IS GOOD FOR ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES.
THAT IS REALLY PART OF THE
COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
AGAIN -- I THINK HOW WE HAVE
SEEN IT BE -- ISSUED IN THE PASS
THROUGH THE THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION HAS
BEEN USUALLY ONE STATE Y.
CONTRACT.
WITH MULTIPLE SMALLER REGIONAL
CONTRACTS SO THAT -- THAT THERE
CAN BE A FOCUSED EFFORT IN
SMALLER PORTIONS OF THE STATE IS
IT ENOUGH MONEY.
I WOULD SAY THAT IT'S A VERY
SMALL AMOUNT OF FUNDS FOR A VERY
LARGE PROBLEM SIMILAR TO WHAT WE
DISCUSSED LAST TIME I WAS HERE.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
INTEND TO DO WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS IS ISSUE
THREE DIFFERENT REPORTS.
THOSE REPORTS WILL BE PROVIDED
TO YOU -- SUMMARIZING THE
CONTENT OF EVERYTHING THAT WE
HEARD -- AND I EXPECT THAT WHAT
WE MIGHT HEAR THROUGH THE
PROCESS IS THAT THERE IS A
HIGHER NEED AND THAT THERE'S
MORE INTEREST FOR RESOURCES FOR
THIS WORK.
BOB -- WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
FUNDING TO HELP A LARGE LAW AND
YOU KNOW THE THE COUNTY SET UPS
ELECTED TO DO THAT MAYBE TWENTY
OF THE FIFTY EIGHT BUT IT SEEMS
LIKE THIS WOULD DOVETAIL REALLY
WELL.
WITH THOSE COUNTIES THAT ARE
READY.
YOU KNOW UTILIZING FLOORS
LATIMES.
I'M JUST CURIOUS ONE HAVE YOU
RECEIVED ANY OPPOSITION FROM --
THE MIDDLE HEALTH COMMUNITY AND
THEY HAVE DATE IS FILED LAWSUITS
TO PREVENT THIS KIND OF FUNDING
OR WAS DISAPPROVED BY THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE THAT CENTER
BELL.
SITS ON WE'VE.
WE'VE -- EXPERIENCED A LOT OF
SUPPORT -- WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THIS.
IT'S THAT SKEWS ME AT SEVERAL OF
OUR COUNCIL.
MEETINGS OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST YEAR AND WE HAVE.
A WORKING GROUP OF A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS -- THAT
ARE GOING TO BE GUIDING THE
PROCESS AND SO ACTUALLY THIS IS
BEEN -- AT TREMENDOUSLY
SUPPORTED BY A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT ADVOCACY GROUPS
PARTICULARLY ONES THAT ARE NEW --
TO TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
COMMUNITY IN THE EXCITING PART
ABOUT THIS PROJECT IS GOING TO
BRING TOGETHER.
THE ADVOCATES FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED AND THE
ADVOCATES FOR PEOPLE WHO -- HELP
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL ILLNESS TO
WORK TOGETHER COLLABORATE A
COLLABORATIVE LEE ON MAYBE.
TOGETHER A PROPOSAL FOR
RESOURCES.
BY I'M GOING TO BEG FOR MY
COUNTY LEVEL GRANTS BUT MY MAIN
JAIL WAS THE LARGEST MENTAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH INSTITUTE IN THE
COUNTY.
OF ORANGE.
AND I'M JUST WONDERING --
COLLEAGUES AT THIS IS ENOUGH
[inaudible]
THAT.
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF STATE INMATES HAVE
MENTAL ILLNESS I WOULD ASSUME
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
WEEKS.
TRY TO FIND OUT WHAT IT WAS.
AND TO WORK WITH FAMILIES -- AND
IF THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT IS WILLING TO PROVIDE
FUNDING IN THIS THIS AREA YOU'RE
GETTING SUPPORT.
WHY AREN'T YOU ASKING FOR MORE?
I THINK THAT WE WANT TO PROVE
THAT WE CAN BE SUCCESSFUL -- AT
I KNOW I KNOW THAT LAST TIME I
WAS HERE THERE WERE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT -- YOU KNOW WE
ARE SMALL COUNCIL AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY STAFF TO FOR POSITIONS.
I THINK WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY --
TO DO REALLY GOOD WORK WITH THIS
BUT AS I MENTIONED BEFORE PART
OF THE THE DESIRE TO SPEND THE
MONEY ON A REALLY ROBUST
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND TO
PRODUCE THESE REPORTS THIS SO
THAT I CAN PROVIDE. TO YOU --
DOCUMENTATION OF THE NEED AND
THE VARIOUS DIFFERENT THINGS I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
THE COMMUNITY -- AND THEN YOU
ALL CAN DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT
YOU WANT TO PROVIDE MORE FUNDING
TO SOLVE THOSE PROBLEMS THAT
THEY'VE IDENTIFIED WHETHER IT'S
MY COUNSEL OR SOMEBODY ELSE WHO.
WHO ISSUES THOSE THOSE FUNDS
THAT'S TO ME NOT IMPORTANT I
THINK THE THE THE THE BEST THING
THAT COULD COME OUT OF THAT
PROCESS WOULD BE -- KEY
INFORMATION TO ALL OF YOU FROM
FOLKS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA --
AS TO WHAT THEY NEED RESOURCES
FOR SO IF YOU DECIDE TO GET
THOSE FUNDS. TO THE B. SEC TO
ADMINISTER OR TO THE COUNTIES TO
ADMINISTER OR FOR THE COUNCIL TO
ADMINISTER THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN REVISIT AFTER THE FIRST
YEAR OF THIS PROJECT WE EXPECT
ALL OF THOSE REPORTS TO BE --
COMPLETE BY THE END OF THIS
CALENDAR YEAR.
WELL MISS WELL TRIED I'D SAY GO
BIG GO BOLD -- THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT.
PROVIDED AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
ROOM RESOURCES BUT IT THERE
LANGUISHING THEY'RE JUST SITTING
IN BANK ACCOUNTS AND I'D LOVE TO
SEE.
A LITTLE BIT MORE GO INTO THIS
DIRECTION WHERE IT'S REALLY
NEEDED -- TO ALL MAKE A MOTION
TO APPROVE THE ITEM MADAM CHAIR
BUT CAN I DOUBLE HEADER TRIPLET
AT ON THE FLOOR HERE.
LIMON MAY I ASK A FEW QUESTIONS
AND THEN. TO A MISS WELSH BY
HADN'T INTENDED TO BEFORE BUT I
SINCE SOME OF THE THINGS YOU
RAISED IT.
REMINDING ME OF THE DISCUSSION
WHEN WE HAD THE ITEM PREVIOUSLY.
AND THE PRESSURE WILL GIVE YOU
PERMISSION TO ASK MISS WELSH
QUESTIONS THANK YOU [inaudible]
SO THIS.
AT LEAST APPROPRIATION IS --
PRIMARILY FOR RESEARCH CORRECT.
TO DO VERSUS DIRECT DELIVERY OF
SERVICES.
NOT THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT THIS
IS ACTUALLY TO DEVELOP A
COMPETITIVE BID PROCESS OKAY AND
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT A
COMPETITIVEBRIDGE PROCESS. TO
FOR THE END RESULT BEING THE END
RESULT BEING A POTENTIALLY COULD
BE DIRECT SERVICES FOR EXAMPLE
THE EXACT -- THE EXAMPLE I GAVE
YOU ABOUT -- CHILDREN WHO HAVE
INCARCERATED PARENTS WERE
LOOKING FOR PEER MENTORS OR IT
COULD BE FOR AN ORGANIZATION TO
DO MORE ADVOCACY SO FOR EXAMPLE
SOMETHING WE'VE HEARD FROM RE
ENTRY COUNCILS.
IS THAT THEY'RE REALLY
INTERESTED IN BEING A TRAIN TO
GO AND TALK TO THEIR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
ABOUT A DIFFERENT SERVICES THAT
THEY WANT.
TO THROUGH THEY PRESENT TO US
AND THAT'S PART OF THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS WE REALLY
WILL HAVE A SERIES ABOUT THIRTY
DIFFERENT QUESTIONS WE WANT TO
ASK THE COMMUNITY.
IN TERMS OF OF WHAT SHOULD BE
THE PRIORITY SHOULD THE PRIORITY
BE TRYING TO DELIVER A SERVICE
SHOULD THE PRIORITY TO BE TO
DELIVER AN A PRODUCT LIKE A TOOL
KIT.
SHOULD IT BE ACE OF AN ONGOING
SERVICE LIKE A CRISIS LINE FOR
AS WE FR THIS TO A CRISIS LINE
THAT PARENTS CAN CALL WHEN THEIR
CHILD IS -- ARRESTED AND THAT'S
REALLY FOR THE COMMUNITY TO TELL
US AND AND WE WILL BRING THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO OUR BOARD AND
IN NOVEMBER THE BOARD WILL
DETERMINE.
HOW THEY WANT TO STRUCTURE THOSE
ARE OF PEAS THEY MAY DETERMINE
BASED ON EVERYTHING WE HERE IN
THE COMMUNITY THAT THEY ONLY
WANT TO ISSUE -- A COMPETITIVE
PROCESS.
FOR I KEEP BRINGING THIS UP BUT
CHILDREN WHO HAVE INCARCERATED
PARENTS.
WHO NEED SERVICES IN THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE WE IDENTIFIED
THROUGH THAT STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
AS WELL AS THE RESEARCH PROCESS
WHEN I SEE RESEARCH LITERATURE
REVIEW KEY INFORMANT INTO
INTERVIEWS WITH EXPERTS FOCUS
GROUPS -- THAT THAT IS SUCH AN
UNMET NEED THAT IT IS THE
BIGGEST PRIORITY FOR THE FIRST
THREE YEARS OF THESE FUNDS.
THE ALLOCATION TODAY IS TO
DEVELOP THAT OUR P. NOT%
NECESSARILY DEFINED [inaudible]
THE WHATEVER ACTIVITY.
ACTUALLY IT IS TO FUND THE
ACTIVITY AND THE THE FUNDS THAT
WE HAVE USED THIS YEAR SO FAR
HAVE SUPPORTED THAT STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS WE'RE ABLE TO CARRY SOME
OF THOSE DELIVERABLES INTO AN
OVER THE SUMMER AND OF COURSE
WERE RIGHT IN OUR OF P.
OURSELVES -- IN IT AS PART OF MY
TEAM AND SO THIS REAPPROPRIATION
WILL GO DIRECTLY INTO CONTRACTS.
THEN IN THE AS FAR AS I CAN TELL
FROM THE DISCUSSION SO FAR.
THE THE SERVICES AND THE DATA
GATHERING I'D SAY OUR RESEARCH
IS [inaudible]
ON FOLKS WHO ARE ALREADY OUT OF
THE SYSTEM THEY MIGHT BE ON
PAROLE BUT THEY'RE NOT.
IN MAKES HOUSE TO NOW IN IN ONE
OF OUR FACILITIES [inaudible]
CORRECT OR TO BE HONEST WE WERE
THIS WAS NOT A B. C. P. -- AND
SO I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS WE REALLY WANT TO ASK
WHEN I SAY IT WAS AN A B. C. P.
THERE WAS AN TO M..
WE WERE LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE
AWARDED THESE FUNDS LAST YEAR AS
PART OF BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS --
AND SO THAT'S ACTUALLY ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS YOU WANT TO ASK
THERE WAS NO DIRECTION AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT IT SHOULD BE. FOR
INDIVIDUALS ONLY WHO OF ALREADY
EXITED INCARCERATION AND OR ONLY
INDIVIDUALS INSIDE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING
INCARCERATION I THINK IT WOULD
BE A CRITICAL ISSUE TO ASK THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE BOTH ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUES -- BUT
AGAIN.
I FEEL LIKE SOMEBODY ELSE
INCLUDING THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
SHOULD TELL THE COUNCIL WHAT IS
THE PRIORITY IF IT'S PEOPLE WHO
ARE HOME.
WHO'VE BEEN INCARCERATED OR WHO
ARE GREAT RISK OF RE
INCARCERATION OR EVEN INITIAL
INCARCERATION OF VERSUS PEOPLE
WHO MIGHT BE EXPERIENCING
PERSPIRATION.
I RAISE THE QUESTION BECAUSE WE
BROUGHT THIS UP IN THE PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION BUT IT'S MORE ROOM.
TO TRY TO UNDERSTAND WHY THIS IS
REALLY HOUSE IN CDC ARE.
IF IT'S IF WERE FOCUSED
PRIMARILY ON THE FOLKS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY IN A STATE FACILITY.
THEN THERE IS THERE SOME LOGIC
TO IT BEING IN CDC ARE IF IT'S
PEOPLE WHO ARE.
EITHER FAMILIES -- FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE ALREADY -- WHO ARE NO
LONGER MAYBE UNDER PAROLE BUT NO
LONGER IN A STATE FACILITY THEN
IT SEEMS LIKE THE ACTIVITY MAY
BE BETTER HOUSE?
NOT WITHIN CDC ARE. ONE OF THE
THINGS I I THINK I'VE NEGLECTED
TO DO WHEN I WAS HERE LAST TIME
WAS TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ABOUT WHO MY COUNCIL
MEMBERS ARE.
I KNOW WE SPOKE ABOUT -- YOU
KNOW MY KIND OF DIRECT CHAIN OF
COMMAND BUT I ALSO -- WORK FOR
MY COUNCIL MEMBERS MY COUNCIL
MEMBERS REPRESENT A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT LOCAL EXPERTS --
BETWEEN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEMS SO
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
PROBATION CHIEFS -- COURT JUDGES --
PEOPLE WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE IN
THE MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
AND SO IT WE REALLY OPERATE --
OUTSIDE OF THE STRUCTURE OF WHAT
IS CONSIDERED THE FOCUS OF THE
TARGET POPULATION OF CDC ARE --
AND WE SPEND OUR TIME WORKING
WITH VARIOUS DIFFERENT GROUPS
AND DEVELOPING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH LIKE THE COUNTY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
OUR SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION -- AND
THAT REALLY IS WHERE WE SPEND A
GREAT DEAL OF OUR TIME WE ALSO
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS.
REPRESENTED HONOR COUNCIL -- AND
SO WE DO A LOT OF PROJECTS WITH
THEM DIRECTLY -- SO.
I THINK I NEGLECTED TO EXPLAIN
THAT -- WHEN I WAS HERE LAST
TIME -- WELL THE SECRETARY OF
CDC OUR IS OUR CHAIR -- IT IS
THE WHOLE COUNCIL THAT MAKES
DECISIONS ABOUT.
WHERE WE SPEND OUR TIME AND
ENERGY WHAT ISSUES WE SHOULD
FOCUS ON X. ADDRESS -- I
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE VICE
CHAIR SENTIMENT ABOUT -- THAT
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE NEEDS THAT
POTENTIALLY COULD DESERVE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
I WOULD BE HESITANT TO DO SO YES
WITHOUT -- SOME CLARITY AS TO
WHAT TIME [inaudible]
IT.
WHAT DIRECTION WE GIVE IT WHAT
OBJECTIVES -- BUT I THINK.
IN THIS MAY BE SOMETHING WHY.
COLLEAGUES ARE WILLING DURING
THE INTERIM THAT WE MIGHT WANT
TO HAVE.
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING ABOUT
BECAUSE I THINK MOST OF S
REALIZE THAT [inaudible]
TEARS -- THAT HAVING A LARGE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WITH.
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
IN OUR STATE PRISONS AND WHO ARE
THEY ARE PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF
LACK OF SIFT AT APPROPRIATE
TREATMENT FOR THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
IS NOT A BENEFIT TO EITHER A
PRISON -- SYSTEM OR TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS.
AND THAT IF.
GETTING SMARTER ABOUT THAT.
IS -- WOULD BENEFIT EVERYONE ALL
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE WE'VE DONE SOME BUT NOT A
LOT.
SO [inaudible]
MAYBE WILL.
I WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION YOU
MADE WILL ACT ON THIS AND IF --
WE WILL HAVE TO DECIDE TODAY BUT
MY COLLEAGUES ARE INTERESTED
MAKE ABOUT HAVING -- SOME
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS IN THE
INTRO.
YEAH WE WOULD BE.
THRILLED TO HELP PUT THAT ON
CENTERVILLE [inaudible]
SO -- THE HEALTH SERVICES
ACKERMAN THE COMMISSION I KNOW
THE PROCESS YOU'RE GOING TO GET
A THREE YEAR THIS A THREE YEAR.
PROPOSAL WITH -- RENEWABLES IF
YOU WANT TO CALL IT THAT.
AND THEY HAVE A PERFORMANCE
EVALUATION PROCESS.
IT'S PRETTY STANDARD YOU KNOW SO
YOU KNOW WHICH ARE YOU HAVE.
TO CHAU WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO
REAP WHAT THE RESULTS ARE GOING
TO BE -- AND THAT'S ALL PART OF
YOUR APPLICATION WHEN YOU
ORIGINALLY APPLIED FOR THIS
RIGHT.
SO -- YOU YOU -- THE MONEY IS
HANDLED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS THE QUESTION I WOULD
HAVE IS.
HOW MUCH MONEY FROM THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES -- X..
DOES THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTION GET AND WORLD SERIES
SPENDING THAT MONEY. TO SPEND
ANY MONEY FROM -- IN YOU GET
MONEY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF OR
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT.
OTHER IN THIS PARTICULAR BRAND
OR OTHER MONEY SPENT ON THANKS
LEAVE THAT THIS IS THE ONLY
PLACE WE SPENT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT FUNDING PROP SIXTY
THREE THIS IS THE ACTUALLY WE
THE COUNCIL ARE THE ONLY.
ENTITY WITHIN CDC ARE THAT
RECEIVES ANY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT FUNDING WE DO
RECEIVE SOME ADDITIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT FUNDING FOR
OF FOR A POSITION FOR A
RESEARCHER.
AND THAT IS FOR A MEDICAL
UTILIZATION PROJECT WITH DH CS
WE WE LOOK AT HOW PEOPLE EXITING
INCARCERATIONS SPECIFICALLY CDC
ARE UTILIZED THEIR MEDI CAL
BENEFITS -- AND THAT IS OF
FUNDED BY THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT AND SO -- WE WE ARE
LAUNCHING INTO OUR NEXT YEAR OF
RESEARCH WITH THAT PARTICULAR
PROJECT AND WE'LL BE FOCUSING ON
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
I KNOW THAT'S GOING TO BE A
SUBJECT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT NOW SO YOU.
WE'LL BE LOOKING AT HOW I WILL
DEVELOP A BASS LINE AND THEN WE
WILL START LOOKING AT HOW PEOPLE
LEADING CDC ARE UTILIZED THEIR
SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT BENEFIT
IN THE COMMUNITY.
YEAH OKAY.
BY TAKE A THINKER ON FOR I GET
OUT OF THIS YOUR YOUR PUNCH THE
KIND OF CONTRACTS.
THE MONEY WILL GO TO WILL BE.
HI THERE APPEARS SO POOR
[inaudible]
SYSTEMS SO TO HELP WITH --
PEOPLE.
IN A TRANSITION AND MAYBE --
HAVE OTHER GOALS LIKE. ONE OF I
I KNOW ONE OF THE BIG GOALS --
IN THE MIDDLE HEALTH SERVICES
ACT.
FOR PEOPLE INVOLVED IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
RE CONNECTION WITH THEIR
FAMILIES.
AND FAMILY -- UNIFICATION TRYING
TO KEEP THE PERSON CONNECTED
WITH THE FAMILY SO THEY HAVE.
A SUPPORT SYSTEM WHEN THEY LEAVE.
IF THIS SPECIALLY IF THEY HAVE A
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS THEY HAVE
TO HAVE THE CONNECTION SO --
HAVING THE PIER HERE KIND OF
SUPPORT [inaudible]
PROGRAMS -- IS WORD OTHER PARTS
OF THE UNITED STATES HAVE DONE
FOR THAT -- AND A SURPLUS KIND
OF PROGRAM SO.
GENERALLY -- SIR MORE LAX
CORRECT IN THAT THIS IS.
WE'RE TO TRY THERE'S GOING TO BE
MORE THERE'S ALREADY A BILL TO
AND PERFORMANCE MONITORING.
GOT A REPORT BACK SYSTEM.
ON THE EXPENDITURE OF OF THE
BILL HELPS SERVICE DOLLARS FOR
THOSE SO.
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED WE COULD.
TALK ABOUT THAT IN THE FUTURE.
AFTER THEY GET STARTED OR IF YOU
WANTED TO YOU KNOW.
HELLO THIS -- I'M LOOKING AT THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT YOU'RE NOT GOING.
TO YOUR SUPPORT PROGRAMS AREN'T
THAT EXPENSIVE BUT ON THE OTHER
HAND I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAN BE --
COVERD WITH THIS AMOUNT OF
MONEY.
MAN I WRITE WITH A PROBABLY
WOULD THINK THAT'S KIND OF A THE
SLIM.
THEN -- BUDGET FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT IT COULD BE LIKE
LOOKED AT AS A MORE OF CAIRO A
PHASE IN KIND OF THING.
YOU ARE LOOKING THAT WAY MORE OF
A MULTI YEAR PHASE AND YOU
WANTED THESE KIND OF PROGRAMS --
CONNECTION WITH FAMILY IN TERMS
OF MIL ILLNESS IS PROBABLY ONE
OF THE BEST THINGS YOU CAN DO.
TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
WITH MEL MENTALLY ILL OFFENDERS
IS TO HAVE SOMEBODY THERE TO
HELP THEM.
RATHER THAN HAVING THE HOMELESS.
AND THAT'S WHERE ARE HOMELESS
POPULATION COMES FROM PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SOMEBODY IN THE THEY BECOME
HOMELESS CHANNELS SO.
THE NAME RE A FAN AND THEN THEY
GET INTO THE SYSTEM AGAIN.
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT KIND OF
RECYCLE OVER AND OVER.
SO I THINK I THINK -- LOOK INTO
THIS OF THAT WAY WOULD BE.
APPROPRIATE I DON'T KNOW.
HOW WE WANT TO DISCUSS THIS
ISSUE BUT I THINK IT'S A
[inaudible]
IT'S TO ME IT SERVICE -- CONCEPT
IT'S BEEN USE OTHER PLACES THAT
SIMPLY IS SUCCESSFUL.
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF.
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY WE'RE HAVING
HERE IS REALLY GOOD -- SCRATCH
THE SURFACE OR MAKE A BIG IMPACT
I DON'T KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE YOU
PROBABLY HAVE TO TARGET THIS
MONEY SOMEWHERE.
A LITTLE BIT.
SO THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS.
CENTER MORE LUCK THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR -- I'M.
I'M NOT A A PRE MED MAJOR I WAS
BUSINESS MAJOR -- BUT IN ORANGE
COUNTY WHEN I WAS SUPERVISOR WE
HAD.
THE SCHIZOPHRENIC HOMELESS YOUNG
MAN -- TRAGICALLY KILLED.
OUT IN A POLICING COUNTER.
AND IT WAS IRONIC BECAUSE HIS
FATHER WAS A POLICE OFFICER TO
AND IT WAS.
A BIG.
A BIG DEAL KELLY THOMAS SORT OF
BECAME.
I BECAUSE FOR ME TO DO A LOT
MORE RESEARCH ON MENTAL HEALTH.
AND LAWRENCE Là IN GETTING
ACQUAINTED WITH GERALD STEINBERG
AND DOING SB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE IN.
TRYING TO GET SOME FUNDING FOR
THAT AND AND SO I'M NOT UP TO
THE LEVEL OF A KNOWLEDGE SAID
SENATOR BELL IS AS THE CHAIRMAN
OF OUR MENTAL HEALTH CAUCUS --
BUT I'M TRYING A LITTLE BIT AT A
TIME AND AND RIGHT NOW I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
LETTERMAN PETROUS ACT SHORT ACT
LETTERMAN LPS.
AND IN THE MORE I READ THE MORE
DISAPPOINTED AND WORRIED I AM --
IT SEEMS TO HAVE -- NOT BEEN THE
RIGHT SOLUTION BY TAKING SO MANY.
INDIVIDUALS OUT OF INSTITUTIONS
IN THE LATE SEVENTIES.
IT WAS A BILL THAT WAS A
DEMOCRAT BILL BUT IT WAS SIGNED
BY RONALD REAGAN.
BUT THESE INDIVIDUALS REMOVED
OUT OF THE INSTITUTIONS AND THEY
WENT TO THE STREETS AND THEN
THEY WENT.
AND BECAME INCARCERATED SO NOW
THEY YOUR WE'RE TAKING CARE OF
THEM IN A DIFFERENT.
INSTITUTION AND SO.
I I WHEN I WHEN I SAW THIS ITEM
I I THOUGHT THIS IS GREAT
REFUSING SOME OF THE IMAGE AS A
FUNDING.
FOR THOSE ARE INCARCERATED OR
RELATED TO THOSE ARE
INCARCERATED PARENTS CERTAINLY
NEED SUPPORT GROUPS.
AS WELL WHEN YOU KNOW YOU JUST
NEED ONE FRIEND IS A I WAS
DRIVING DOWN TESTABLE OF ART I
SAW MY DAUGHTER FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN TWO YEARS.
YOU KNOW YOU START TO REALIZE
THIS GUY'S A DOCTOR.
IN ANSWER ALL MY GOODNESS.
WHAT'S GOING ON IF YOU START TO
APPRECIATE THAT FAMILIES NEED TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S GOING ON AS
WELL AND AND SO.
MAYBE YOU HAVE THE NOSE UNDER
THE TENT I WAS KIND OF SAN I'D
LIKE TO GET THE WHOLE CAMEL.
INTO THAT.
TEN BECAUSE THIS IS FOR THE REAL
MEAT IS IN THAT AND SOMEHOW WE
CAN GET THE MAP MHSAA -- TO TO
HELP IN THIS AREA YOU BECAUSE
YOU'RE.
YOU'RE TAKING CARE OF SO MANY OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS AND I'M.
SO FOR THE PHASE IN IS FINE BUT
THE NEED IS NOW -- I'VE A A I
CAN GO THROUGH A DAY WITHOUT
SOMEONE TALKING ABOUT THE
HOMELESS SITUATION.
A LAST NIGHT I WAS WATCHING THE
NEWS HERE LOCALLY IN
SOMEONE FROM THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY SAID YEAH WE HAD A
MAJOR CORPORATION I WAS GONNA
MOVE TO SACRAMENTO.
AND THEN THEY SAID ONE NIGHT
HAVE IT'S GOING TO A KINGS GAME.
THEY WENT TO THE KINGS GAME AND
THEN WHEN THEY LEFT THIS ALL
THESE HOMELESS PEOPLE WALKING
AROUND THEY SAID.
WE CAN PUT OUR COMPANY HERE
[inaudible]
THE FACT.
THAT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME EVER
TO STORY OF THAT NATURE.
SO AS TO THERE'S A WE'VE GOT A
WE GOT TO GET MORE AGGRESSIVE
WITH MHSAA -- AND SO I'D LOVE TO
DO A HEARING I'D LOVE.
TO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO AN
AUDIT ON THE L. P. -- AS A THE
ACTIVE YOUNG I'M I'M I'M NOT
HAPPY WITH WHAT I'M DOING WITH
MY OWN INDEPENDENT RESEARCH I'M
NOT WHAT I'M FINDING IS VERY
DISTURBING AND AND AND I'M GOING
BACK TO THE LATE SEVENTIES
EIGHTIES -- AND AND SO THERE'S A
LOT WE CAN DO AND THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME DUMP IT ALL ON YOUR
PLATE.
MADAM CHAIR -- BUT THAT'S WHY
OUR PROGRAM INTRIGUED BY THIS
ITEM THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME
PULL IT AND THANK YOU.
FOR LET ME TRY.
TO DOUBLE IT UP [inaudible]
TOTALLY.
SENATOR BILL I THINK IT'S WORTH
MORE DISCUSSION AND ALSO ON THIS
COMMITTEE -- GROUPS ARE MORE
LIKE -- THE MIDDLE ILL.
PART OF THE CORRECTIONS
DEPARTMENT IS ONE OF THEBIGGEST
COST DRIVERS IN OUR BUDGET
INCREASE IN THIS.
AREA SO.
SINCE IT IS SUCH A HUGE COST
DRIVER IN TERMS OF THE COST OF
PROVIDING -- CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SERVICES CENTER CORRECTIONS
DEPARTMENT.
IT SHOULD BE ONE OF THE MAIN
FOCUSES OF THIS COMMITTEE.
MY OPINION BECAUSE IT IS COSTING
IT THE BUDGET INCREASES.
WELL IN ANSWER WHY ARE WE HAVING
INCREASES WHEN THE POPULATION
[inaudible]
OF THE INMATE POPULATION IS
EITHER STABLE OR GOING DOWN.
WELLS BECAUSE OF THE HIGHER
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE THAT REQUIRE.
TREATMENT -- YOU KNOW OTHER
FACTORS LIKE AGING BUT WE'RE
GOING TO FIND OUT A FEW MINUTES
BUT YOU KNOW.
THE MENTAL ILLNESS PART HAS
NEVER BEEN.
IN A COMPREHENSIVE WAY ANALYZE
IN TERMS OF HOW WHAT KIND OF
ACTIONS WE CAN TAKE.
TO ATTACK THE COST DRIVERS THAT
WE HAVE HERE THE COST INCREASED
DRIVER.
YOUR YOU HAVE TO GO AFTER THOSE
POSH DRIVERS.
FIND OUT WHAT YOU CAN DO.
SO FROM OF THEY JUST DID A
SURVEY AND THEY FOUND THAT.
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO HAS THE
MOST -- BEING BILLIONAIRES PER
PER CAPITA.
AND SO THE MILLIONAIRES AND MY
DISTRICT OR SAND WHAT AM I
GETTING FOR MY 1%.
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
BILLIONAIRE'S SAM CISCO ARE
SAYING BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO HAVE
APPS.
TO FIGURE OUT WHERE NOT TO WALK.
YOU KNOW SO.
WE'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING.
I THINK I THINK WE NEED TO NOT
BE DOING PHASE INS WE NEED TO BE
DOING [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
AND IF THE THE THE PROP SIXTY
THREE OR IF WITH ALL THE IPOS
ARE GOING THIS YEAR IT SEEMS
LIKE WE'RE GOING TO MAYBE HAVE A
LITTLE.
BUMPER CROP SO WE SHOULD BE
FIGURING OUT QUICKLY WHAT TO DO
WITH THOSE FUNDS.
SO ARE VERY.
THIS WAS A IMPORTANT WILL NEED A
DISCUSSION.
WELL IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY.
GIVE US A ROADMAP YET WE
CERTAINLY -- CAN GIVE IT MORE
TIME WHEN WE'RE NOT UNDER THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PRESSURE OF
ADOPTED THE BUDGET BY JUNE
FIFTEENTH BUT ALL TAKE THE
MOTION NOW TO PROOF AS BUDGETED
AS SENATOR MORE LACK.
HAVE MADE AND WE WILL.
DEFINITELY -- FIGURE OUT.
NEXT STEPS WHEN WE ARE PASS THIS
PERIOD.
OKAY SO LET'S HAVE A ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER BY SENATOR
MORLOCK SENATOR BELL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THAT -- ITEM THAT ISSUE FIVE IS
APPROVED AND WE WILL NOW.
GO -- TO ISSUE.
SEVEN AND THAT IS UNDER AGAIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION IT IS THE
RECEIVERS.
MEDICAL CLASSIFICATION MODEL
UPDATE.
AND IT IS -- TO APPROPRIATE --
TWENTY SEVEN POINT NINE MILLION.
AND A HUNDRED AND TWO POSITIONS
IN. TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TO
INCREASE STAFFING LEVELS FOR
HEALTH CARE OPERATIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA'S PRISON
SYSTEM.
WE HAVE OUR RECEIVER HERE AND
SOME OTHER FOLKS WE INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES YOU CAN PERCENT THE
ITEM.
GOOD MORNING -- SYSTEM TO BE
DIRECTED TO WIN READER FOR C.
CCS -- I ALSO HAVE -- PART
COUNCIL RECEIVER IN MY HAND WITH
ME DOCTOR WHEN THEY CAME IN ON
THE ITEM NUMBER -- SEVEN THIS IS --
AN ITEM THAT REFLECTS AN UPDATE
TO THE MODEL THAT WE USE -- OF
FOR DETERMINING NUMBER OF
MEDICAL POSITIONS -- IT IS A
MODEL THAT WAS INITIALLY ADOPTED
ABOUT FIVE OR SIX YEARS AGO.
I'M WORRIED TRYING TO BE A MODEL
OUR STAFFING BASED UPON THE
ACUITY LEVEL OF OUR A PATIENT
POPULATION -- WE HAVE SINCE THEM
ON HAVE.
I'M MORE EXPERIENCE WITH -- HOW
WELL THAT MODEL HAS WORKED ON
SOME OF ITS SHORTCOMINGS --
WE'VE LEARNED MORE FROM HAVING
THE ELECTRONIC MEDICAL RECORD
THAT IS HELP US BETTER
UNDERSTAND.
OF THE NEEDS OF OUR POPULATION.
AND THE THE THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL ESSENTIALLY MY
RECOGNIZES THAT WE ARE
UNDERSTAFFED IN A FEW AREAS.
IN PARTICULAR -- BUT WE DID NOT
A WHEN WE INITIALLY - BUT FOR
THE MODEL FIVE YEARS AGO -- HAVE
IN THE JUST ONE FORM OF FEMALE
PATIENTS.
AND IT'S WELL RECOGNIZED THE
THERE IS A GREATER A STAFFING
NEED A TO DEAL WITH A FEMALE
POPULATION ON THE MAIL -- SO WE
NEEDED TO INCREASE ON ALLOCATION
FOR OF THE FEMALE ON
INSTITUTIONS.
WE ALSO DO NOT -- TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
PATIENTS WHO ARE DISABLED.
AND WE DID NOT APPROPRIATELY
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE AGING OF
THE PRISON POPULATION ON INMATES
OVER -- FIFTY IN AND BASED UPON
NEW INFORMATION THAT WE LOOKED
AT IN THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS WE
DECIDED WE NEEDED TO HAVE AN
INCREASE.
IN THOSE OUT LOCATIONS.
THAT WAS THE FIRST IN A PRIMARY
CARE SERVICES SECOND WE REALIZE
THAT -- WE HAVE WITH OUR AGING
POPULATION IN PARTICULAR A LOT
OF SERIOUSLY ILL PATIENTS WHO
HAVE VERY COMPLEX MEDICAL NEEDS --
AND WE NOW HAVE REALIZE WE NEED
TO HAVE -- AN INCREASE IN
ALLOCATIONS FOR THOSE PATIENTS.
AND THEN -- FINALLY -- ANCILLARY
STAFF WHO SUPPORT OUR PROVIDERS --
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
ELECTRONIC MEDICAL RECORD AND
WORKLOAD ADJUSTMENTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT ARE DRIVING THE NEED
FOR A CHANGE IN -- OUR ANCILLARY
STAFF -- SO THE THAT'S THE BASIS
OF FOR THE THE REQUEST.
FOR AN ADJUSTMENT TO THE MEDICAL
CLASSIFICATION MODEL.
I KNOW THE LA -- SO ORIGINALLY.
OR NOT ORIGNALLY THAT'S AN
INACCURATE WHEN WE WERE FIRST --
DEVELOPING THE AGENDA.
FOR THIS HEARING WE WERE GONNA
HAVE A DISCUSSION ON THIS
HOWEVER WE ARE NOW HAVING A
DISCUSSION CLEARLY BUT WE HAD --
STAFF NINE GOING THROUGH.
THE ITEMS -- BECAUSE THIS IS AN
ITEM FROM THE RECEIVER.
AND IN SOME RESPECTS DUE TO THE
COURT ORDERED THE RECEIVER HAS
THE ABILITY TO TO ACT ON SUCH
THINGS -- INDEPENDENT OF OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S APPROVAL
[inaudible]
AND THE PAST INFORMATION BASED
ON THE STEPPING ALLOCATION
SYSTEMS THAT WERE PUT INTO PLACE.
HAVE NOW.
SHOWN AS SAID THE RECEIVER'S
INDICATED AS A NOW -- GIVEN US A
BETTER BETTER INFORMATION ABOUT
THE POPULATION WE'RE SERVING.
AND THEIR NEEDS AND IDENTIFIED
WHICH I THINK MOST OF US
PROBABLY COULD'VE WITHOUT EVEN.
NECESSARILY HAVING THE DATA TO
KNOW THAT OUR POPULATION IS
GETTING OLDER.
AND THAT -- IT JUST AS THE
GENERAL POPULATION.
THE HEALTH NEEDS ARE MEDICAL
REQUIREMENTS INCREASE.
AND SO I DO TO THAT -- WE
ELECTED TO PUT IT ON OTER ONLY.
BUT THE LA -- HAD -- SOME
OPINIONS SO I'M GONNA LET LA --
EXPRESS THOSE AND CLEARLY SINCE
WE PULL THAT WE CAN HAVE A
DISCUSSION NOW.
GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU LOU KOOSH MORROW THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
MEDICATION CLASSIFICATION MAHLER
CURRENTLY IN PLACE DOES TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THE CUTIE AND
POPULATION OF THE INMATE
POPULATION.
OUR CONCERNS ARE.
WHETHER THAT DATA IT IS
SUFFICIENT TO ADJUST THAT MODEL
CURRENTLY -- WE NOTE THAT THE
COURT YOUR EXPENDITURES FOR
MEDICAL CARE HAVE EXCEEDED THE
AMOUNT THAT THE MEDICATION
PROSECUTION MODEL WOULD HAVE
PROVIDED.
HOWEVER EMPIRE YOURS THE AMOUNT
RIGHT IT HAS TO BE SUFFICIENT.
WE ALSO NOTE THAT THAT UPDATED
DATA PRESENT IN THE PROPOSAL IS
GENERALLY OVER A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME.
ON TO THAT SHOP AT THE TIME THAT
THAT ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD
SYSTEM HAS BEEN IN PLACE.
WE RECOMMEND APPROVING THE
FUNDING ON A ONE TIME BASIS TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE CURRENT
YOUR AND ABOUT YOUR AND ALLOW
TIME.
TO COLLECT MORE DATA AND ANALYZE
WHETHER THE ADJUSTMENTS BEING
MADE OF WOOD SO -- SUFFICIENTLY
MEET THE MEDICAL NEEDS OF THE
POPULATION AND DO SO ON A
SUSTAINABLE WAY ALL OF THE OTHER.
DIFFERENT ADJUSTMENT WOULD BE
NEEDED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO THE RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE
TO DO A ONE TIME ONLY VERSUS ON
GOING.
YES THAT'S CORRECT AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THOSE POSITIONS
COULD BE HARD TO FILL HOWEVER WE
NOTE THAT.
IN THE PAST THE RECEIVER HAS
MADE UP FOR VACANCIES THROUGH
USING REGISTRY SERVICES TO
PROVIDE SERVICES -- YEAH ON MY
WHEN YOU WERE.
SO VERY COMMONLY WE HAVE.
ITEMS BEFORE US THAT ARE
APPROVING ONE TIME OR PROVING
TEMPORARY.
AND NOT IN ALL CASES BUT VERY
OFTEN THOSE ARE FINE -- FOR
POSITIONS THAT ARE FAR LESS
TECHNICAL THAN HERE HERE WERE
ACTUALLY -- IT SEEMS DIFFICULT.
WELL I APPRECIATE THE LA SHOWS --
WHAT THEY'VE RAISED ABOUT IN THE
PAST WE WEREN'T EXCEEDING THE
FUNDING ALLOCATION BUT WE DID
THIS YEAR?
THAT RATHER THAN JUST ASSUMING
WE ALWAYS WELL.
ON THE OTHER HAND.
THESE ARE NOT POSITIONS THAT ARE
EASY TO FILL IN JEST ESPECIALLY
FOR SAYING OKAY SIR -- FOR
TWELVE MONTHS ONLY.
AND IT COULD BE THAT.
THEY DON'T EVEN GET FILLED RIGHT
AWAY AND SO THEN HOW DO WE EVEN
MAKE THE ADJUSTMENT SO.
BUT I'M HAPPY TO HAVE THE
RECEIVER COMMENT AND THEN SEE IF
MY COLLEAGUES SEVENTY COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MA'AM SURE I AGREE
WITH YOU THESE ME VERY DIFFICULT
FILL ON A LIMITED TERM BASIS --
SOME OF THESE WILL BE IMPOSSIBLE
FOR ALL.
ARM WHICH YOU PUT ME IN A
POSITION OF HAVING TO THE SIDE
WORLD WHAT DO I DO AND THE WHITE.
EXPAND THE USE OF REGISTRY ONE
HOW DO I RESPOND TO THAT SO I I
THINK A ONE YEAR FUNDING OF
SIMPLY FOR THESE TYPE OF
POSITIONS DOESN'T WORK -- I
WOULD NOTED -- IN ADDITION -- IN
THE IF THIS GIVES APPROVED OF
THE WAY TO THE AND ACTUALLY GET
BUDGET SAVINGS.
IS TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF WOMEN
WHO ARE INCARCERATED.
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE DYING IN PRISON -- AFTER
HAVING GONE THROUGH EXPENSIVE
MEDICAL TREATMENT.
OF FIGURE OUT HOW -- TO STOP
HAVING THEM OF THESE MOST
VULNERABLE AND EXPENSE OF PEOPLE
IN PRISON -- I THINK THAT
ACTUALLY ON IT IS A BETTER
SOLUTION.
THEM -- HAVING US TRY TO DO THIS
ON A ONE TIME BASIS.
ON THAT NOTE.
LET US LET US -- OKAY LET'S DO
SOME CONJECTURE.
LET'S SAY WE WERE.
TO RE VISIT OUR MEDICAL PAROLE
ON OUR ELDERLY PAROLE --
POLICIES WHICH WERE DESIGNED. TO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAD -- PEOPLE
IN PRISON THAT WERE VERY
ADVANCED STAGES AND THAT ALSO IN
MANY CASES WERE -- COMPUTER
THERE MANY OF MEDICAL CONDITION
INCAPACITATED SO FROM A POINT OF
VIEW OF CONCERNED ABOUT PUBLIC
SAFETY IN LITTLE TO NO POSITION
TO BE A THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
HOWEVER WERE OF A HIGH HIGH COST
TO THE STATE BY KEEPING THEM IN
THE WAY THAT.
THAT THEY ARE CURRENTLY HOUSE SO
LET'S ON THAT CONJECTURE -- IN
ASSUME THAT WE'VE MADE THOSE
POLICIES MORE ROBUST.
AND LET'S SAY THOSE WITHIN THREE
YEARS WE ARE TO MAKE THOSE
POLICIES MORE ROBUST AND THEY
WERE STARTING TO BE IMPLEMENTED.
WOULD DOUBT ARGUES TO APPROVE
ALL OF THESE POSITIONS ARE
PERMANENTLY AS YOU'VE SUGGESTED
SO WHAT I'M ASKING IS GIVEN.
THAT SO.
SO I'M DOING VARIATION NOW SO LA --
SAID DO IT ONE TIME ONLY I THINK
WE'VE REYES THAT ONE TIME ONLY
IS DIFFICULT FOR THE NATURE OF
THESE TYPE OF POSITIONS.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT IN THE
PAST WE DIDN'T NEED AS MANY
EXCEPT FOR THIS YEAR SO.
IS THERE A HYBRID HERE ARE THERE
A FEW LESS POSITIONS.
POTENTIALLY THAT WE NEED FOR
LOOKING AT THE FACT THAT.
IT WAS ONLY THIS ONE YEAR.
THAT WE EXCEEDED OUR THE
EXPENSES EXCEEDED OUR ALLOCATION --
MANAGER THE IF IT TURNS OUT THAT --
THERE ARE REDUCTIONS.
OF REDUCTIONS IN STAFF WILL
HAPPEN AUTOMATICALLY -- AS PART
OF THE ON A REGULAR POPULATION
ADJUSTMENT PROCESS.
SO -- YOU'RE PROVING PERMANENT
POSITIONS BOUGHT THEIR SUBJECTS.
TO OUR POPULATION REDUCTIONS SO
IT IT NATURALLY WILL HAPPEN THAT
THERE WOULD BE A REDUCTION IN
STAFF IF IT TURNS OUT THAT.
WE ARE ABLE TO REDUCE SOME OF OF
THE THESE.
WORKLOAD DRIVING POPULATIONS.
AND IN TERMS OF WHETHER I THINK
THOSE WHO YOU KNOW.
IS IT HALF OF THESE THAT WE
ACTUALLY NEED NO I THINK WE
ACTUALLY NEED -- EVERYTHING THAT
WERE ASKING FOR HERE
[inaudible]
HELLO. ONE OPTION IF WE WANT TO
GO FORWARD WITH APPROVING THIS
IS CHANGE THE METHODOLOGY WOULD
BE TO REQUIRE REPORTING ON
ACTUAL USAGE RELATIVE TO WHAT
THE MODEL IS PROVIDING.
THIS WOULD ALLOW US TO IDENTIFY
IF THERE IS A MISMATCH IN THE
FUTURE AND MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
NECESSARY.
THAT'S A GOOD SUGGESTION.
SENATOR BOB.
DOLE.
THIS IS BASED ON THE POPULATION
RISE OF THESE KIND OF PATIENTS
CORRECT.
THE ADDED STAFF THAT YOU'RE A
WELL THE END OF STAFF IS
ACTUALLY BECAUSE WE PREVIOUSLY
DID NOT ACCOUNT FOR THE HEAVIER
WORKLOAD. FOR WOMEN YEAH -- BUT
YES IT'S BASICALLY ONCE IT'S
BUILT INTO THE MODEL YEAR OF
OPERATION THE POPULATION IS
GOING UP -- SO WHEN THE
POPULATION GOES DOWN WHAT
HAPPENS YOU LIMITED THESE
POSITIONS.
OF WHAT'S WHAT'S THE SITUATION --
HOW HOW WOULD THAT BE AN?
LOCAL USUALLY -- THE MEDICAL
SYSTEM WILL HAVE LIKE
FLUCTUATIONS IN.
SPECIALLY LIKE AN INPATIENT I
DON'T KNOW WHY YOU'RE HAVING
LIKE A MORE.
IMPATIENT -- ARE YOU LOOKING AT
Y. EIGHT MORE DAYS PER PATIENT
IN THE IN PATIENT.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON THERE --
AND SEEMS LIKE YOURS NO CONTROL
OR AB KENTUCKY.
THAT'S AN AREA I WOULD I WOULD
WONDER ABOUT.
WHEN I SAW THAT I SO WELL HE'S
GOT MORE?
LONGER STAYS IN THE IN PATIENT
WHAT'S GOING ON THERE THE COSTS
MONEY.
SO WHY WHY IS THAT HAPPENING.
WELL IN TERMS OF PROCESS.
YEAH I'M INTO AND GET SENT TO
THE NEXT ITEM BUT I'M I'M ASKING
THEM NOW SO YOU.
YEAH IN MY EYES I'M SUSPICIOUS
WHY THAT IN PATIENTS GOING UP.
IN TERMS OF THE POSITION
REDUCTIONS -- WE WOULD DO THAT
THROUGH ATTRITION OR FIND
ANOTHER VACANCIES -- THE LAYOFF
PROCESSES ARE OUR LAST OPTION
WHEN IT COMES TO POSITION
REDUCTIONS AND NORMALLY WITH OUR
POPULATION REDUCTIONS ITS USE ON
THE MARGIN WE CAN ABSORB THOSE.
OR THESE TEMPORARY INCREASES OR
THE YOU LOOK LIKE A MORE --
LEVELING OFFER WHICH STORY --
WELL I I SUSPECT IS A LEVELING
OFF THE IF IF THIS CHANGE TO THE
MODELS APPROVED WE FILL THESE-POSITIONS AND THE POPULATION I
DON'T.
KNOW I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
POPULATION PROJECTIONS ARE I
DON'T THINK THERE [inaudible]
INCREASING SUBSTANTIALLY
NARROWER BUT IT WOULD DOWN THE
THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING IF THINGS
ARE GOING DOWN.
THEY ARE LIKELY WONDERING THEN
IT WOULD DEPEND ON ARE YOU
BRINGING DOWN I KNOW WHICH
POPULOUS CORRECT.
YEAH YOU'RE BRINGING DOWN THE
HEALTHY YOUNG GUYS -- THAT HELPS
A LITTLE BIT BUT IT DOESN'T HELP
ALL THAT MUCH SO IT DEPENDS ON
THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE
POPULATION REDUCTION CAN FOCUS
ON THE IN PATIENT PART OF IT
YEAH LIKE -- LET ME HAVE WIRE
WHERE -- YOU HAVING MORE LONGER
STAYS IN THE IN PATIENT OR MAY
HAVE DOC KANE AND DO YOU CONTROL
THAT I MEAN HOW DO YOU CAN.
YOU KNOW LIKE THAT'S ONE OF THE
PRIMARY THINGS HOSPITAL WHO'S
THE THE HAVE PROTOCOLS TO
CONTROL YOUR INPATIENT.
SO WHAT'S GOING ON AND I THINK.
OVER A CANE AND I THINK PART OF
WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO A
SENATOR BAIL IS ACTUALLY A
PATIENTS WHO ARE.
ADMITTED TO OUR OUTSIDE
COMMUNITY HOSPITALS THERE WE ARE
SEEN ON ALTHOUGH THE ADMISSIONS
ARE ACTUALLY NOT GOING UP AT THE
SAME RATE WE ARE SEEN LONGER
LENGTH OF STAY.
AND ACTUALLY THAT'S RELATEDTO
THAT TWO THINGS BUT REALLY IT
REALLY BOILS DOWN -- TO THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE PATIENT A CASE
MIX -- ONE OF THE POPULATIONS
THAT STRIVING THAT IS ACTUALLY
OUR PATIENTS ARE GETTING OLDER
AND SICKER SO IF YOU LOOK AT OUR
STANCE FOR HIGH RISK ONE INTO
PATIENTS.
THAT IS GOING ON UP AND THAT IS
COMMENSURATE WITH AN INCREASE IN
THE ADMISSIONS TO OUR COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL.
THERE'S ALSO KIND OF A SECOND
GROUP OF OF PATIENTS WHO ARE
REALLY NOT -- WHO WEREN'T AS
COMPLEX -- PRIOR TO
HOSPITALIZATION BUT THIS IS
ACTUALLY RELATED TO THE INCREASE
IN TRAUMA THAT WERE SEEN IN
INCREASES IN -- OVERDOSES AND
INFECTIONS WERE ACTUALLY RELATED
TO SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER ON SO
THOSE TWO DIFFERENT PATIENT
POPULATIONS ARE DRIVING THE
INCREASE IN ADMISSIONS BUT EVEN
MORE IMPORTANTLY
DISPROPORTIONATELY.
THEY'RE DRIVING THE INCREASED
LENGTH OF STAY IN THE COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL AND I WILL SAY THAT ARE
WE WE TRACK VERY CLOSELY -- WHEN
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR PATIENTS TO
BE DISCHARGED AND PATIENTS ARE
DISCHARGED -- BY AND LARGE WHEN
THEY NEED TO BE FROM THE
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL WE CALL IT
ADMINISTRATIVE BAD DAYS AND WE
HAVE VERY LOW NUMBERS OF THAT.
OKAY AND SO CENTER WE ACTUALLY
DO HAVE -- A YUBA UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT TYPE SYSTEMS THAT
RIGHT AS YOU CAN TELL KEEP TRACK
PRETTY CLOSELY OF OF THESE SORT
OF ISSUES.
THE DO YOU HAVE -- NO HEALTH
OUTCOMES MEASUREMENTS.
SO YES YOU'RE SAYING THE
PATIENTS ARE GET ANY BETTER SO
WHAT'S YOUR STRATEGY ON HEALTH
OUTCOMES THAT. TO MAKE YOU KNOW
IS THERE IS THERE A STRATEGY ON
NOT.
WELL FOR YOUR HEALTH OKAY WE
CERTAINLY WANT IF YOU LOOK AT ON
IN TERMS OF DEATHS.
EVERYWHERE EXCEPT ON OVERDOSE --
WHAT WE HAVE REDUCE DEATHS OF
THE DEATH RATES ASSOCIATE OR
DOES IT SHOULD ON A LITTLE BIT
OVERDOSES OF GONE UP
SUBSTANTIALLY -- ON OTHER SORTS
OF CONDITIONS THAT WE WOULD
TYPICALLY.
OF A WAR WE HAVE A LARGE NUMBER
OF PATIENTS.
OF DIABETES FOR EXAMPLE ON IN
STAGE LIVER DISEASE THERE --
WOULD WE TRACK OUR PERFORMANCE --
VERY CLOSELY AGAINST OF THE
PERFORMANCE OF OUTSIDE -- THE
MEDICAL HOSPITALS AND MEDICAL
SYSTEMS ARE IN OUR PERFORMANCE
CONTINUES TO BE BETTER THAN MOST
HMO SO -- WAS SIMILAR TO THE VET
ADMINISTRATION -- AT TIMES
APPROACHING -- KAISER LEVEL OF
QUALITY SO WE'RE TRACKING
OBJECTIVE.
OUTCOME MEASURES ARE ON A
ROUTINE BASIS AND ARE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE SUCCESSFULLY I THINK
THAT WERE EXCEEDING.
THE PERFORMANCE IN THE COMMUNITY.
IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF STAFF
ON THE TABLES A BNC HAVE.
OF THE THE QUESTION I WOULD HAVE
ON THAT IS THE I SEE THE THE THE
MAJOR INCREASES IN PHARMACY.
AND THEN YOU HAVE -- FOOD.
FOOD SERVICES.
OKAY CAN YOU EXPLAIN KNOWS WHY.
FOOD SERVICES WHAT'S GOING ON
THERE.
IN FOOD SERVICES I DON'T SEE
WHAT WE DID WE LABEL BE ACTUALLY
YEAH -- FOR THE FOR THE DIETARY
PIECE -- AND COOKS COOKS YEAH
THE COOKS WOULDN'T HAVE A MODEL
FOR AND SO WE'RE UPDATING OUR
MODEL BE CONSISTENT WITH CITIES
HERE ARE.
THE EVERY LEAVE.
AND THAT RELIEF PROVIDES -- FOR
THEM TO HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
STAFFING DALY AND WE'D WE HAD
NEVER BASS LINE OUR COOKS IN OUR
INPATIENT UNITS -- AND SO WE'RE
RE BASING OUR COOKS TO THE TO
THE CDC OUR BLUEPRINT MODEL SO
WE HAVE THE APPROPRIATE RELIEF
AND STAFFING TO PROVIDE SERVICES
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
OKAY DO YOU -- THE NURSES.
THERE'S QUITE A FEW NURSES
PROPOSALS AND NURSE INSTRUCTORS.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT.
THERE'S BEEN IT.
SHOULD INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF
TRAINING THE THAT IS PROVIDED TO
OUR OUR NURSING STAFF AND WE
HAVE.
UPWARDS OF FIVE THOUSAND NURSING
STAFF -- SO WE SAW A CRITICAL
GAP WE WE HAVE BASICALLY ONE
NURSE INSTRUCTOR PER FACILITY.
AND THAT HAS PROVEN TO BE
INSUFFICIENT -- SO WE'RE CLOSING
THAT GAP ON THE INFECTION
CONTROL -- INFECTION CONTROL --
WAS NEVER PART OF THE ORIGINAL
MODEL AND WE CURRENTLY DON'T
HAVE THAT FUNCTION IN OUR
FACILITIES AND THAT'S A BIG GAP
IN HEALTH CARE ENVIRONMENT AND
SO.
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO CORRECT
THAT GAP NOW.
SO YOU'RE GOING FROM -- ONE SO
THE THIRTY THIRTY TWO WE'RE
GOING TO THIRTY FOUR THIRTY FOUR
NURSES.
SO EACH EACH.
IS FOR SOIL HAVE INFECTION
CONTROL.
NEVER SPECIFICALLY FOR INFECTION
CONTROL IN EACH FACILITY CORRECT
AS OPPOSED TO WE DON'T HAVE THAT
ANYMORE YEAH WE JUST DON'T HAVE
IT.
OKAY SO THAT NURSE WILL BE IN
CHARGE OF THE WHOLE SUBJECT YES
OR THE PLANNING FOR THEM -- OKAY --
I WAS JUST LOOKING AT OUR
POPULATION NUMBERS -- IN TERMS
OF WHO IS HOUSED CURRENTLY WE
HAVE.
THERE YOU KNOW.
THE HIGHER HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN K. A
OUR THOUSAND IN INMATES RIGHT
NOW.
AND OF THOSE.
ABOUT THIRTY NINE THOUSAND ARE
LONG LONG TERM SO WE'VE GOT
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND LIFERS.
FIVE THOUSAND WALKED.
AND SEVEN THOUSAND THIRD
STRIKERS SO THESE ARE ALL PEOPLE
THAT ARE -- IT BASICALLY GONNA
GET OLD IN OUR PRISONS AND WHICH
I THINK IS THE POINT THAT'S
BEING MADE HERE AND UNLESS WE DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
IN TERMS OF IF WE LEAVE ITAS IT
IS EVEN WITH.
SOME OF THE CHANGES WITH CREDIT
AND SUCH -- THERE'S AN AWFUL LOT
OF THESE FOLKS WHO JUST START.
ELIGIBLE DATE SO.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
OUR THE COSTS AROUND THE MEDICAL
IN SUCH INCREASE
JUST DUE TO THE FACT OF THE
POPULATION THAT WE'RE THE WAY
OUR SENTENCING CONDITIONS AND
SUCH SO -- THIS IS ANOTHER ONE
LIKE HER MENTAL HEALTH THAT WE
MAY WANNA.
DO SOME HEARINGS IN THE INTERIM
OR A HEARING.
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE HAS
PASSED -- POLICIES LIKE
COMPASSIONATE RELEASE POLICIES
ON MEDICAL PAROLE POLICIES ON
ELDERLY.
AND THE DATA THAT WE'VE RECEIVED
TO DATE WOULD INDICATE THAT IT'S
THESE POLICIES THAT WE HAVE --
APPROVED HAVE NOT.
THE BEEN RARELY LITTLE UTILIZED.
SO WE MAY WANT TO LOOK FURTHER
AT THAT -- BECAUSE FOR A PUBLIC
SAFETY POINT OF VIEW.
OUR HOUSING SOME NUMBER OF THESE
PEOPLE IS NOT NECESSARILY
BRINGING US PUBLIC SAFETY BUT
DEFINITELY BRINGING US VERY HIGH
COSTS -- ANYWAY SO THE GROUP.
WE MAYBE WE COULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. TO APPROVE AS BUDGETED
BUT WITH THE ADDITION OF A
REPORT -- AS THE LA -- SUGGESTED
SO THAT WE CAN LOOK AT
UTILIZATION RATES AND MAKE A
FUTURE ADJUSTMENT IF NEEDED.
I MAKE A MOTION PICTURE.
ALL RIGHT.
A DEPARTMENT FINANCE JACQUELINE
COME THE PART OF FINANCE I THINK --
PROVIDING SOME REPORTING METRICS
THAT AREN'T OVERLY
ADMINISTRATIVELY BURDENSOME
MAKES SENSE -- THE THE TERM
REPORT SEEMED A LITTLE BIT MORE
ROBUST AND I THINK I WAS MAKING
BUT DEFINITELY RECOMMEND THAT
ACT ON THE METRICS THAT WERE
USED TO JUSTIFY THE REQUEST.
SEEMS LIKE A REASONABLE ASK OKAY --
YES THAT IS WHAT I WAS INTENDING
VERSUS -- A LONG -- SUBJECTIVE
REPORT IT WAS MUCH MORE IN THE
MATRIX OKAY SO WITH THE
CLARIFICATION ON THE MOTION I'LL
TAKE A ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER HI THERE MARK
[inaudible]
CENTRE BELL.
I'M WILL HOLD IT OPEN IN CASE
SENATOR MORE LIKE ONE STAT ON
ALL RIGHT NOW SINCE WE HAVE THE
RECEIVER AT THE TABLE.
AND I'M THINKING THAT WE MIGHT
WANT TO WITH OUR NEXT ITEM WAS --
UNDER -- UNDER.
THE ITEM FIVE TWO TWO FIVE ISSUE
EIGHT THEIR CONTRACT MEDICAL
AUGMENTATION.
BUT THE OTHER RECEIVER ITEM THAT
WE HAVE.
ON OUR AGENDA.
IS -- WHICH ONE WHICH NUMBER.
TWENTY EIGHT TO TWENTY EIGHT SO
PERHAPS WE WOULD DO NOW ISSUE
EIGHT AND FOLLOW IT BY ISSUE.
TWENTY EIGHT THAT [inaudible]
THAT WORK.
SO WE DEAL WITH THE WITH THE
BACK TO THE NUMBER EATEN.
YET WE'RE GONNA GO TO EIGHT
RIGHT NOW.
OKAY ISSUE EIGHT THANK YOU MA'AM
CHAIR -- THE THE BUDGET INCLUDES
AN AUGMENTATION OF SIXTY ONE
POINT NINE MILLION OFFER
CONTRACT MEDICAL SERVICES THERE
ARE I THINK A REALLY TWO ASPECTS
OF THIS THE FIRST IS.
A STARK CANAAN'S ALREADY
MENTIONED WE SIMPLY SEEN I
INCREASES IN LENGTH OF STAY
INCREASES IN COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE STATE BECAUSE OF
GREATER COMPLEXITY -- AND
POSSIBLY INCREASES IN THE COSTS
OF OUTSIDE HOSPITAL HERE.
A SHE CAN ADDRESS THOSE IN
GREATER DETAIL THERE IS A SECOND
ASPECT TO THIS THIS JUST A
BUDGET MANAGEMENT.
ON THE ISSUE OF THAT ARE USEFUL
I HAVE TO TAKE PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY -- FOR WE
ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN.
ON THIS LINE OF OUR BUDGET.
SEEING INCREASES BEYOND THAT THE
AUTHORIZATION FOR ABOUT FOUR
YEARS.
AND WHAT WE HAVE DONE ON DURING
THOSE YEARS AS WE HAVE COVER
THOSE COSTS.
ARE BASED ON A CENTRALLY SALARY
SAVINGS BECAUSE WE WENT THROUGH
A COUPLE OF YEARS WHERE WE WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY DOWN.
IN THE OUR STAFFING WHERE WE HAD
AS MUCH AS 2225% VACANCIES IN
CLINICAL STAFFING.
WHICH GENERATED AN ENORMOUS
SAVINGS.
ON END OF SENSUALLY I MADE THE
MISTAKE I CONSIDERED IN
RETROSPECT A MISTAKE.
OF USING THOSE SAVINGS TO OFFSET
THE INCREASES IN CONTRACT
MEDICAL AND THEN I THINK THE
MISTAKE WAS NOT TELLING FINANCE
ON A YEAR BY YEAR BASIS.
THAT WE ACTUALLY NEED TO
INCREASE THE AUTHORIZATION FOR
CONTRACT MEDICAL.
THE RESULT IS WE'RE HAVING TO
PLAY CATCH UP.
BECAUSE IN THE LAST YEAR.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE FILLED ON
NEARLY ALL OF THOSE CLINICAL
POSITIONS.
SO WE DID NOT GENERATE A COST
SAVINGS THAT WE COULD USE TO
COVER THIS -- THAT WAS THE
REASON THAT WE HAD -- A REQUEST
FOR A DEFICIENCY -- AND THIS
RELATES TO THE ACT OF SENSUALLY
WE NEED A ONE TIME CATCH UP.
ON AND I HAVE DONE MY
APPROPRIATE PENANCE OF OVER THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
IN ASSURE THEM THAT THE I WON'T
BE DOING THIS IN THE FUTURE --
AND THAT WE WILL -- BE SHARING.
OUR EARLIER IN THE YEAR.
ON ANY AND ALL INFORMATION ABOUT
PROJECTED INCREASES FOR EXAMPLE
IN CONTRACT MEDICAL OR
PHARMACEUTICALS.
SO THE BUT BOTH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THE LEGISLATURE
IS NOT CAUGHT OFF GUARD
[inaudible]
CENTERVILLE.
SO THE COST DRIVERS -- THE
INPATIENT HOSPITAL -- WHAT KIND
OF -- HOSPITAL TREATMENT ARE YOU
PUTTING PEOPLE AND IS THIS OF
INTENSIVE CARE OR REGULAR
HOSPITAL LIKE YOU HAVE DIFFERENT
LEVELS.
CAN YOU GIVE US AN IDEA OF WHAT
KIND OF PEOPLE OF WHAT WHAT KIND
OF CARE LEVELS ARE.
YOU PUTTING PEOPLE AT THE
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY RESERVE THE
WE BREAK IT DOWN A LITTLE BIT
MAYBE.
WELL I'M I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE
THEM THE DATA FOR YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SEE SORT OF THE
BREAKDOWN OF THE DIFFERENT KIND
OF LEVELS OF CARE ONCE WE SEND
THE PATIENT ALLAH BUT IT.
IT REALLY IS THE WHOLE CONTINUUM
THAT YOU THAT YOU MENTIONED -- A
LOT OF THIS IS DRIVEN -- THROUGH
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT THE
PATIENT IS THEN ADMITTED ON MOST
OF THEM GO TO YOU KNOW GENERAL
MEDICAL -- WARDS OBVIOUSLY THERE
ARE SPECIALIZED A UNITS AS WELL
FOR CARDIOLOGY IS AN EXAMPLE --
AND WE DO A SEND PATIENTS TO THE
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT AS WELL --
ACROSS ALL THOSE SPECTRUMS ONCE
THEY'RE HOSPITALIZED WHAT WE ARE
SEEN OUR PATIENTS WHO ARE
STAYING LONGER.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE CODING
REGARDLESS OF THE DIAGNOSES THAT
THESE PATIENTS HAVE.
IT'S OFTEN ASSOCIATED WITH MORE
COMPLEXITY.
SO WE'RE SEEING THE SAME TYPE OF
DIAGNOSES -- THAT WE WERE SEEN
IN PREVIOUS YEARS EXCEPT THAT
THEY ARE NOW -- THERE NOW
CONSIDERED MUCH MORE COMPLICATED.
ARE YOU -- WHEN YOU SAY HOSPITAL
INPATIENT WHEN I THINK OF A
HOSPITAL INPATIENT I THINK OF?
A HOSPITAL NOT.
A NURSING HOME OR YOU'RE NOT.
SENDING PEOPLE TO THOSE KIND OF
FACILITIES CANNELLA THEY'RE NOT
REALLY LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES --
SO REALLY TALKING ABOUT A CUTE
YOU DON'T A CUTE GENERAL ACUTE
CARE HOSPITALS SO YOU GO IN
THERE IN THESE [inaudible]
SPEND [inaudible]
TIME THERE -- DO YOU HAVE PEOPLE
WHO SPEND MORE THAN -- A WEEK.
YES THESE FACILITIES YEAH SO
WHAT KIND OF THEME IN CLOSE ONES
ACOSTA OUR MONEY RIGHT.
WELL THE THE COST OF THE COST OF
HOSPITALIZATION IS DEPENDING ON
A NUMBER OF FACTORS BUT ONE OF
THE MAJOR DRIVERS THAT WE ARE
SEEING.
IS THAT THEY ARE STAYING LONGER
ON AVERAGE A LONGER.
SO WHAT KIND OF CONTROLS ARE YOU
AS ESTABLISHING [inaudible]
ON THAT.
AGAIN IT WAS EITHER SAID WE HAVE
A VERY ROBUST UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM RIGHT STAFF
WITH PHYSICIANS AND NURSES.
AND WE COMMUNICATE WELL ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITY HOSPITALS THERE
ARE SEVERAL DOZEN OF THAT WE
WORK WITH ON A DAILY BASIS -- TO
MONITOR WHO WAS RECENTLY
ADMITTED WHO'S READY FOR
DISCHARGE AND TO BEGIN THAT
DISCHARGE PLANNING.
AND AS I MENTIONED.
WE HAVE VERY LOW NUMBERS OF
PATIENTS WHO WE KNOW ARE READY
FOR DISCHARGE WHO IN FACT.
A STAY IN THE HOSPITAL LONGER
THAN THEY SHOULD.
WE HAVE VERY LOW ADMINISTRATIVE
BAD DAY SO AGAIN ON MOST OF
THESE PATIENTS HAVE A BONA FIDE
DIAGNOSES -- THAT SHOULD BE
ADMITTED TO THE HOSPITAL BUT
AGAIN WHAT WE ARE SEEN BECAUSE
OF THE COMPLEXITY OF OUR PATIENT --
OUR PATIENT POPULATION IS GOING
UP THE HIGH RISK PATIENTS BUT WE
ARE ALSO SEEN.
OUR PATIENTS WHO ARE GETTING
ADMITTED WHO WERE -- NOT
NECESSARILY HIGH RISK CRIER TO
ADMISSIONS -- BUT ARE BEING
ADMITTED NOW -- BECAUSE OF
SIGNIFICANT TRAUMA -- BECAUSE OF
DRUG RELATED PROBLEMS A
SIGNIFICANT INFECTIONS FOR
EXAMPLE OR RELATED TO OVERDOSE
OF SO YOU.
DO HAVE A VARIATION IN THE RATES
THE HOSPITAL'S [inaudible]
CHARGE THE DEPARTMENT OF FOR THE
SAME.
SERVICES IS THERE ARE A WIDE
VARIATION OF RATES.
THAT THE HOSPITAL'S CHARGE AND
WHAT'S YOUR CONTROL MECHANISM ON
CONTROLLING THE HOSPITAL CHARGES
ON THE RATES.
WITH THE HOSPITALS.
WE CONTRACT WITH HEALTH NET.
AND HEALTH THAT -- BY THE
SUPERVISOR NETWORK TO WORK
WITHIN IN THE THEY DO MANY OF
THOSE CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS WE
DO HAVE A FEW HOSPITALS THAT ARE
OUTSIDE OF THE HELP THAT
CONTRACT THAT -- WE DO WORK WITH
AND AND YOU TO GO SHE ASIANS
THOSE ARE HEALTH NET
[inaudible]
AFFILIATED HOSPITALS.
THE MAJORITY YES OKAY -- THEY
INCLUDE PUBLIC HOSPITALS
[inaudible]
OUR I BELIEVE SO [inaudible]
YEAH OKAY.
AND SO ON SO I'M INTERESTED IN
WHAT.
WHAT KIND OF VARIATION OF RATES
TO THE?
YOU KNOW LIKE.
AND IF I REMEMBER CORRECTLY
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG I THINK
THAT STATUTE ACTUALLY SPECIFIES
HOW MUCH OF THE DEPARTMENT IS
ALLOWED TO PAY FOR THE SERVICES
AND I THINK IT MAY BE LIKE
PERCENT OF MEDICARE MEDICARE.
MEDICARE I THINK SO.
IN 25% OF MEDICARE SO IF YOU.
RELEASED THE PATIENTS AND TO
TREATMENT DUDE AUTOMATICALLY GET
A 25% LESS COST.
RIGHT YES.
OKAY.
ASSEMBLY SO THERE MIGHT BE SOME
TO LOOK INTO.
SO SO IF THEY'RE IF THEY'RE
RELEASED FOR MEDICAL DISCHARGE
OR OR COMPASSIONATE RELEASE ROSE.
THOSE KIND OF RELEASE THAT WOULD
REDUCE THE COST.
JUST ON OF MEDICAID AND MEDICARE
MEDICARE RATE.
NOT MEDI CAL RATE OKAY.
MEDICARE RATES HIGHER YEAH MEDI
CAL RATES LOWER.
SO SO IF THE PERSON.
WAS RELEASED IN A META CAL RATED
THE BIG SAVINGS [inaudible]
SO.
DO IF IF -- THAT COULD BE
INTERJECTS.
FOR SO IS THERE SOMETHING IS A
YOU CAN GIVE US ON ON ELIGIBLE.
POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE.
PATIENTS FOR MEDICAL DISCHARGE.
DOES THAT MONEY [inaudible]
SUBCOMMITTEE.
SOME TO LOOK INTO.
SO I'D LIKE TO HAVE THAT LOOKED
INTO.
SO WE ARE THERE YOU'LL SAVE
MONEY COLLECTOR [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
WE WOULD -- AS INDICATED BEFORE
THESE MAY BE SUBJECTS OF SOME
VERY -- INFORMATIVE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING -- IN OUR
WHEN WE'RE NOT UNDER THE PRESS
OF A BUDGET OPTION.
SO YOU -- CENTER BILL DID YOU
HAVE A MOTION ON THIS OF A FEW --
MAKE THE MOTION.
AND THE SUGGESTION THAT WE
EXPLORE THOSE THOSE ISSUES
RAISED.
ALL RIGHT SO -- THE MOTION THEN
IS A APPROVE IS BUDGETED.
BUT WITH -- HOME HOUSE LIKE
CHARACTERIZE THIS.
SOME OF THE ISSUES RAISED.
BY THE REPORT BACK ON THE MANY
CHARACTERIZE IT IS HOW WE MIGHT --
REDUCE THESE COSTS WHAT OPTIONS --
WE MIGHT HAVE.
TO YEAH AND AND THIS IS A JUST
ABOUT YOUR REQUEST WE DO PLAN ON
COLLECTING SOME ADDITIONAL DATA
COMING BACK -- WITH THE FUTURE
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESSES ISSUES OF
THIS IS THIS IS JUST A ONE YEAR
AUGMENTATION AND BUDGET YEAR.
SO I MADE THE MOTION BECAUSE
WHEN YOU TESTIFIED YOU OPEN THE
DOOR ON THE SUBJECT SO.
THE WALKTHROUGH.
I'D SAY THAT WAY SO WITH THAT IN
THE SUBJECT ON EARLY RELEASE
ANOTHER THING SO I WALK THROUGH
THE DOOR IS.
OPEN.
YET AND SUGGESTS THAT WE GET THE
INFORMATION IF WE'RE GONNA
EXPLORE ANY KIND OF BUDGETARY
SAVINGS WE SHOULD EXPLORE EVERY
OPTIONS FOR BUDGETARY SAVINGS.
RIGHT SO WE'LL DO THIS -- AS
BUDGET WHICH IS THE ONE TIME
ALLOCATION BUT WILL ALSO
[inaudible]
IN -- FOR OUR IN THE ITEM NEXT
YEAR WE WILL GET SOME -- OPTIONS
FOR HOW WE MIGHT AND REDUCE
THESE COSTS.
ART.
WE HAVE A MOTION LET'S TO ROLL
CALL.
CENTER SKINNER BY SENATOR
MORLOCK [inaudible]
CENTRE BELL.
OKAY SO WE WERE GONNA GO NEXT --
TO SUBSTANCE ABUSE YES THOUGH I
SHOULD ASK FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
POLICIES ISSUED ON IT BEFORE YOU --
ACTED BUT THERE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE ITEM WE JUST DID.
ALRIGHT SO THIS NOW IS GOING TO
BE THE THE SEVEN SEAS DISORDER
PROGRAM BUT WHAT I WOULD LIKE
WITH YOUR INDULGENCE TO HAVE A
FIVE MINUTE RECESS.
SO THAT -- OUR SPECIAL SERVICES
CAN PUT THE PODIUM HERE SO I MAY
UTILIZE THAT TO STAND FROM THIS
POINT ON AND AND IF ANYONE HAS
ANY OTHER AT NEED WILL DO A FIVE
MINUTE -- FOR DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
AFTER A BRIEF RECESS.
AND WE HAVE GOT -- WE ARE.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY GOING TO
REOPEN ISSUE SEVEN WHICH WE
ALREADY VOTED ON TO SEE --
SENATOR MORE LOCK IF YOU WANT TO
ADD ON WHICH YOU AND JUST READ
THE MOTION ON ISSUE -- SEVEN
YEAH SO THE THE MOTION IS.
TO APPROVE THE PROPOSAL -- AS
BUDGETED BUT INCLUDE ALEJO
REPORTING LANGUAGE [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALRIGHT SO THAT VOTE WAS THREE
NOTHING AND A WE WILL NOW GO.
TO OUR DISCUSSION ON THE
MEDICALLY ASSISTED.
A DRUG TREATMENT PROGRAM GO
AHEAD -- MR RECEIVER THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR -- I'M DELIGHTED TO
BE HERE TO PRESENT -- OF THE
GOVERNOR'S -- INTEGRATED
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER PROGRAM --
I HAVE WITH ME FOR STOCKTON THEY
CAME IN AND I'M JOINED NOW BY --
OR A RUNNING SUSAN CORRECT --
WHOSE POSITION MODEL I'LL GET
THE JOB TITLE WRONGS FOLLOWED
HIM INTRODUCES JOB TITLE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU THE THE COMMITTEE
STAFF REPORTS -- THAT REALLY
DOES A GREAT JOB OF SUMMARIZING --
THE SCOPE OF THE PROGRAM OUR
INITIAL FOCUS -- AND WHAT WE
HOPE TO ACCOMPLISH IN THE FIRST
COUPLE OF YEARS -- I THINK I CAN
FAIRLY DESCRIBE OUR APPROACH
HERE -- AS OF GOLD GOLD GO BIG --
I BUT I THINK IT'S FAIRLY
DESCRIBES IT -- THE VALIUM IS
PROBABLY BEST OF AT LEAST I
THINK IT MAY BE -- INSTEAD OF
TRYING TO SUMMARIZE -- THIS
COMPLEX PROGRAM IT MAY BE BEST
FOR US TO JUST JUMP IN THE
QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO SUMMARIZE
IT BUT IT IN THE STAFF REPORT
REALLY DOES -- AN EXCELLENT JOB
OF DESCRIBING ITS COMPONENT
PARTS.
OKAY I'M LET US SEE IF THERE ARE
QUESTIONS BY MY COLLEAGUES OR IF
WE HOLD ON A MINUTE WE DID HAVE
AN LA -- FOR A RECOMMENDATION
ARE PERHAPS A SHELVE ELLIE --
PERCENT AND THEN WE CAN OPEN FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS GO AHEAD
EARLIER.
EARLY LOOK WHO'S MORE WITH THE
LA -- WE DID IDENTIFY A FEW
CONCERNS WITH THIS THE PROPOSAL
WE NOTE THAT.
ASPECTS OF IT ARE EVIDENCE BASED
FOR INSTANCE MEDICATIONS THIS
TREATMENT HAS BEEN FOUND TO BE
AN EFFECTIVE TREATMENT OPTION
AND COGNITIVE BEHAVIOR THERAPY
HAS BEEN FOUND TO BE EFFECTIVE
IN.
MANY CIRCUMSTANCES.
OF ART THEM THIS IS A LARGE
SCALE IMPLEMENTATION OF A
PROGRAM THAT IS UNTESTED BECAUSE
MANY.
WHAT INCLUDES ASPECTS OUR
EVIDENCE BASED NOT ALL ASPECTS
ARE EVIDENCE BASED IN THIS
COMBINATION OF PROGRAMS HAS NOT
BEEN EVALUATED TO BE EFFECTIVE --
WE NOTE THAT IN THE ONE ASPECT
THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES TREATING
PATIENTS WITH A FORM OF
MEDICATION AND IT LONG LASTING
JEKYLL FROM A GROUP AN ORPHAN
THAT'S NEVER BEEN TESTED IN A
CORRECTIONAL SETTING TO SEE IF
IT HOW EFFECTIVE IT WOULD BE AT
TREATING.
INDIVIDUALS COMPARED TO THE
OTHER FORMS OF MEDICATIONS AS
THE ALL FORMS WHICH ARE SEVERAL
TIMES CHEAPER.
THE ONLY -- PILOT OF THIS DRUG
IS CURRENTLY BEING CONDUCTED BY
PENNSYLVANIA AND OUR PRISON
SYSTEM.
HOWEVER OR NOT BUT IT HAS RUN
INTO SEVERAL ADMINISTRATIVE
ISSUES AND SO.
WHILE I WAS INITIALLY PLANNED TO
LAUNCH IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN THEY'RE STILL
STRUGGLING TO GET THE FIRST
PATIENTS ENROLLED.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD ROLL ABOUT
DRUG OUT STATEWIDE TO TREAT 10%
OF THE M. A. T. PARTICIPANTS WHO
HAVE AN OPIOID USE DISORDER --
WE ALSO NOTE THAT THE COST
ESTIMATES ARE SUBJECT TO
SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY.
ESTIMATES ARE BASED OFF OF
PERCENTAGES THAT WE UNDERSTAND
TO BE BASED OFF OF BUT VARIETY
OF SOURCES INCLUDING OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
VALIDATED TO REPRESENT THAT CDC
OUR POPULATION -- AND ALSO ARE
SUBJECT TO ERROR FOR INSTANCE WE
NOTE THAT THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
PRESCRIBE THE LOCKS ON THE DRUG
DESIGNED TO REVERSE OPIATE
OVERDOSE IS. TO OFFENDERS GET
BEING RELEASED FROM PRISON --
AND THAT WOULD BE ENOUGH FOR
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND OFFENDERS
FIVE OR THAT WERE -- PROPOSAL
NOTES AT ONLY FOUR THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS ARE ESTIMATED TO BE
RELEASED EACH YOUR WITHIN --
BILL USED TO SORT OR THERE ARE
POTENTIALLY OTHER ERRORS OF THIS
NATURE THROUGHOUT THE PROPOSAL
GIVEN THAT A LARGE AMOUNT OF
MOVING PARTS INVOLVED -- IN
ADDITION THE FULL COST OF
IMPLEMENTATION IS NOT IDENTIFIED
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOTED THAT
THIS -- PROGRAM WOULD TAKE FIVE
YEARS TO IMPLEMENT HOW THE
PROPOSAL IS ONLY FOR THE FIRST
THREE YEARS AND IT'S NOT CLEAR
WHAT THE ADDITIONAL COMPONENTS
WOULD BE FOR THE FOLLOWING YOURS
OR WHAT FUNDING WOULD BE
NECESSARY.
THERE'S ALSO LIKELY TO BE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS RELATED TO
THIS PROPOSAL -- GIVEN THE LARGE
INCREASE AND CBT PROGRAMS OF THE
CUT CLASSROOMS THE MEDICAL STAFF
WHICH WOULD NEED SPACE -- AS
WELL AS TREATMENT FOR THE NET.
AND MEDICAL DISTRIBUTION --
THERE ALSO POTENTIAL
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES -- AS
HAS BEEN NOTED PREVIOUSLY THAT
WAS THESE MEDICAL POSITIONS CAN
BE DIFFICULT TO FILL THIS WOULD
BE A SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF POSITIONS -- MORE OF
OUR IT IS UNCLEAR HOW EFFECTIVE
THE PROPOSAL WOULD BE AT LINKING
INDIVIDUALS TO CARE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
WE NOTE THAT IN THE PROPOSAL IT
MENTIONS AT FIFTY SIX COUNTIES
HAVE.
IMPLEMENTED DIEM CODIS WHICH
WOULD EXPAND THE TREATMENT IN
THE COMMUNITY HAVE ACCOUNTS ARE
VERY STAGED IMPLEMENTATION AND
DATA FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
SUGGESTS THAT NUMBER IS ACTUALLY
FORTY AND NOT.
FIFTY SIX WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
ONLY STATE THAT HAS A STATEWIDE
M. A. T. PROGRAMS.
HAS GONE AROUND THIS
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUE BY HAVING
THE SAME PROVIDER PROVIDE
SERVICES IN THE PRISON SYSTEM AS
IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND SO WHAT THAT PROGRAM HAS
BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE AT REDUCING
OVERDOSE DEATHS NOT SURE HOW THE
MORE COMPLICATED NATURE NOT BE
NECESSARY FOR CALIFORNIA.
WOULD BE AT LINKING THESE
OFFENDERS TO SERVICES.
FINALLY THERE'S ALSO THIS
PROGRAM WOULD BE A SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE TO THE COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL THERAPY PROGRAMS IT
WOULD BE REPLACING THE EXISTING
CONTRACTS WITH NEW CONTRACTS IN
NEW CURRICULA -- ADDED.
WOOD BEES THERE'S ACTUALLY
INCREASING THE SIZE TO TREAT A
LARGER POPULATION.
WE KNOW THAT THESE ARE THE SAME
PROGRAMS AT A RECENT AUDIT FOUND --
MORE NOT EFFECTIVE AT REDUCING
RECIDIVISM.
WE DO NOT FEEL THAT THIS
PROPOSAL CONTAINS SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
OF THESE PROGRAMS.
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE LARGE
INCREASE.
WE ALSO NOTE THAT IN THE
PROPOSAL IT MENTIONS THAT SOME
OF THAT CONTRACT STOP FOR
ACTUALLY BRINGING IN CONTRABAND
AND DRUGS.
INTO THE PRISONS AND SO IT'S
UNCLEAR IF THAT COULD ACTUALLY
HAVE IT FOR THEIR ISSUE.
AS SUCH DO THE UNTESTED IN HR WE
RECOMMEND ADOPTING THIS OUT AS A
PILOT -- STARTING WITH THE THREE
FACILITIES THAT HAVE CORD AND
EIGHTY PILOTS IN PROGRESS.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT THE PILOT
INCLUDE OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE THAT
CONTRACTORS FOLLOW BEST
PRACTICES AND INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION BY RESEARCHERS TO
DETERMINE THE EFFECT OF THE
PROGRAM ON SUBSTANCE USE IN
PRISONS.
INMATE HEALTH AND OFFENDER
OUTCOMES UPON REENTRY INCLUDING
RECIDIVISM AN OVERDOSE DEATHS.
BASED ON THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ESTIMATES WE AT ESTIMATE THAT
APPLAUDED SIZE WOULD COST ABOUT
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
UNLIKELY TO EXCEED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS AT FULL
IMPLEMENTATION.
SHOULD THE LEGISLATURE DECIDE TO
IMPLEMENT STATEWIDE RATHER THAN
DOING A PILOT WE RECOMMEND
MODIFICATIONS SUCH AS REQUIRING
A MORE GRADUAL IMPLEMENTATION.
AN ANNUAL PROGRESS REPORT FROM
SEA TO SEA ON THE RECEIVE OUR ON
THE PROGRAM'S IMPLEMENTATION
COSTS.
AN INDEPENDENT EVALUATION ONCE A
PROGRAM IS FULLY IMPLEMENTED.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
DONE.
BY A COUPLE QUESTIONS AND I
HAPPEN -- TO HAVE OTHER FOLKS
NGUYEN SO inaudible]
I'M.
I'M WONDERING WHAT THE REACTION
WOULD BE TO A PILOT AND IF WE
WERE TO OPT TO DO A PILOT.
WHAT -- EITHER WHAT NUMBER OF
FACILITIES I MEAN.
I APPRECIATE ALEJO'S
RECOMMENDATION THOUGH IT SEEMED --
I WON'T SAY ARBITRARY BUT THERE
THERE WAS A LITTLE JUSTIFICATION
AS TO WHICH WHY THE CHOICE OF
THE FACILITIES THAT THE LA
ALWAYS -- INDICATING AND WHY
ONLY THREE SO I GUESS SOMEONE A
REACTION TO IF WE WERE TO OPT TO
DO A PILOT ONLY WHAT FACILITIES
WOULD BE RECOMMENDED AND HOW
MANY.
MADAM CHAIR ON THE QUESTION OF
OF A PILOT -- I GUESS SEVERAL
REACTIONS -- THE THE REAL
VISIONARY HERE IN THE ROOM ON
THIS TOPIC.
BUT YOU'LL SENATOR BELL.
AND I'M NOT JUST SAYING THAT --
TO BE NICE TO HIM -- EVER
NOTICED ME I'VE NEVER BEEN NICE
REFERRAL [inaudible]
THE NO ALL THIS IS ACTION.
I THOUGHT I ALREADY HAD YOUR
VOTE WITH DOLE BIGELOW BOLD --
THE THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S WHAT HE
SAID [inaudible]
AS SENATOR.
CONSERVATIVE SENATOR MEL --
ENCOURAGED WITH GREAT UNTIL
NATIONALLY OF THE DEVELOPMENT OF
A PILOT. FIVE YEARS AGO -- ONE
MIGHT SAY HE BROWBEAT THE
DEPARTMENT IN ME INTO DOING A
PILOT.
SO THE IDEA OF DOING A PILOT.
WE'VE ALREADY DONE A PILOT --
WE'RE IN THE THIRD YEAR OF THAT
WILL BE REPORTING THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE RESULTS OF
THAT -- IN THE SAUDIS IT WAS AT
THREE FACILITY AS WELL TO SEE I
AM TO SEE I DON'T.
AND A HOUSE OUT OF AN ASSET OF
SO WE'RE INTO A THIRD SO WE WE
WE ACTUALLY ALREADY I HAVE SOME
SENSE.
OF THE EFFICACY OF OF THE BASIC
TREATMENT PROGRAM -- AND THE
PROGRAM THAT WE ARE NOW OFFERING
IS BUILT UPON OUR SUCCESS THERE.
THE THE SECOND POINT -- DOING A
PILOT HERE.
DOESN'T REALLY SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
BECAUSE OF WHAT WE'VE GOT A
PATIENTS IN EVERY FACILITY.
IT'S NOT LIKE WE DO A PILOT
WE'RE GONNA LEARN MUCH ABOUT HOW
TO DO THIS SYSTEM WIDE.
WE NEED TO ACTUALLY.
DO THIS SYSTEM WIDE MUCH IN THE
SAME WAY THAT WE DID HABSI --
BECAUSE THE PATIENTS -- WILL THE
GOAL HERE IS TO ANY PATIENT WHO
IS ON THE ALREADY THIS TREATMENT
REGIMEN -- WE NEED TO KEEP THEM
ALL.
WELL THEY'RE GOING TO BE AFTER
THEY GO THROUGH OUR RECEIVING A
RECEPTION THEY'RE GONNA BE
SPRINKLED THROUGHOUT THE
DEPARTMENT.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE.
TO PROVIDE THEM TREATMENT WHERE
THEY ARE -- I THINK THE THIRD
POINT -- IS.
THERE'S AN URGENCY HERE -- THAT
SUGGESTS TO ME THAT THE PILOTS
THE WRONG RESPONSE.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST DEATH RATE
FROM OVERDOSE IN THE COUNTRY AND
OUR PRISONS COMPARED TO OTHER
PRISONS.
THIS LAST YEAR WE HAD EIGHT
HUNDRED TRIPS TO THE EMERGENCY
ROOM FOR OVER THOSE.
AND THIS IS A SPIKE FROM SAY TWO
YEARS AGO.
SO YOU KNOW WHEN I DO A PILOT.
WELL OKAY WE DO A PILOT WE COME
BACK IN THREE YEARS WITH THE
RESULTS OF THAT -- YOU YOU'RE
DOWN FIVE TO SEVEN YEARS ON A
PROBLEM THAT IS STARING US IN
THE FACE RIGHT NOW.
AND I THINK IT'S A PROBLEM OF
SUFFICIENT DIMENSION THAT IT
CALLS.
FOR AN IMMEDIATE.
RESPONSE OF THE SIZE AND SCOPE
OF THOSE BEING PROPOSED.
NO QUESTION I AGREE WITH THE LA
OWES COMMENTS THEN THERE'S
UNCERTAINTY A GREAT DEAL OF
UNCERTAINTY.
WELL THERE'S UNCERTAINTY BECAUSE
WHAT WE HAVEN'T HAD THIS PROGRAM
AT ALL.
IN THE PRISONS.
SO NATURALLY THERE'S GOING TO BE
SOME UNCERTAINTY ABOUT.
LEVEL OF CERTAIN EXPENDITURES.
WELL AL I CAN PROMISES THAT AS
WE HAVE DONE WITH EVERY PROGRAM
WE'VE -- INITIATED -- BUT WE ARE
GOING TO BE CONSCIOUS OF OF THE
CITY EXPENDITURES OF THIS IS
PUBLIC MONEY.
OTHER WE NEED TO WORK AS HARD AS
E CAN TO GET THE EXPENSES OF
THE PHARMACEUTICALS DOWN. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE HIRING THAT
WE DO WORKS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE CONTRACTORS THAT WE HIRE ARE
PROPERLY -- A MONITORED AND
SUPERVISED.
SO YOU KNOW THE THE I THINK THE
RESPONSE THAT I WOULD GIVE TO
THE UNCERTAINTY ARGUMENT IS.
LIVE RECEIVERSHIP OVER THE LAST
TEN YEARS HAS DONE A PRETTY GOOD
JOB OF IMPLEMENTING A LEVELING
OUT.
BIG CHANGES.
AND I THINK THIS IS SIMPLY GOING
TO BE ANOTHER CASE FOR WILL BE
ABLE TO DO THAT -- FINALLY WITH
RESPECT TO THE C. B. T. M.
SUPERVISION ACTUALLY WILL BE
FINALLY I HAVE ONE MORE FINALLY.
A BRITISH BACK -- TO IS A
MONITORING OF THAT FUNCTION
WITHIN CDC ARE -- I DON'T THINK
THERE'S GOING TO BE A NEED FOR
EXTERNAL MONITORING OR SPECIAL
MONITORING.
ON THE SECRETARY DEALS AND I
HAVE ALREADY DECIDED TO HAVE --
A STEERING COMMITTEE.
OF AB ESSENTIALLY OUR LEVEL.
IN A FEW BELOW -- THAT'S GOING
TO BE MEETING ROUTINELY UP TO
MONITOR AND TRACK PROGRESS A
WE'RE GONNA TREAT THIS VERY MUCH
AS THOUGH IT WAS A LARGE IT
PROJECT -- THAT REQUIRES THAT
DEGREE HOME OF EXECUTIVE
SUPERVISION AND MONITORING.
AND I WOULD NOTE THAT CDC ARE
OVER THE LAST DECADE.
HAS BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL IN
LARGE IT PROJECTS.
BOTH FARMS IN THE ELECTRONIC
HEALTH RECORD WERE ENORMOUS
PROJECTS THAT REPLACED.
I IN THE CASE OF PHAM SOME
EIGHTEEN OR TWENTY DIFFERENT IT
SYSTEMS WITH ONE SYSTEM. TO
TRACK OF VENDORS.
AND IT WORKS BEAUTIFULLY.
SO I THINK THE DEPARTMENT
ACTUALLY IS IN A GOOD POSITION
TO SAY WE WE CAN DO THIS TYPE OF
LARGE IMPLEMENTATION.
FINAL COMMENT -- IN TERMS OF
EXTERNAL EVALUATION -- I DON'T
MIND EXTERNAL EVALUATION I DO
WONDER WHETHER WE REALLY NEED.
OF THE RECEIVERSHIP HAS BEEN AS
OPEN AS IT IS POSSIBLE TO BE
ABOUT OUR PERFORMANCE WITH OUR
DASHBOARDS ARE REPORTS.
I THINK WE HAVE THE CONFIDENCE
TO EVALUATE -- OUR PERFORMANCE
OURSELVES.
IF THE PERFORMANCE IS BAD.
WE'LL TELL YOU ABOUT IT.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE HIDING
ANYTHING -- AND TO SOME EXTENT
EXTERNAL EVALUATION IS JUST IT
ADDS ANOTHER COMPLICATION -- THE
ARE FRANKLY WE COULD DO WITHOUT.
BUT I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS --
THE YOU MENTION THAT WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST OVERDOSE RATE OF IN THE
STATE PRISON SYSTEM NOW IT UP
RIGHT FACTORED SKEWS ME.
DEATHS FROM OVERDOSE YES FROM
OVERDOSE OKAY NOW IS THAT
FACTORED -- OUR POPULATION SINCE
WE ALSO HAVE THE HIGHEST
POPULATION IS THAT ARE YOU MEAN
THE RATE IN SO YET FACTORS IN
THE POPULATION THE RATE IS ABOUT
THREE TIMES WHAT THE AVERAGE
RADIOS.
IN A CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES
AROUND THE COUNTRY -- AND YET.
AWAY -- I THINK -- YOUR COMMENTS
WERE THAT THERE'S NOT OTHER
STATE PRISONS DOING MEDICALLY
ASSISTED TREATMENT.
THERE ARE VERY FEW -- YOU KNOW
WHAT'S ON ISLAND.
THE WORLD ISLAND.
MASSACHUSETTS BUT THOSE ARE THE
STATE'S WEARING YELLOW RHODE
ISLAND THEIR ENTIRE STATE
FACILITY IS ONE BUILDING -- IT'S
A LITTLE EASIER FROM THEM -- TO
DO SOME OF THE COORDINATION WITH
LOCALS SO BY THE THE CHALLENGE
AREAS.
A CORRECTIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
JUST LIKE SOCIETY GENERALLY.
IS WHAT ARE WAY BEHIND THE CURVE.
ONE ON TREATING THIS RELATIVELY
RECENT.
OF EXPLOSION IN THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC GIVEN THAT -- THERE'S
NOT REALLY OTHER THAN TO MEANT
STATE YOU MENTIONED OTHER STATES
NECESSARILY USING MEDICALLY
ASSISTED TREATMENT [inaudible]
WHAT -- WHAT THE EXPLAINS OUR
HIGH DEATHS?
WELL WE HAVE A LOT MORE THAN
CERTAINLY PART OF IT IS WE HAVE
A LOT MORE DRUGS THAT GET INTO
OUR PRISONS.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S THE ONLY
FACTOR BUT AB AND YOUNG DRUGS
ARE GETTING IN -- THEY'RE BEING
MAILED THEM ON THE BEING BROUGHT
IN BY VISITORS THEY'RE BEING
BROUGHT IN BY STAFF BOTH CUSTODY
AND HEALTHCARE.
THEY'RE BEING DROPPED OVER THE
FENCE ON IN DRONES.
AND WITH SOME OF THE MORE
DANGEROUS RECENT -- OR
FORMULATIONS OF FENNEL FOR
EXAMPLE THE OLD TINY SPECKS IS
ALL YOU NEED -- TO GET INTO THE
FACILITY.
AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO EVEN
WITH A FULL BLOWN WE'RE GONNA
SEARCH EVERYBODY -- IN THE DRUGS
ARE STILL GOING TO GET IN.
SO I DON'T KNOW THAT.
I'M NO QUESTION IF YOU CAN
REDUCE THE PRESENCE OF DRUGS IN
THE PRISON.
THAT WOULD BE A GOOD THING.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE T SUGGEST THAT.
TRYING TO DO THIS ON THE SUPPLY
SIDE ONLY.
IT ISN'T GOING TO WORK WELL.
WE NEED TO HAVE A DEMAND THE
SOLUTION AND PART OF THE PROBLEM
I RAISE THE ISSUE BECAUSE IF WE
LOOK AT HOPE YOUR USE OVER THE
COUNTRY.
WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS IN TOTAL
NUMBERS IT IN THIS IS.
WHETHER IT OUTSIDE OF THE INMATE
POPULATION [inaudible] FIVE A
HEART LAW HI TOTAL NUMBER AS
PROPORTION TO THE POPULATION WE
ARE STILL LOWER THAN MANY OTHER
STATES MANY OTHER STATES ARE
EXPERIENCING THE OPIOID CRISIS
FAR GREATER THAN WE ARE.
SO I REYES SAID IN THAT.
YET IT SEEMS TO BE THE OPPOSITE
WITH IN OUR PRISON FACILITY AND
I PARTLY REYES BECAUSE WELL THIS
IS DEALING WITH MEDICALLY SISTER
TREATMENT [inaudible]
IT -- IF WE SEE OUR NUMBERS.
OF PEOPLE USING YOUR FOR YOUR
IT'S WITHIN OUR PRISONS INCREASE
THEN THE COST TO US FOR THIS IS
GOING TO INCREASE.
AND EDITION ONLY MY QUESTION
WOULD BE.
THE SEMI CONNECTED IS.
WITH THIS POTENTIALLY LEAD TO
MORE DRUGS BEING BROUGHT IN
[inaudible]
AND IT'S AN INCREASE IN USAGE.
WELL HAT WOULD CERTAINLY BE ONE
OF THEARM -- ONE THE DATA
ELEMENTS THAT WE SHOULD BE
MONITORING AND MEASURING FOR
SUCCESS.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU WANT
TO HAVE HAPPEN.
WHAT YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO SEE
IS THAT THE NUMBER OF OF INMATES
WHO -- ARE YOU ACTIVELY USING --
OPIOIDS GOES DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY.
THAT WHEN THEY'RE RELEASED TO
THEY'RE ABLE TO BE THERE
TREATMENT IS ABLE TO CONTINUE.
MAKING IT LESS LIKELY THAT THEY
WILL THEM -- COME BACK INTO THE
SYSTEM AS PART OF RECIDIVISM.
SO WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
WHETHER ON WHAT THE YOU KNOW.
WHAT YOU'VE DESCRIBED WHICH
WOULD BE A BAD SCENARIO A WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT WHETHER
THAT HAPPENS I DON'T BELIEVE IT
WILL HAPPEN THE EXPERIENCE SO
FAR AS YOU MENTIONED FOR THREE
YEARS YOU HAPPEN TO TESTING THIS?
HAS THE NUMBER OF HOPE YOUR
USERS GOING DOWN IN THOSE
FACILITIES.
A COLLECTION DO YOU KNOW THE
NUMBERS LAST TIME I LOOKED AT
THIS WAS ABOUT SIX MONTHS AGO MY
RECOLLECTION IS THAT THE NUMBERS
HAVE GONE DOWN -- AND I BELIEVE
ON RECIDIVISM MAY STILL BE TOO
EARLY FOR TELL EARLY IN TWO
SMALL [inaudible]
FROM.
WE KNOW THAT THE THE INMATES WHO
HAVE BEEN PART OF THE PROGRAM.
AND WE DO HAVE TO DISTRICT
SHOWING THAT I THINK IT'S 6270%
HAVE STAYED ON THE TREATMENT
PROGRAM.
SO TO THAT EXTENT -- THAT'S BEEN
SUCCESSFUL ENOUGH PROBABLY ALL
YOU'RE GOING TO GET THE MEASURE
IN A THREE YEAR PILOT ANYWAY.
A YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
SHOW OF OF RECIDIVISM WHERE YOUR
TOTAL -- PILOT POPULATION IS A
HUNDRED HUNDRED AND FIFTY YOU
JUST TALK A SEAT ON IMPACT WITH
THOSE IN SMALL NUMBERS.
CAN YOU DESCRIBE OTHER IN THIS
OBVIOUSLY COVERING ALL
FACILITIES WHAT ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL THAT YOU'VE BROUGHT
BEFORE US IS DIFFERENT FROM WHAT
YOU HAVE BEEN DOING IN THE THREE
FACILITIES THAT YOU ARE
CURRENTLY USING.
MEDICALLY ASSISTED TREATMENT --
I MAY TURN THE DOCTOR CAME IN
FOR THAT DESCRIPTION GOOD THAT
WILL NOT TO WANT TO MISS STATE --
ELEMENTS OF THE PROGRAM.
YEAH NO I THINK THIS IS A A MUCH
MORE COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
WE'RE REALLY FOCUSING ON THAT
THE THREE BIG PATIENT
POPULATIONS THAT ARE AT THE
HIGHEST RISK. FOR DEATH AND SO
WHAT WE'D BE DOING IS CONTINUING
PATIENTS ON MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT AS THEY COME FROM THE
THE COUNTY JAILS -- WERE ALSO
HAVE A DEVELOPER VERY ROBUST
PROCESS TO IDENTIFY PATIENTS.
WHO ARE CURRENTLY WITH US PAGE
FIFTEEN OF YOUR?
AT THE BOTTOM CONTINUE.
THE SECOND GROUP OF PATIENTS ARE
REALLY THE THE FOLKS WHO HAVE
ALREADY DECLARED THEMSELVES AT
HIGH RISK -- WHO HAVE OVERDOSED
AT LEAST ONCE?
I ON ON A ON A DRUG.
OR HAVE SOME OTHER COMPLICATION
RELATED TO SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER -- SORT SO FOR EXAMPLE
WE SEE SPINAL ABSCESSES OR
INFECTIONS OF THE HEART
ENDOCARDITIS.
AND THEN THE THIRD GROUP THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY DIFFERENT AND THE
THE BIG DIFFERENCE IS WE'RE
GOING TO BE FOCUSING.
ON THE PATIENTS WHO ARE LEADING
US IN THE NEXT FIFTEEN TO
EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
OUR GONNA DO.
SCREENING ON EVERYONE OF THOSE
PATIENTS LEAVING IF THEY SCREEN
POSITIVE WILL BE DOING OF KIND
OF A RISK ASSESSMENT FROM A
CLINICAL PERSPECTIVE.
AND BASED ON THAT ASSESSMENT IF
THEY'RE MODERATE TO HIGH RISK --
WE WILL -- DETERMINE THEIR
TREATMENT NEEDS USING THE A SAM
CRY TERRY THIS IS THE COMMUNITY
A STANDARD IF YOU WILL -- TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THEY NEED
pI'M SORRY INTENSIVE OUTPATIENT
OR OUTPATIENT.
I AND THEN WE WILL START THEM ON
A TREATMENT REGIMENT IF THEY'RE
APPROPRIATE FOR MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT WILL START
THEM ON THE MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT.
AND REFER THEM TO TO D. R. P.
FOR A COUNTY BEHAVIORAL THERAPY
AND THEY'LL RECEIVE THAT
TREATMENT.
FOR AN AVERAGE OF OF TWELVE
MONTHS.
AND SEVERAL MONTHS PRIOR TO
DISCHARGE OF THROUGH OUR NURSING
SERVICES OUR WHOLE PERSON CARE --
WE WE GETTING THEM READY TO
TRANSITION EITHER TWO THREE
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION OR PAROLE --
WE WILL BE WORKING. TO GET THEM
AT CONNECTED IF YOU WILL FOR
THEIR FIRST APPOINTMENTS
INCLUDING AS SHE D. T..
AS WELL AS WORKING WITH OTHERS
TO SECURE HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION AND OTHER SORT OF
UNNECESSARY SOCIAL SERVICES.
SO IT'S MUCH MORE COMPREHENSIVE
REALLY FOCUSING ON THESE THESE
LARGE GROUPS OF OF PATIENCE VERY
HIGH RISK -- INCLUDING
ESPECIALLY THE LARGE GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO WE LIVE LEAVING US IN
THE NEXT FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN MONTHS
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE AT VERY
HIGH RISK OF DEATH.
IN THE FIRST TWO WEEKS OF OF FOR
LEASE.
AND WE ALSO A NO THEN -- MANY OF
THE COUNTIES ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES MANY OF
THE COUNTIES HAVE PUT IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO TAKE CARE OF
THESE FOLKS SO IT GIVES US SOME
TIME TO PUT OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
IN PLACE.
WE CAN FOCUS ON THOSE LEAVING
GET THEM TREATMENT GIVEN
CONNECTED -- TO BEAR TRANSITION
SERVICES AND THEIR FIRST
APPOINTMENTS -- PARTICULARLY
THOSE COUNTIES THAT HAVE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE WHICH
FORTUNATELY IS WHERE ABOUT 70%
OF OUR PATIENTS ARE RELEASED.
RECEIVED -- MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
QUESTIONS CENTER MORE LIKE.
MR KELSO -- JUST BECAUSE I AM
THE NEW PERSON HERE YOU YOU WERE
APPOINTED BY A FEDERAL JUDGE
CORRECT YES.
AND TO DEAL WITH THE HEALTH CARE
IN THE PRISON SYSTEM WITH
MEDICAL CARE MEDICAL CARE.
BUT NOT.
TO DEAL WITH THE POPULATION OF
THE PRISON WOULD THAT BE A
DIFFERENT FEDERAL JUDGE OR IS
THAT THE SAME JUDGE.
WE WE'VE BEEN MANDY OVERCROWDING
LOS WELL THE OVERCROWDING.
OVERCROWDING IS WHAT'S CALLED OF
THOSE ARE THE THREE JUDGE PANEL.
THAT DEALS WITH OVERCROWDING
ISSUES SO THAT WOULD NOT BE --
MY RESPONSIBILITY BUT YOU'RE
STILL REPORTING TO THE SAME
FEDERAL JUDGE THAT YOU STARTED
WITH -- ON THE DIFFERENT FEDERAL
JUDGE JUDGE -- HENDERSON -- TO
SEVERAL YEARS AGO RETIRED WHAT
BAND -- AT THIS POINT -- THERE'S
A NEW FEDERAL JUDGE THING
FEDERAL DISTRICT COURT IN SAN
FRANCISCO GAY AND SO.
IN IN THE MEANTIME.
LIFE IS CHANGING THINGS
REVOLVING WE HAVE NEW DRUGS.
AND THAT'S PART OF YOUR MANDATE
THEN.
TO YES WHAT WHAT LITTLE THE
APPROACH THAT THAT BUT I'VE
TAKEN A IS TO TRY -- TO SET AS
THE STANDARD FOR OUR PERFORMANCE.
COMMUNITY STANDARDS OF CARE.
SO IT'S NOT ANYTHING THAT WE
MAKE UP WE'RE LOOKING AT WHAT'S
HAPPENING OUT IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND CERTAINLY ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAS HAPPENED IN THE LAST
THREE OR FOUR YEARS HAS BEEN IN
THE CONTEXT OF S. UT T..
HAS BEEN A REAL CRYSTALLIZATION
OF A NEED FOR A BETTER MEDICAL
RESPONSE TO OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER.
SO I'M JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHETHER IT'S STYLE DRIFTER IF
IT'S YOU KNOW.
PART OF THE JOB DESCRIPTION
BECAUSE WE'RE DEALING WITH
SYMPTOMS AND NOT THE ROOT CAUSE
OF WHAT'S GOING ON SO YOU'VE
EXPLAINED.
THAT THIS IS COMING INTO THE
PRISON SYSTEM THROUGH DRONES OR
WHO KNOWS HOW -- OUR OUR OUR
INMATES REQUIRED TO DO A URINE
TEST EVERY [inaudible]
FEW DAYS [inaudible]
THERE'S DEPENDING ON THE ON THIS
BIG FOR D. AFTER JUST I GUESS I
WILL NOT MISS SPEAKING -- UNDER
OUR DIVISION OF A DAHLE
INSTITUTIONS DEPENDING ON THE
JOB THAT THE INMATE HAS THEY
WILL BE REQUIRED TO DRUG TEST
AND IN OUR TREATMENT PROGRAMS
THERE'S A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF
THE POPULATION IS PARTICIPATING
IN TREATMENT.
THAT WOULD BE DRUG TESTED BUT
OUR PROGRAMS RIGHT NOW AGAIN --
JUST GEARED TOWARDS THE END OF
THE INCARCERATIONS SO.
NOT THE ENTIRE POPULATION AMPLY
DESTRUCTIVE.
HI JENNIFER BRANHAM.
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS
I'D LIKE TO HELP ADDRESS THE
QUESTION ON THE ANALYSIS.
WE DO HAVE RANDOM URINALYSIS
REQUIREMENTS OF ALL INMATES BUT
THOSE THAT ARE IN PROGRAMS OR AS
PART OF THE IS THIS A MEATY ARM
TREATMENT THERAPY.
THEY HAVE A A HEIGHTENED
REQUIREMENTS BEYOND THE RANDOM.
WELL I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE I GET TO
EXPLAIN THIS TO CONSTITUENTS
RIGHT RIGHT THAT WE'RE SPENDING
MORE MONEY TO PROVIDE.
ASSISTANCE AND BY KIDS TEACHERS
ARE GONNA GO.
HOW DO YOU OVERDOSE IN A PRISON
HOW DOES THAT YOU KNOW THAT'S
THE FIRST THING WE GOT UP TRYING
TO FIGURE OUTSIDE [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
SO I SO IT WE'VE GOT IT AND I'M
JUST TRYING.
TO UNDERSTAND HOW CAN YOU HELP
[inaudible]
THE PRISON SYSTEM TO MAKE SURE
THAT DRUGS DON'T GET IN WHICH IS
YOU YOU MENTIONED THAT IT'S
SOMEHOW NOT HAPPENING BUT IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE THAT'S THE FRONT
LINE RATE.
YES AND AND THAT WOULD BE BEYOND
THE SCOPE OF FOR MY AUTHORITY
AND THE FEDERAL CASE OKAY --
AMAYA FORTY SIMPLY IS IF YOU
HAVE A AN INMATE WHO HAS A
MEDICAL PROBLEM.
MAKE SURE THEY GET TREATED
APPROPRIATELY AND AN OVERDOSE IS
CONSIDERED A MEDICAL PROBLEM YES
IT CERTAINLY OKAY I JUST.
WANNA MAKE SURE I GOT
DEFINITIONS YES CORRECT SO THEN
IT DOES BECOME A MANDATE.
AND SO YOU'RE NOT REALLY ASKING
US FOR MONEY YOU'RE KIND OF
ORDERING US.
WELL UP TO BE A LITTLE CLEARER
THIS IS A A A BUDGET REQUEST --
OF FROM THE ADMINISTRATION.
SO THIS IS GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S
PROGRAM -- I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
TWO HELP PROVIDE [inaudible]
EXPERTISE INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
WOULD SUCH A PROGRAM LOOK LIKE.
BUT AS I'M SITTING HERE TODAY
THIS IS I MEAN DEPARTMENT
FINANCE WOULD CONCUR THIS IS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
OKAY SOLD IT'S NOT MANDATED BY
THE FEDERAL JUDGE [inaudible]
NOT YET [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
NOW IS THAT A PREDICTION OR
THREAT.
IT'S NOT A THREAT CERTAINLY --
AND IT'S ALSO NOT A PREDICTION.
BECAUSE OF THE JUDGE DOESN'T
SHARE HIS VIEWS WITH ME ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT HASN'T BEEN YEP
BEFORE THE COURT -- IT HAS ANY
IT IS AN ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN
RAISED IN THE LITIGATION.
BY THE PLAINTIFFS.
AM THE BY OF THREE CHORD EXPERTS.
OF WHO THE COURT HAS APPOINTED.
SO IT'S CLEARLY AN ISSUE THAT IN
GENERAL TERMS IS BEFORE THE
COURT -- MY OWN SENSE IS GIVEN --
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT IT'S BEING
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A?
MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEM -- IN THE TREATMENT THIS
IS THE THE STANDARD TREATMENT
NOW THAT WE'RE SEEING IN THE
COMMUNITY.
I THINK IF THE ISSUE WERE PUSHED
REFER THE COURT THE COURT WOULD
HAVE A VERY DIFFICULT TIME.
IN NOT DIRECTING ME. TO
IMPLEMENT SUCH A PROGRAM.
BUT WHAT YOU'RE GETTING NOW IS
JUST MY LEGAL CONCLUSION MIKE
GAS ABOUT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
THIS WERE LITIGATED.
UNFORTUNATELY IN MY JUDGMENT OF
THE ADMINISTRATION DECIDED.
THIS IS A GOOD PROGRAM WE SHOULD
DO IT.
AND IT MAY BE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S DECIDED WELL
BECAUSE THEY AGREE WITH SORT OF
AT LEGAL ANALYSIS THAT IN FACT.
THIS IS A MEDICAL ILLNESS YOU
HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
REQUIREMENT TO TREATED.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO TRY TO SPEAK
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION ON THEIR
JUSTIFICATION I'M JUST DELIGHTED
TO SEE YOU.
I AM ON THE BUDGET AT THIS POINT
WHAT'S MORE OF A PROACTIVE
POSTURE AS AND WITH THAT YOU'RE
SUPPORTING AS OPPOSED TO HAVING.
TO HAVE US BEREACTIVE BY A
FEDERAL JUDGE HE I THINK THAT'S
A VERY FAIR WHERE I'M DESCRIBING
AN END SIMPLY MY REACTION -- TO
THE NUMBER OF DEATHS -- THAT I
THINK CAN BE AVOIDED BY
IMPLEMENTING THIS TYPE OF A
PROGRAM AND I KNOW SOMETIMES
DEATHS OF INMATES -- AND THE
FACT THAT EIGHT HUNDRED OF THEM
ARE HAVING OVERDOSES SOME PEOPLE
MAY NOT VIEW THAT.
WITH A SENSE OF URGENCY.
BUT I AM REQUIRED TO VIEW THAT
WITH A SENSE OF URGENCY WE HAVE
REDUCED AFFORDABLE DEATHS.
IN EVERY OTHER CATEGORY.
THIS ONE NOW -- IT POPS UP AND
SO I DO FEEL A SENSE OF URGENCY
ABOUT RESPONDING TO THIS CRISIS.
WAS A LAY PERSON I WOULD SEE A
PRISON AS A LARGE DETOX CENTER.
AS OVER A MUCH IN THE SAME WAY
THAT -- IN THE PRISONS ARE NOW
WERE YOU PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT.
BUT IT IT BE GREAT TO HAVE DETOX
IN A A LITTLE OF A TREATMENT BUT
AS LONG TERM.
SO THAT WHEN THEY'RE RELEASED
THEY CAN CONTINUE ON THAT
TREATMENT WAS NOT JUST DETOX IS
ACTUALLY LONG TERM CHRONIC
TREATMENT -- HOPEFULLY IN THE
END OF BEING ONE REASON WHY
MAYBE THAT PERSON CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL ON THE OUTSIDE.
SO IF I GET CANCER WHILE I'M IN
PRISON THAT'S ONE THING BUT IF I
CHOOSE TO TAKE DRUGS.
PATTERSON AGAIN THAT'S ALL
THAT'S A SELF CHOICE I HAVE NOW.
CREATED A HEALTH PROBLEM.
AT MY CHOICE.
DO I THEN BECOME RESPONSIBLE TO
PAY FOR THE DRUGS SAID YOU'RE
GOING TO GIVE ME TO OFFSET.
THAT DO I HAVE SOME KIND OF
RESPONSIBLE TO REIMBURSE TO
TAXPAYERS OR IS ADDICTION
CONSIDERED.
AN ILLNESS AND THEREFORE THE
EVERYTHING IS KICK THIS PAID FOR
FOR FREE ADDICTION IS CONSIDERED --
MOVED TO BE AN ILLNESS IN MUCH
THE SAME WAY AS DIABETES.
YOU COULD ARGUE THAT THE ARE
DIABETICS I HAVE MADE A CHOICE.
THEY EAT TOO MUCH SUGAR.
THEY DON'T EXERCISE.
OF SO WELL WILL WIRE WHY DON'T
THEY HAVE TO PAY FOR THEIR
DIABETIC TREATMENT WELL THAT'S
NOT THE WAY IT WORKS IN THE FREE
WORLD EITHER -- YOU.
DIABETIC COMES TO A DOCTOR NEEDS
MEDICALLY NECESSARY TREAT.
THIS IS THIS IS VERY MUCH BUTTE
AT THIS POINT AS SIMILAR TO THAT.
OF SOMEBODY WHO HAS THE SORT OF
AN ADDICTION ACTUALLY HANDLES OF
CHEMICAL CHANGES.
IN THEIR BRAIN.
THAT ADDICTS THEM THAT MAKES THE
CRAVING FOR THE DRUG WAS.
ABSOLUTELY IRRESISTIBLE.
NOT EXACTLY THE SAME WAY BUT IN
SOMEWHAT THE SAME WAY THAT I'VE
GOT A CRAVING FOR THAT NEXT
CANDY BAR -- THOUGH IT IS VIEWED
AS A MEDICAL ILLNESS.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME ASK
QUESTIONS ONE A ONE MR KELSO
THANK YOU MANAGER.
CERTAINLY.
I'M.
WHAT I WANTED -- TO REYES. FIVE
THE CLARIFICATION OF ITS
ADMINISTRATIVE PROPOSAL.
I'M WE THE SUBCOMMITTEE HAS BEEN
APPROVING OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS INCREASING ALLOCATIONS.
FOR I'M WILL CALL INTERDICTING
OR WHERE FOR NOTES THAT ANYWAY
TRYING TO KEEP THE DRUGS OUT.
AND IT SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF
MONEY.
AND YET EVEN WITH OUR INCREASES
OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS WHERE WE
HAVE AMPED UP. FIVE DRUG
SNIFFING DOG SCREENINGS --
SEARCHES A WHOLE VARIETY OF
THINGS WE ARE SEEING.
THIS DRAMATIC INCREASE AN
OVERDOSE DEATHS SO.
DO YOU KNOW ONE WOULD HAVE TO
SAY.
THAT SO FAR ARE EXPENDITURES ON
TRYING TO PREVENT THE DRUGS FROM
COMING IN.
HAVE YOU MET MAYBE IF WE HAD
NONE OF FOR THEM WE DO HAVE
WRITTEN MORE OVERDOSES BUT THERE
ISN'T THAT A GREAT CORRELATION
BETWEEN OUR EXPENDITURES IN
TRYING TO STOP THE DRUGS FROM
COMING IN.
AND A REDUCTION IN OVERDOSES AN
OVERDOSE DEATHS.
SO -- HI I THINK IT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR US TO LOOK AT I
MEAN IT IT.
IT MAKES NO SENSE ON THE ONE
HAND THAT.
PEOPLE WOULD OVERDOSE IMPRISONED
AND YET THAT IS THE CIRCUMSTANCE
WE HALF -- SO AS I THINK FOR FOR
ME THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
EXPENDITURE.
IT'S THERE ARE WHAT APPEARS.
AND CLEARLY STAFF CAN TALK MORE
TO THE RECEIVER NUMBERS OR TO
THE ADMINISTRATION.
IT WOULD APPEAR THAT THE LA OWES --
WHAT THE HIGHLIGHTED REGARDING --
THE FIVE MILLION.
FOUR I NALOXONE FOR THOSE WHO
ARE BEING RELEASED AS MAY BE --
A NUMBER THAT COULD BE ADJUSTED
CONSIDERING THAT WE HAVE BY
THEIR OWN ESTIMATES ONLY -- FOUR
THOUSAND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
PEOPLE BEING RELEASED EACH YEAR
SO BECAUSE OF A VARIETY OF
THINGS LIKE THAT I WANNA HOLD IT
OPEN I KNOW WE DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF TIME. TO GET SOME OF THIS
NAIL DOWN BUT CLEARLY I THINK WE
DO WANT TO GET IT NAILED DOWN
BEFORE WE WOULD -- ACT.
UGH BUT THE FINAL QUESTION I
WOULD HAVE -- BEFORE WE JUST
HOLD IT OPEN.
IS HOW CAN WE ENSURE I MEAN
THERE'S YOU KNOW PART OF THIS IS
THAT CAN FOR CONTINUITY OF CARE
ONCE THE RELEASED.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE NLOXONE
DOSES ARE.
FOR GIVING PEOPLE WHEN THEY
LEAVE BUT WHAT IN WHAT WAYS THIS
IS KIND OF PREDICATED ON THAT
ONCE THE PERSON IS RELEASED THAT
THERE.
THERE ARE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
WOULD CONTINUE TO BE TREATED SO
IN WHAT WAYS DO IS THIS.
PROGRAM ENSURING THAT.
IF AT ALL.
I THINK DOCTOR KING INCOMES BE
TO THAT BECAUSE THAT'S BEEN ONE
OF OUR BIGGEST FOCUSES AS HOW WE
COORDINATE THIS WITH LOCAL
PROVIDERS.
PARTICULARLY IN THOSE FIRST TWO
WEEKS SO THAT YOU CAN GET THE
CONNECTION MADE WHEN THEM AT
THAT POINT YOU KNOW YOUR
PATERNAL RESPONSIBILITY TO ON
THE THE PATIENT AND LOCAL
PROVIDERS BUT DR GAININGCAM
EXPLAIN WHERE WE ARE ON THAT.
YES AGAIN I THINK SOME OF THE
RESOURCES THAT WE REQUESTED
PARTICULARLY THE NURSING
RESOURCES AND SOME OF THE SOCIAL
WORKER OUT RESOURCES.
A VERY SPECIFICALLY ARE
TARGETING -- PATIENTS WHO ARE
LEAVING BOTH ON COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION AND A SUBSET OF
THOSE PATIENTS WHO ARE LEAVING
THROUGH PAROLE -- TO WORK WITH
THE COMMUNITY PROVIDERS AND TO
GET THOSE PATIENTS CONNECTED TO
THEIR FIRST APPOINTMENTS ALONG
WITH THE SOCIAL SERVICES THE
WRAPAROUND SOCIAL SERVICES.
I WILL SAY THAT -- AGAIN IN OUR
PILOT THE TWO PILOTS
INSTITUTIONS ONE OF THE REALLY
BIG SUCCESS STORIES PROBABLY THE
MOST IMPORTANT.
LESSON LEARNED FROM THOSE PILOTS
IS THAN US JUST USING A SMALL
NUMBER OF SOCIALWORKERS WITH
THE ADDICTION SPECIALIST
DEVELOPING THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
OUT IN THE COUNTIES.
WE WERE ABLE TO GET -- ALMOST
80% OF OUR PATIENTS CONNECTED TO
COMMUNITY RESOURCES AND THOSE
FIRST APPOINTMENTS AND THAT IS.
THREE TO FOUR TIMES HIGHER THAN
WE SEE -- WITHOUT THOSE --
TRANSITION RESOURCES REALLY
HELPING THAT PERSON HAND OVER
HAND MAKE THOSE APPOINTMENTS SO --
WE DO A VERY POOR JOB QUITE
FRANKLY -- BUT WITH THESE PILOTS
AND THAT MODEL WHERE WE HAVE A
SOCIAL WORKER THE NURSES AND THE
ADDICTION SPECIALIST -- WE DID
CONNECT THOSE PATIENTS AT IN
ABOUT 76% WHICH IS VERY VERY
HIGH.
RIGHT SO BEFORE A ASK FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT IS THERE ANY OTHER
COMMON OR QUESTIONS BY
DEPARTMENT FINANCE CáC C<c.cyan>G</c>
COME DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
THINK I WOULD JUST ECHO THE
RECEIVERS COMMENTS ON THIS BEING
AN ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL --
THE DEATH RATE HAS INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT FACTOR INTO HOW WE
RECOGNIZE WHERE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES MAY BE NEEDED -- I
THINK THE RECEIVERS.
FOCUS ON THIS PROGRAM IS
DEFINITELY NECESSARY GIVEN THE
ENERGY INTEGRATION WITH THAT
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM GENERALLY SO
WELL THERE'S DEFINITELY OVERLAP
IN APPEARANCE OF MAYBE EXPANSION
AND ACTIVITIES I THINK -- THE
THE RECEIVER STAY FOCUSED ON THE
ISSUE OF THE DEATH RATE IN
ADDRESSING THAT I THINK THERE'S
QUITE A BIT IN THIS PROPOSAL
THAT HASN'T BEEN THIS DISCUSSED
IN DEPTH TODAY THAT IS ACTUALLY.
RELATED TO CDC ARE PROPER AND I
THINK THOSE ARE ALSO -- VERY
IMPORTANT RESOURCES TO MAKING AN
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM SO
[inaudible]
THAT'S IT.
I'M PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE SIDE
OF YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR IN
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MARIE
SALINAS CHIEF OPERATING ALSO FOR
CENTERPOINT.
BUT I'M HERE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES -- AND I WANT TO
PRESENT OUR COLLECTIVE VIEW.
ON THIS PROPOSAL WHICH WILL AIR.
IN FAVOR OF MOST OF THIS
PROPOSAL -- IF IT'S A LONG WE
CAN YOU CAN GIVE IT TO US IN
WRITING BECAUSE WE ARE HOLDING
IT OPEN.
IF YOU WANT TO STIR SUMMARIZE
AND AND GIVE US THE COMMENTS IN
WRITING THAT WOULD BE
APPRECIATED WE WILL PRESENT A
FORMAL LETTER TO THE OFFICER
WILL BE DELIVERED TODAY AND I
WILL SUMMARIZE IT. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THAT CAP HE SUPPORTS
AS THE CONFERENCE OF YOUR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER.
AND A TREATABLE CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITION AS A TREATABLE HEALTH
CONDITION.
THE INCLUSION OF A FULL RANGE OF
FOOD OF FTA DRUGS.
APPROVED MEDICATED ASSISTED
TREATMENT FOR ALCOHOL USE
DISORDERS.
AND HOPE YOUR USE DISORDER.
THE INCLUSION OF RECESS A
STRATIFICATION TREATMENT STAGING
THE ISSUE OF THE PEOPLE WITH THE
HIGHEST NEED A PART I HAVE. FOR
SERVICES AS A SYSTEM IS
DEVELOPED AND EFFORTS THAT
PARALLEL.
AND FEED INTO THE STATE'S
COMMUNITY BASED DRUG AND ALCOHOL%
ORGANIZED DELIVERY SYSTEM I'LL
SUMMARIZE THE OTHER AREAS.
KATHY HAS QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE FOLLOWING THINGS.
LACK OF ALIGNMENT WITH THE STATE --
DMC ODS SYSTEM AND CREATE AN
INCREASE COSTS AND COMPLEXITY.
CURRENTLY -- DOES PROPOSAL THAT
NURSES PROVIDE A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THE WORK IS GOING TO
BE ADMINISTERED.
THIS IS NOT TRADITIONAL WORKED
AT NURSES DO -- THIS
TRADITIONALLY DONE BY CERTIFIED
COUNCILS.
AND BY -- LICENSED CLINICIANS.
OUR NURSES RECEIVED VERY LITTLE.
EDUCATION.
OUR ON SUBSTANCE USE OUR
TREATMENT.
AND A PROPOSES THE FOR COMPARING --
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IN
ORDER TO IMPLEMENT THIS PROPOSAL
IS GOING TO BE A REALLY HAVE A
HEAVY LIFT IS NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE
WE WE ARE WE ENCOURAGED INCREASE
SALARIES.
THAT ARE NEAR TO BE COMPETITIVE
THE HARD TO STAFF.
HOWEVER THERE JUST ISN'T THE
WORK FORCE CURRENTLY IN THE
STATE SO WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE A
PHASED IN APPROACH RATHER THAN.
JUST TO MAKE IT WHERE EVERYBODY
HAS TO BE CERTIFIED IS GOING TO
BE REALLY DIFFICULT STAFF
[inaudible]
ARE WE REALLY ENCOURAGED THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE LOCKS ALL.
IN THE PRISONS NOT JUST AT THIS
CHARGE.
WE DO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM
WITH -- MH OVERDOSING WHEN THEY
ARE RELEASED FROM PRISON.
HOWEVER AS YOU CAN HEAR THE
NUMBERS THERE'S A NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE OLD B. AND
IN THE PRESENCE.
SO WE DON'T WANT IT JUST TO BE --
ADMINISTRATIVE DISCHARGE.
BUT WHILE THE IN THE PRISONS IS
VERY LITTLE RISK.
OF ABUSE ALL HALL FROM INMATES
HAPPEN THE LOCKS ALL.
THE AVAILABILITY AND UNLOCKS ON
I'LL LAVE IT AT THAT AND OUT
MAKE SURE THAT YOU GET A COPY.
OF THE FULL PRESENTATION.
AND IF WE CAN GET THAT SOONER
THAN LATER AS WE'LL CALL YOU YOU
WILL GET IT TODAY WE AREMEETING
AGAIN ON THURSDAY YOU WILL GET
IT TODAY.
WILL BE DELIVERED TODAY OKAY.
SO ON THE WHOLE THIS ITEM OPEN
AND WE ARE GOING TO RECESS NOW.
AND WE WILL RETURN AT
START THE PRESENTATION TO OUR
OTHER MEMBER JOINS US.
BUT THE ITEM THAT.
THE ITEM THAT WE'RE GONNA GO.
TO IS -- ITEM ZERO EIGHT TWENTY
UNDER DOJ ISSUE TWENTY SIX SO IF
WE HAVE -- ANYONE FROM
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO PRESENT.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT THEY CAN
COME TO THE TABLE NOW.
EXCELLENT SO -- I PUT THE GAVEL
DOWN BUT I DIDN'T FORMALLY SAY.
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY ARE RATHER OUR
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE SEVEN
FIVE PUBLIC SAFETY IN THE
JUDICIARY IS RETURNED FROM
RECESS.
AND WE ARE STARTING WITH -- ITEM
ZERO EIGHT TWENTY DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ISSUE TWENTY SIX PAYMENT
OF SETTLEMENTS AND JUDGMENTS GO
AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CHRIS RYAN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
ON THIS ISSUE RELATES TO A BILL
THAT WAS PASSED -- BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN IT WAS AB SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE IT WAS AND AN ACTOR
REQUIRED CERTAIN REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES. TO MAKE
CERTAINDISCLOSURES TO CLIENTS
OR PTENTIAL CLIENTS.
IN EACH OF THE FOLLOWING FIVE
CASES A PLAINTIFF OR A GROUP OF
PLAINTIFFS MOUNTED OF FREE
SPEECH -- AND OR FREEDOM OF
RELIGION CONSTITUTIONAL
CHALLENGE TO THE ACT.
NAMING -- AGP SIR AS A DEFENDANT
ALTHOUGH THE ACT WAS NEVER
ENFORCED BY THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE -- THESE LAWSUITS FOR TO
PREVENT THE APPLICATION OF AB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE OR THE
PLAINTIFFS IN THESE FIVE CASES
DID NOT SEEK MONETARY DAMAGES.
AND WE'RE SEEKING ONLY TO
INVALIDATE THE ACT.
PLAINTIFFS EVENTUALLY SUCCEEDED
IN INVALIDATING THE ACT BY
TAKING THE LEAD CASE -- WHICH IS
THE NTIONAL INSTITUTE OF FAMILY
AND LIFE ADVOCATES PEOPLE SERRA.
TO THE SUPREME COURT THE JUNE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN US SUPREME COURT
DECISION AND THE FLORA THE THE
SERRA RULED THAT THE DEVIL
PLAINTIFFS WERE ENTITLED TO A
PRELIMINARY INJUNCTION.
AGAINST ENFORCEMENT OF THE ACT
EFFECTIVELY SECURING VICTORY FOR
THE ALL THE PLAINTIFFS IN ALL
THE CASES.
THIS ISSUE -- IN THE MAY REVISE
IS FOR TWO POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO PAY THOSE ATTORNEYS
FEES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PLAINTIFFS [inaudible]
YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- I WOULD
WIN WIN OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS
HERE I ASKED HIM SPECIFICALLY
WHAT.
DID HE SPENT WITH HIS DEPARTMENT
IS WERE CONCERNED ABOUT.
YOU KNOW ALL THESE ACTIVITIES
AND AND THE EMAIL THAT WE GOT
BACK WAS EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS SO
TAXPAYERS PAID. TO OUR STAFF IS
IT THE AG'S OFFICE AND NOW WE'RE
GONNA SPEND ANOTHER TWO POINT
ONCE WE'RE GETTING CLOSE TO
THREE MILLION. FOR FOR ONE
PARTICULAR BILL THAT YOU KNOW
YOU CAN KIND OF SEE WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL FROM THE GET GO
YOU DIDN'T I'M NOT A LAWYER BUT
YOU CAN KIND OF SEE THAT THERE'S
GONNA BE SOME TROUBLE WITH THIS
PARTICULAR BILL.
SO I JUST WONDER.
WHAT DEPARTMENT BEARS THE BRUNT
OF THIS TWO POINT ONE MILLION IS
IT?
WHO THE WHAT WHAT WHERE DOES IT
COME FROM BORDERS ORDER WHO'S
PAYING THIS FOR THIS FOR THIS IS
A TO YOUR POINT -- EARLIER THERE
WAS THE STAFF TIME ASSOCIATED
WITH THE ATTORNEYS AND THAT WAS
THE THE EMAIL THAT WE SHARED
WITH THE STAFF -- THE COSTS I
THINK WAS EIGHT HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND THIS IS TO PAY THOSE
SETTLEMENT FEES FOR THE THE
PLAINTIFFS AND SO.
TYPICALLY THIS WOULD BE THROUGH
THE CLAIMS BILL PROCESS -- AND
SO THESE TYPES OF CASES ARE PAID
THROUGH THAT CLAIM SO PROCESS
BECAUSE THESE PAYMENTS ARE DUE --
AND I END UP LOOKING TO
DEPARTMENT FINANCE FOR TIMING ON
THIS BUT THESE THESE PAYMENTS
ARE DUE PROBABLY EARLIER THAN
THE NEXT CLAIMS WILL PROCESS OF
DOING AVOID PAYING ADDITIONAL
INTEREST AND AND PENALTIES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT ON THESE.
SETTLED -- AGREEMENTS -- IT WAS
PUT INTO THE BUDGET -- THE MAY
REVIVE I GUESS CHRIS THAT THE
QUESTION IS DOES IT COME OUT OF
THE DOJ'S BUDGET.
NUMBER SIX OKAY NOW I'M OUT OF A
DO WE SELF INSURE FOR THESE.
ARE THESE ARE TYPICALLY PAID --
FROM A GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION OR OTHER SPECIAL
FUNDS IN THE CLAIMS BILL PROCESS
BUT THERE'S A SPECIAL DEPARTMENT
ON THAT BUDGETS ITS CLAIMS.
THERE'S A YOU WANNA.
FINANCE FINANCE THANK YOU --
TYPICALLY THAT CLEANS BILL --
WHEN IT GOES THROUGH IT'LL SAY
IT IS HEREBY APPROPRIATED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO PAY FOR
THESE VERY SPECIFIC CLAIMS -- I
THINK THERE WAS JUST ONE THAT
HAPPENED -- THIS PAST COUPLE
MONTHS AGO SB FOUR EIGHTEEN DID
VERY SIMILAR THING WHENEVER
THERE'S SETTLEMENTS AGAINST THE
STATE.
IT'S TYPICALLY PAY FOR OUT OF
DIRECT APPROPRIATIONS FROM A
CLAIMS BELL -- WE DO ALSO
INCLUDE THEM IN THE BUDGET
THOUGH DEPENDING ON THE TIMING
OF WHEN THEY'RE DO AND THE
TIMING OF WHEN THE CLING STILL
HAPPENS -- AT THE SOURCE OF THE
FUNDS IN THE CLAIMS BILL WOULD
BE -- IT'S I CAN BE IT CAN VERY
I THINK -- IT CAN BE GENERAL
FUND I THINK MOST COMMONLY IS
GENERAL FUND BUT DEPENDING ON
I'M AN ACCOUNTANT SO I'M USED TO
A CHART OF ACCOUNTS.
SO WHAT ACCOUNT IS IT COMING OUT
OF THIS COME OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY.
ADMINISTRATIVE ACCOUNT IS A THE
BILL CAME OUT OF THERE.
NOW IT WOULD -- IT WOULD COME
JUST OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND POT
THAT WE HAVE FOR THE STATE IS
THAT WHATEVER IS IN THE RESERVES
IN THE GENERAL FUND.
IS WHAT COMES OUT OF ITS NOT
BUDGET OTHER.
YEAH IT'S NOT REALLY BUDGETED
FOR LIKE SPECIFIC DEPARTMENTS OR
SPECIFIC CATEGORIES OR ANYTHING
IT'S JUST KIND OF WHAT WE
LEARNED FROM FROM THIS HOW IT
DOES THIS HAPPEN OFTEN WHERE WE
DO A BILL AND IT GOES ALL THE
WAY THROUGH AND GETS BEAT UP AT
THE STATE.
U. S. SUPREME COURT IN THIS CASE.
AND SO NOW WE HAVE TO SPEND
THREE MILLION.
FOR IT WOULD HOW DO WE HOW DO WE
LEARN FROM THAT BECAUSE AT THAT
COULD GET EXPENSIVE -- WE DO
THIS ALL THE TIME RIGHT.
YEAH THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION I
THINK -- THE IDEA THAT HE MIGHT
BE BETTER BECAUSE THEY DO ARE
THEY ARE THE PEOPLE THAT DO
REPRESENT THE STATE BUT I WILL
SAY THAT CLEANS WHEELS OFF -- TO
HAPPEN PRETTY OFTEN I MEAN IT IS
TWICE A YEAR WHERE WE HAVE
CLAIMS AGAINST THE STATE -- THAT
ARE APPROPRIATE IN THE CLAIMS
BILL USUALLY ONE SPRING ONE IN
THE FALL -- ANYTHING THERE'S
USUALLY A NUMBER OF SETTLEMENTS
BUT DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE.
YEAH I MEAN JUST ADDED THAT
THERE ARE VARIOUS CLAIMS THAT
COME THROUGH THE THE PROCESS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR -- ON ON
VARIOUS MATTERS SOMETIMES IT'S
THAT LEGISLATION -- SOMETIMES
IT'S A LOSS -- DUE TO YOU
NATURAL DISASTER AND THINGS LIKE
THAT SO IT VARIES QUITE A BIT I
I THINK IT'S BEEN QUITE AWHILE
SINCE WE'VE SEEN ONE LIKE THIS.
LIKE THIS -- BUT WE WILL KEEPTRACK OF IT AND CAN YOU SHARE
WITH YOUR STAFF IN THE FUTURE --
BUT HI I JUST.
IT'S ALWAYS THAT ERRORS THE GULF
A MAN THIS IS GOING TO BE
INTRANSIGENT BUT ABOUT FORTY
MAYBE THEY'LL MAYBE IT WAS
LITTLE -- WHAT WE NEED TO COOK A
LITTLE MORE OR WHATEVER YOU KNOW
YEAH HERE AS IT MOVES THROUGH
THE PROCESS?
AND THEN HERE IS A LIVE YOU KNOW
TO TO TRY TO EXPERIMENT IT GETS
PRETTY EXPENSIVE AND TIME I JUST
WANTED.
TO FIGURE OUT.
YOU KNOW HOW TO HOW TO GET BACK
TO US [inaudible]
AS LEGISLATORS [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE TRIED THIS AND AND WE LOST
RIGHT.
SO IS IT THE GOVERNOR THAT'S
LIKE THE BACKSTOP WHICH AT THAT
RELY ON THE GOVERNOR'S VETO FOR
BILLS LIKE THIS SO THEY DO LIKE
A LEGAL ANALYSIS WHEN THERE'S
THERE'S THE PROCESS AT ALL THE
BILLS GO THROUGH -- AND THE
VARIOUS COMMITTEE PROCESS -- BUT
THE CLAIMS BILL I THINK IS A
POLICY WHERE YOU WOULD SEE IT ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS -- AND AND
SOMEBODY PAYING ATTENTION TO THE
CLAIMS BILL -- AND DOING THE
ANALYSIS COULD TRACK HOW MANY OF
THESE CASES THERE ARE FROM YEAR
TO YEAR SO THAT'S THE TYPICAL
PROCESS MOST OF THESE GO THROUGH.
I I WILL MOVE THE ITEM MANAGER
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME
[inaudible]
TRY.
TO PEEL THE ONION A LITTLE BIT
CERTAINLY.
I'VE IRONICALLY WE EN
[inaudible]
WHAT WE'VE?
SOME OF THE ITEMS THAT WE'VE
BEEN DEALING WITH ARE ITEMS THAT.
WERE COMPELLED TO HAVE TO MAKE
THE EXPENDITURE DUE TO A COURT
ACTION BUT IT'S NOT SO MUCH FROM
A BILL.
THAT WAS BECAUSE TO BE
pINTERVENING WHERE THEY FELT THAT
WE DID NOT ACT.
YET APPROPRIATELY SO WHEN WE
LOOK AT WHEN THE RECEIVER IS
HERE.
ALL OF THE INCREASED COST.
NOT ALL BUT MOST FROM FROM.
AT THAT HE BRINGS TO US WHICH
HAVE BEEN QUITE SIGNIFICAN LAST
FEW YEARS [inaudible]
CORD ACTION.
NOW WE JUST GOT ONE AGAIN --
WITH -- GETTING A SETTLEMENT FOR
MORTGAGE.
FINE SO I JUST GOT.
YEAH.
JUST DECIDED SO THERE'S PROBABLY
MORE LAWYER FEES THAT WE HAVE TO
PAY FOR IT.
AND SOME OF THOSE -- SETTLEMENTS
ARE REIMBURSING -- VARIOUS
LAWYERS SO THERE'S NOT AN ASK
FOR MORE MONEY BUT THERE'S A
SETTLEMENT PROCESS THAT'S
REIMBURSING -- THE COST OF THOSE
ATTORNEYS.
RESTAURANT THANK YOU.
WE'VE GOT A MOTION -- IN ITS THE
TO APPROVE AS PROPOSED AND WILL
DO A ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER HI CENTER MORE
LAKAI SENATOR BELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO NOW WE
WILL AND THAT BY.
THE WILL TO THAT'S THE END OF
OUR DOJ ISSUES -- PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THAT ITEM.
ALRIGHT WILL NOW MOVE TO OUR
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION.
IT'S ITEM.
FIVE TWO TWO FIVE ISSUE TWENTY
SEVEN AND IT'S IN -- INFIRM IT'S
MOSTLY INFORMATION ALTHOUGH IT
DOES SUGGEST OUR EXPENDITURES.
BASED ON THE POPULATION
ADJUSTMENT SO.
MISTER SWANSON MAISIE PERCY ALL
RIGHT.
AGAIN AMERICA SWANSON W.
DIRECTOR CCAR'S OFFICE OF FISCAL
SERVICES -- CDC ARE UPDATES OUR
POPULATION ESTIMATES TWICE PER
YEAR.
ON JANUARY TEN ENEMY REVISION --
IT'S ALL INCLUDED WE HAVE IT'S A
WE DO A BUNCH OF POPULATION
JUDGMENTS ARE ALL IN THIS SORT
OF BINDER WE DISTRIBUTE.
TO LA -- WITH ALLEGE STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS -- BUT THERE ARE
THREE POPULATION BASE PROPOSALS
THAT YOU'VE NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA.
BUT DEPARTMENTS REQUESTED HE HAS
COMPARED TO THE JANUARY BUDGET.
AROUND A SEVENTY SEVENTEEN POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLAR REDUCTION
ARNOLD INSTITUTIONS.
IN EIGHT POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASED OUR CUSTODY TO
COMMUNITY TRANSITIONAL REENTRY
PROGRAMS.
AND A SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE FOR JUVENILE
FACILITIES -- HI BEFORE WE I
WANT TO GET -- TO JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK OF THE LA --
BECAUSE THE FIGURES THAT I'VE.
SAID TO YOU RIGHT NOW ARE GOING
TO BE ADJUSTED BASED ON SOME OF
THE FINDINGS OF THE LA ALWAYS
MADE AND WE AGREE WITH -- WE'RE
IN THE PROCESS OF GOING THROUGH
THAT -- ESTIMATE RIGHT NOW BUT I
DO WANT TO INTRODUCE TO YOU --
CHRIS CHAMBERS TO SEE SOCIAL
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
RESEARCH AND HE'S GOING TO TALK
TO A LITTLE BIT ABOUT GENERAL
POPULATION TRENDS BEFORE WE TALK
ABOUT THAT -- TO BEFORE WE HEAR
FROM YOU.
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE INDICATING
NOW OUR RECOMMENDATION IS TO
HOLD THIS ITM OPEN AND I THINK
WHAT YOU ARE INDICATING IS THATYOU WOULD AGREE WITH THAT
BECAUSE YOU ARE GOING TO ALREADY.
A CHEST THESE NUMBERS BASED ON
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT THE LA --
RACED BAGS THAT'S RIGHT ALRIGHT
SO WE WILL HEAR FROM LA -- JUST
SO ALL MY COLLEAGUES CAN.
IT'S IN THE ANALYSIS BUT JUST IN
CASE -- SO THAT WAY HOPEFULLY
WHEN THE ITEM COMES BACK GIVEN
OR TRUNCATED TIME PERIOD.
WE'D BE ABLE TO ACT.
I'M PRETTY.
QUICKLY BUT WILL.
PROCEED WITH THIS DISCUSSION AND
LEARN ABOUT WHAT WAYS THEME
MIGHT BE ADJUSTED.
GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
SENATORS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
PRODUCES POPULATION PROJECTIONS.
OVER THE YEARS THE DEPARTMENT
HAS FOUND THAT FUTURE
INSTITUTION.
FUTURE INSTITUTION POPULATION A
SHAKE MOSTLY BY COURT
COMMITMENTS.
HOW MANY THE SENTENCE TYPE
WHETHER DIED DETERMINAR LIFE
SENTENCE?
UNLIKE THE STAY.
ADDITIONALLY OTHER FACTORS
INCLUDING STATUTORY REVISIONS
BALLOT INITIATIVES.
IN POLICY CHANGES HAVE IMPACT.
TV STARS MOST CURRENT
PROJECTIONS ARE PUBLISHED.
IN THE SPRING TWENTY NINETEEN
POPULATION PROJECTIONS REPORT.
THIS REPORT WAS RELEASED I
BELIEVE ABOUT A WEEK AGO.
IN THIS REPORT -- WE INCLUDE TWO
SETS O ADULT PROJECTION
DISPLAYS OR MORE TRADITIONAL IN
MEN ARE AN ADDITIONAL DISPLAY --
THAT WE'VE BEEN ASKED BY BY
DEMAND THAT SHOW SEVERAL POLICY
CHANGES RECENTLY IMPLEMENTED BY
THE DEPARTMENT.
THOSE POLICY CHANGES INCLUDE.
SUPPLEMENTAL REFORMS TO CREDIT
EARNINGS INCLUDING -- INCREASES
TO REHABILITATE OF ACHIEVEMENT
IN EDUCATIONAL MERITS CREDITS.
IN CHANGE TO NINE PER SIXTY DAY
RELEASE RESTRICTION.
PEARL DETERMINATION PROCESS FOR
INDETERMINATE LEE SENTENCED
NONVIOLENT OFFENDERS.
AS WELL AS PENAL CODE SECTION
ELEVEN SEVENTY D. RECALL IN
RECENT AND TING CHANGES.
OVERALL.
THESE CHANGES ARE EXPECTED TO
DECREASE INSTITUTION POPULATION
AND INCREASE THE PAROLE
POPULATION.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT FEW
YEARS.
LOOKING AT WHERE WE ARE NOW THE
DAHLE INSTITUTION POPULATION IS
PROJECTED TO DECREASE OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS.
WE ARE PROJECTING CLOSING THIS
FISCAL YEAR OUT WITH A AN ADULT
POPULATION OF A HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX SIX NINETY GIVEN WHERE WERE
AT I THINK WERE JUST A FEW
HUNDRED OFFICE NUMBER RIGHT NOW
SO WE ARE ON TRACK WITH THIS.
WE PROJECT OVER THE COURSE OF
THE NEXT TWO FISCAL YEARS OUR
POPULATION TO DECREASE ROUGHLY
BY ABOUT A TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
ABOUT 2% OVERALL.
LOOKING A PAROLE POPULATION PRO
POPULATION IS EXPECTED TO CLOSE
THIS FISCAL YEAR OUT AT FORTY
NINE FOUR OH THREE IN INCREASE
OVERALL DURING THE SPAN OF THE
NEXT TWO FISCAL YEARS BY ABOUT
NINE HUNDRED AND THIRTY PAROLEES.
OR ONE POINT.
SO THAT CONCLUDES MY MY BRIEF
SUMMARY.
IT WILL BE FOR WE HEAR FROM LA --
I JUST HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS ON
THE COMMUNITY -- THE CUSTODY TO
COMMUNITY TRANSITIONAL REENTRY
WHICH I DON'T THINK IS THE
SUBJECT OF MOST OF YOUR COMMENTS
AROUND JUSTICE POPULATION
CALCULATION ARE YOU DID HAVE
SOMEONE THAT -- PART ONE TO
PROCEED IN AN OFFICE MY
QUESTIONS DO YOU LIKE ME AT
CAITLYN O'NEILL WITH THE LA --
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO GIVE OUR
COMMENTS ON THE WHOLE THING OKAY --
SO REGARDING THE A DAHLE INMATE
POPULATION AT AS WAS INDICATED
THE DEPARTMENT PRODUCED TWO SETS
OF PROJECTIONS FOR THE ADULT AND
MADE POPULATION THIS MAY ONE IS.
A DOWNWARD ADJUSTMENT JUST BASED
ON HAVING MORE ACTUAL DATA SINCE
THAT -- JANUARY PROJECTIONS WERE
RELEASED THE SECOND ADDRESS
FURTHER DOWNWARD BASED ON THE
ANTICIPATED EFFECT OF THE POLICY
CHANGES THAT WERE LISTED -- THE
BUDGET ADJUSTMENT WAS BASED AS
AS FAR AS I UNDERSTAND --
ACCIDENTALLY OFF OF THE FIRST
SET OF PROJECTION SET SO -- THE
DEPARTMENT IS WORKING TO UPDATE
THAT BUDGET ADJUSTMENT TO
INCLUDE THE ADDITIONAL DECLINE
THAT'S PROJECTED AS A AS A
RESULT OF THIS THE POLICY
CHANGES.
AND SO WE WILL CERTAINLY REVIEW
THAT BUDGET ADJUSTMENT AND
COMMUNICATE ANY CONCERNS WE
IDENTIFY TO THE COMMITTEE.
EN WHAT YOU WHAT YOU'RE
INDICATING IS THAT IN OTHER
WORDS THEY I AM.
WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE US IS A
POPULATION ADJUSTMENT BASED ON?
IT FIGURES.
AND IT DOES NOT INCORPORATE THE
THE COURT ACTION IN A COUPLE OF
OTHER ACTIONS THAT WOULD.
UNDER PROP FIFTY SEVEN AND A FEW
OTHER THINGS POTENTIALLY HAVE
FOLKS WITH EARNING CREDITS BE
ABLE TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR PAROLE.
POTENTIALLY SOONER WHICH MAY
FURTHER REDUCE THE POPULATION
THAT CRACKED OKAY.
AND SO WE'RE GONNA.
IN ONE ITEM COMES BACK WE'LL GET
ADJUSTED NUMBERS.
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY AND ONE
OTHER RECOMMENDATION THAT IS
NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA ON THIS
NOTE ON THIS TOPIC IS -- WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED STATUTE REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT TO NOTIFY THE
LEGISLATURE AND PROVIDE.
A POPULATION IMPACT ESTIMATES
WHEN IT MAKES FURTHER CHANGES TO
ITS CREDIT EARNING REGULATIONS
AS CHANGES TO CREDIT EARNING CAN
HAVE AS WE SAW IN THIS CASE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
POPULATION WHICH IS.
IMPORTANT FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
HAVE AS IT CONSIDERS CCAR'S
RESOURCE NEEDS AND OTHER RELATED --
POLICY ISSUES [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND THEN YOU HAD AS A THING ON A
CUSTODY TO COMMUNITY
TRANSITIONAL REENTRY YES.
SO WE WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
PROGRAM SHOULD BE EVALUATED FOR
COST EFFECTIVENESS BEFORE IT IS
EXPANDED.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S EASY TO
YOUR P. ARE THE EXPANSION OF C.
C. T. R. P. ACCORDING TO THE
COST ESTIMATES AND THE PROPOSAL
WOULD BE FIVE TIMES MORE
EXPENSIVE DâN -- ON A ON A PER
INMATE BASIS DAN WHERE THESE
WOMEN WOULD BE HOUSED UNDER THE
STATUS QUO.
THIS MEANS THAT CC TO YOUR P.
WOULD NEED TO BE ESSENTIALLY
MORE THAN FIVE TIMES AS
EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING RECIDIVIST
RECIDIVISM RECRUITING OTHER
BENEFITS.
AS A STANDARD PRISON ENVIRONMENT.
HOWEVER THERE SIMPLY ISN'T -- WE
A SIMPLY DON'T KNOW HOW
EFFECTIVE THE CC TEAR P. PROGRAM
IS GIVEN THAT HASN'T BEEN
EVALUATED.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS PROVIDED SOME
DATA INDICATING THAT WOMEN WHO
PARTICIPATE IN CC TEAR P. ARE
LESS LIKELY TO RESET OF EIGHT
THAN WOMEN WHO DON'T PARTICIPATE
IN CC TEAR HE HOWEVER THAT ISN'T
REALLY AN APPLES TO APPLES
COMPARISON -- BECAUSE IT'S NOT
CLEAR WHETHER IT'S THE PROGRAM
THAT'S RESULTING IN THEM BEING
LESS LIKELY TO RESET OF EIGHT OR
IF IT'S SUB SOMETHING TO DO WITH
HOW THE WOMEN ARE SELECTED INTO
THE PROGRAM IN OTHER WORDS THAT
THE PROGRAM IS SORT OF NATURALLY
SELECTING -- INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
LESS LIKELY TO RESET DEBATE TO
BEGIN WITH.
AND THIS IS THE KIND OF THING
THAT RESEARCHERS WOULD
POTENTIALLY BE ABLE TO TEASE OUT
IN OTHER WORDS -- BY HAVING
RESEARCHERS LOOK AT THIS PROGRAM
THEY COULD POTENTIALLY COME UP
WITH A CREDIBLE -- ESTIMATE
ESSENTIALLY OF HOW EFFECTIVE THE
PROGRAM IS.
WHICH WOULD -- BE VERY VALUABLE
FOR THE LEGISLATURE HAVE AS IT
CONSIDERS POTENTIAL EXPANSIONS --
SO WE DO RECOMMEND THAT WHETHER
OR NOT YOU APPROVED THIS
EXPANSION THAT YOU REQUIRE AN
INDEPENDENT STUDY OF THE
PROGRAM'S COST EFFECTIVENESS --
BECAUSE HAVING THIS INFORMATION
WOULD ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE --
TO ASSESS WHETHER AND CONTINUING
TO INVEST IN THIS PROGRAM -- IS
ALLOWING IT TO ESSENTIALLY
PREVENT -- MORE VICTIMS OR
REGENERATE OTHER BENEFITS DâN
CHOOSING TO INVESTORS RECESS
RESOURCES ELSEWHERE [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO MY QUESTIONS.
RIGHT NOW.
THE I SEE COMMUNITY TRANSITION
RAINTREE PROGRAM.
HAS LOCATIONS IN SAN DIEGO SANTA
FE SPRINGS SPEAKERS FILL
STOCKTON IN SACRAMENTO.
EN ROUTE WE HAVE IN OUR REPORT
THE NUMBER OF BEDS.
ARE THOSE FULL RIGHT NOW ARE
THOSE FLOOR THE BEDS FULL -- LET
ME CALL UP AMY MILLER WHOSE --
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF OUR
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AMY
MILLER.
AND THOSE BEDS ARE FULL SO WE
HAVE.
SO THERE'S A NATURAL -- TURNOVER
SO AS A AND D. WERE FILLING
BEHIND THEM WE DO CURRENTLY HAVE
A WAIT LIST OF APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED WOMEN WAITING TO GET
INTO THOSE PROGRAMS THEY'RE ALL
VOLUNTARY SO THE WOMEN ACTUALLY.
A VOLUNTEER FOR THE PROGRAM AND
THEN THEY ALSO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SELECT WHICH
FACILITY THEY'D LIKE TO GO -- TO
SO SOME OF THEM CHOOSE TO BE
CLOSER TO HOME CLOSER TO
FAMILIES OTHERS LOOKING FOR A
FRESH START.
BUT AS OF RIGHT NOW THAT WAIT
LIST WE HAVE WAIT LISTS FOR
EVERY SINGLE FACILITY AND THEY
ARE BEING KEPT FULL SO AS WOMEN
EXIT.
DATE THEN ARE ARE BEING PLACED
ON WITHIN A WEEK OR SO WERE
FILLING THOSE BETS BEHIND THEM.
ARE THESE -- TRANSITIONAL
FACILITIES.
IT UP IN A WAY THAT.
THE STATE COULD POTENTIALLY.
CHARGE MEDI CAL [inaudible]
I'M.
IT RECOVER COSTS.
FOR THESE FOLKS THAT WE MIGHT
RECOVER IF THEY WERE IN.
YOU KNOW THAT WE CANNOT RECOVER.
IF WE HOLD THEM IN OUR STATE
FACILITY OUR STATE PRISON
FACILITY SO WE ACTUALLY HOPE TO
THAT THAT WOULD BE THE CASE AND
WHEN THOSE -- PROGRAMS WERE
INITIALLY BROUGHT ONLINE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN AND AS
WE'VE EXPANDED -- WE BELIEVE
THAT THEY DID MEET THE CRITERIA
HOWEVER WE HAD SOME EXTENSIVE
MEETINGS OVER ABOUT EIGHTEEN
MONTHS TO TWO YEARS WITH
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
AT WHICH TIME THEY ULTIMATELY
DECIDED THAT ARE WOMEN DID NOT
MEET THE CRITERIA FOR MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY BECAUSE THEY WERE
TECHNICALLY STILL INMATES.
NOT RELEASED ON PAROLE AND THAT
THEY COULD BE RETURNED INTO THE
STATE PRISONS AT ANY TIME -- AS
THE POLICY WORKS SO LIKE I SAID
WE SPENT A COUPLE OF YEARS
TRYING TO GET THOSE WOMEN
APPROVED FOR MEDI CAL ULTIMATELY.
THAT THAT WAS DISAPPROVED SO
CURRENTLY WE WORK WITH OUR
HEALTH CARE SERVICES VERY
CLOSELY THEY'VE WE'VE WORKED
WITH -- CLINICS IN THE AREA AND
WE WORK THROUGH HEALTH NET TO
GET THEM SERVICES SO THERE'S NO
IMPACT ACCESS TO CARE
[inaudible]
IT'S SO WHEN WE FIRST APPROVED
THIS IT WAS ANTICIPATED THAT THE
COST MIGHT BE LESS. TO THE STATE
FOR THEIR FOR HOLDING THEM.
OR FOR THEIR BEING IN THESE
TRANSITIONAL FACILITIES VERSUS
BEING HELD.
IN OUR CORRECTIONS FACILITY
THAT'S CORRECT THAT WAS THE
ASSUMPTION AT THE TOP RIGHT NOW
THE COST PER INMATE IS HIGHER.
SO THE MEDICAL EXPENSES --
OBVIOUSLY ARE BILLED SEPARATELY
AND SO THOSE GO THROUGH THE
HEALTH NET CONTRACT.
SO ABSOLUTELY THEY'RE NOT BEING
COVERED UNDER MEDICARE ALL THOSE
ARE EXPENSES THAT THAT ARE BEING
PAID FOR IT IS THE COST JUST TO
HAVE THEM IN THE RE ENTRY
FACILITY HIGHER PER PERSON.
THAN IF THEY WERE IN THE ACT
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY THEY HAD
BEEN IN PREVIOUSLY I DON'T KNOW
I DON'T THINK SO A LOT OF TIMES
IS THIS POPULATION IS TENDS TO
BE HEALTHIER -- THAN THE
POPULATION WE HAVE IN OUR
PRISONS THAT'S ONE OF THE YOU
KNOW I'M NOT JUST DOING ITS
HEALTHCARE COSTS NO MY QUESTION
A LITTLE OVERALL COSTS CORRECT.
YET WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT IT'S
MORE EXPENSIVE TO HOUSE THEM
THERE WE BELIEVE THAT -- IT'S
IT'S PROBABLY A COMPARABLE OR
EVEN A LITTLE BIT LESS AND THEN
ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT WE DO HAVE
A A FAIRLY LOW RECIDIVISM NUMBER.
THAT IS COMING OUT OF THAT
PROGRAM SO FAR AND SO WE
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF OF THEIR
RELEASE AND NOT COMING BACK INTO
PRISON IS A HUGE VALUE FOR US AS
WELL ALEJO'S COMMENTS SEEM TO
INDICATE THAT THE COST.
OUT THE REENTRY FACILITY IS
HIGHER PER PERSON THAN THE COST
AT THE THE CORRECTIONAL FACILITY
THE WOMAN HAD PREVIOUSLY BEEN AT
AND YOU INDICATE NO.
THEY'RE NODDING THEIR HEADS YES.
CAN WE HAVE SOME CLARIFICATION.
ADD THAT WE USE THE NUMBERS THAT
ARE PROVIDED IN THE PROPOSAL
WHICH I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
FINAL CONTRACTS HAVE BEEN
NEGOTIATED SO IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
THEY COULD CHANGE -- BUT IF YOU
SIMPLY TAKE THE THE TOTAL DOLLAR
QUESTION DIVIDED BY THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE HOUSE
THERE YOU GET ABOUT.
SIXTY THOUSAND PER YEAR AND
OTHERWISE THESE WOMEN AS FAR AS
WE UNDERSTAND WOULD BE HOUSED IN
THE STATE PRISON WHICH COSTS
ABOUT TWELVE THOUSAND PER YEAR
PER INMATE.
JUST WHAT WE THIS IS THE COST TO
ADD OR REMOVE ONE IN MAINE IS
TWELVE THOUSAND BECAUSE YOU ONLY
HAVE TO PAY OR WE ONLY HAVE TO
PAY FOR FOOD CLOTHES.
ETCETERA WE DON'T CUT CITY
STAFFING YOU ONLY SEE THOSE
SAVINGS AND OTHER TYPES OF
STAFFING.
YOU WOULD ONLY SEE THOSE IF WE
WERE CLOSING A WHOLE PRESENT
THAT'S WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE EIGHTY THOUSAND NUMBER THAT
YOU'RE PROBABLY MORE FAMILIAR
WITH THAT'S THE AVERAGE COST OF
A INMATE.
PER YEAR IN THE STATE PRISON SO
BY MOVING THAT'S HUNDRED TWENTY
WOMEN OUT OF THE STATE PRISON.
WE WOULDN'T BE CLOSING A STATE
FACILITY SO WE WOULDN'T SEE ANY
OVERHEAD COSTS GO WAY WHICH IS.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
STAFFING LARGELY -- SO WE WOULD
BE SAVING ON THINGS LIKE FOOD
AND CLOTHING AND OTHER WHAT WE
CALL MARGINAL COSTS.
NON OVERHEAD ESSENTIALLY AND
THAT'S ABOUT TWELVE THOUSAND PER
YEAR.
ALTHOUGH COUL BE LESS OF THESE
WOMEN PARTICULAR WOMEN ARE LESS
COSTLY.
THIS IS NOT NECESSARILY GERMANE
TO THIS DISCUSSION BUT IN EFFECT
WHAT YOU'RE ADVOCATING IS THAT
ANY POPULATION REDUCTION IS NOT.
A SAVING THIS MONEY.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE COST IS
IN ANOTHER FACILITY SO ANY
POPULATION REDUCTION IN THE
STATE PRISON IS NOT SAVE US
MONEY.
THIS ISN'T A POP A REDUCTION OF
THE OVERALL INMATE POPULATION IT
SHOULD IT IS IN A FACILITY
CORRECT BUT SO IT'S REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF INMATES IN STATE
PRISONS AND EACH ONE OF THOSE
COMES OUT AT AN ANNUAL COST OF
ABOUT.
TWELVE THOUSAND BUT THEN WE'RE
MOVING THEM INTO A MORE COSTLY
FACILITY BY THE YES BY THAT SOME
SINS IN THE B. C. P. ABOUT --
SIXTY THOUSAND PER YEAR SO IT'S
NOT.
IT'S SIXTY THOUSAND TOTAL PER
PERSON PER YEAR COMPARED TO IN
THE STATE FACILITY WHICH IS
EIGHTY THOUSAND PER PERSON PER
YEAR BUT IN A IN THE CASE OF
ACTIVATING TUNE TO NEW
FACILITIES WITH.
THE DECISION THERE IS.
IS TO ACTIVATE THE WHOLE
FACILITY AND WENT WITH A SMALL
FACILITY LIKE.
SIXTY BEDS EACH YOU'RE STILL.
YOU'RE YOU'RE OPERATING THE
WHOLE FACILITY ESSENTIALLY HOW
MAY HOWEVER MANY PEOPLE YOU%
CHOOSE TO PUT THERE.
SO.
IT'S ESSENTIALLY YOU'RE PAYING
THE AVERAGE CAUGHT THE FULL --
SIXTY THOUSAND TO ACTIVATE THE
NEW FACILITY WERE IS ON A ON
THE FLIP SIDE WHEN WE'RE
BRINGING DOWN THE PRISON
POPULATION WE'RE NOT.
AS AS A RESULT OF THIS EXPANSION
GOING TO CLOSE A PRISON SO WHEN
YOU'RE IN THE ACTIVE ON THE
ACTIVATION SIDE YOU'RE INCURRING.
FIXED COSTS ON THE ON THE
DECLINE TO THE PRISON POPULATION
YOU'RE NOT.
SAVING FIXED COSTS OVERHEAD
COSTS I SHOULD SAY THAT MAKE
[inaudible]
MAKES SENSE.
SO IT.
ANOTHER WAY TO THINK ABOUT IT IS
THE EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
EXAMPLE INCLUDES A LOT OF
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS AND THEIR
SALARY AND THE NUMBER OF
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS THAT ARE
EMPLOYED BY CDC OURS AND CAN BE
CHANGED BECAUSE WE TAKE THESE A
HUNDRED TWENTY WOMEN OUT.
AND SO YOU'RE NOT REALLY GONNA
CHANGE NUMBER CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS UNLESS YOU'RE MAKING A
LARGE ADJUSTMENTS LIKE ENOUGH TO
SHUT DOWN ENTIRE WING OF A
PRISONER OR PRISONER OVERALL.
BUT IT DOES DEAL WITH OUR OUR
WOMEN'S FACILITY STILL ARE.
HI MORE OVERCROWDED DETERMINES
FACILITIES.
WHILE WE WHILE OUR COURT ORDER
NUMBERS IN IT IS A TOTAL NUMBER.
WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR INDIVIDUAL
FACILITIES THE ONE SPECIFIC
CITIES ARE HAVE HAD LESS
REDUCTION IN OUR MORE CROWDED?
THAN -- OUR MEN'S FACILITY SO.
WHILE IT MAY NOT REDUCE COSTS IT
DOES ADDRESS THAT ISUE OF THE
OVERCROWDING WHICH WE ARE ALSO
SUBJECT.
TO AHEAD I HAVE THE OVERCROWDING
FIGURES IF YOU'D LIKE -- BUT BY
A FACILITY VERSES OVERALL OKAY.
SO THE OVERALL NUMBER IS A
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN POINT OF
WHAT WE HAVE.
CAVALIERS -- AS OF MAY EIGHTH
ONE OF OUR WOMEN'S FACILITIES
WAS AT A HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
POINT 5% -- ONE WAS AT A HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX POINT.
THREE AND ANOTHER WITH THAT
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN POINT.
NINE THE ORDERLY ONE IS A VOTER
TWO POINT FIVE ONE TWENTY SIX
AND ONE SIXTEEN SIXTEEN OKAY SO
ONE ONE OVER ON AVERAGE -- THE
FEMALE THE WOMEN'S IN FEMALE
INSTITUTIONS OVERALL IS AT ONE
THIRTY THREE POINT.
NINE AND THE MEN WERE AT ONE
THIRTY ONE POINT THREE ON
AVERAGE ACROSS ALTHOUGH MANY
SOME OF THE MEN'S PRISONS ARE
FAR MORE IN FAR LESS CROWDED.
BERMAN FINANCE YOU WANTED TO ADD --
AYE MADELINE CLAIM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I THINK.
WHILE IDEALLY IT WAS CORRECTED
IF YOU TRULY THAT IF YOU PULL
THE NUMBER SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
C. C. TRP PROPOSAL AND DIVIDE IT
BY THE HUNDRED TWENTY
PARTICIPANTS YOU DO GET THAT
COST OF SIXTY THOUSAND BUT IF
YOU AVERAGE.
THE COST OF THE ENTIRE C. C. T.
R. P. PROGRAM IT'S ROUGHLY
EIGHTY TWO DOLLARS PER DAY --
PER -- OFFENDER WHICH IS ROUGHLY
THIRTY THOUSAND PER YEAR SO AS A
AS A WHOLE FOR THE PROGRAM IT IS
LESS BUT I DO UNDERSTAND BE
ALEJO'S POINT I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT.
IN TOTAL THE THE OVERALL PROGRAM
SAVINGS ARE LESS.
COSTS ARE LESS.
VERY I WANNA RETURN -- TO TO THE
MEDI CAL QUESTION -- SO YOU
INDICATED THAT.
WE THAT WHEN WE FIRST BROUGHT IT
ONLINE WE ARE HOPING THAT WE
WOULD BE ABLE -- TO RECOVER
COSTS THROUGH MEDICARE ALL USED
UTILIZING THIS TYPE OF REENTRY
FACILITY BUT THEN YOU DESCRIBE
THAT IN INTERACTIONS WITH THEIR
OWN DEPARTMENT.
THAT WAS DETERMINE WE COULD NOT
WERE THERE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
FEDS.
SO THOSE DISCOVERY IN OTHER
WORDS WE OURSELVES PREVENT OUR
ABILITY -- TO POTENTIALLY RECOUP
THE COSTS.
YES FOR YES IT DOES SO THERE IS --
THERE'S A DOCUMENT THAT CAME
FROM THE FEDS THAT TO FIND --
WHAT WOULD BE REQUIRED IN ORDER
TO PROVIDE FOR MEDI CAL FNDING
AND USING THAT DOCUMENT THAT
CAME FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IT WAS OUR?
AND OURSELVES OUR DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THAT
ULTIMATELY USE THAT DEFINITION
INDETERMINATE THAT OUR
PARTICIPANTS ARE NOT ELIGIBLE.
YES MA'AM.
I THINK WOULD BE VERY IMPORTANT
TO REVISIT THAT AND TO SEE WHAT
ADJUSTMENTS THAT WE WOULD HAVE
TO MAKE.
IN THE FACILITY THEY MAY NOT BE
ACCEPTABLE BUT TO SEE WHAT
ADJUSTMENTS WE WOULD HAVE TO
MAKE OR WHETHER THERE'S ANY
WAIVERS.
BECAUSE THE PREMISE WHEN WE
APPROVED THIS WAS THAT PREMISE
AND HI.
I WOULD HOPE THAT WE WOULD HAVE.
MORE THOROUGHLY.
WE WOULD HAVE EXHAUSTED OUR
POSSIBILITIES VERSUS JUST
DETERMINING BASED ON F.
DEFINITION ON A PIECE OF PAPER --
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS FROM
COMMENTS I MEAN COLLEAGUES.
I JUST HAD SOMEONE ON THE
ELIGIBILITY -- SO WE HAVE WE
HAVE LIKE -- THE COURTESY THE
COMMUNITY TRANSITIONAL REENTRY
PROGRAM THE ONE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT NOW THEN WE HAVE -- THE
FEMALE OFFENDER.
EMINEM PLYMOUTH PROGRAM.
ACT THAT'S NOTELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICAL EITHER RIGHT.
SO THE THAT PARTICULAR PROGRAM
IS ACTUALLY A PAROLES BASED
PROGRAM THE ONE IT'S BASED IT'S
IT'S UP PAROLE PROGRAMS OF THOSE
WOMEN ARE RELEASED FROM.
STATE PRISON AND SO IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THEY ARE ACTUALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDI CAL DOT POINTS
THEN THERE IS A MALE COMMUNITY
REENTRY PROGRAM.
THE ELIGIBLE.
IT'S IN THE SAME CATEGORY AS C.
C. T. R. P. SO TO SAY IT'S A NOT
ELIGIBLE -- THEN -- ENHANCE
ALTERNATIVE BECAUSE THE PROGRAM.
SO THAT'S THAT'S OUR SIXTY TRP
PROGRAM SIR THAT'S THE SAME
THING AS A CC OR DARK CUSTODY TO
COMMUNITY TRANCE SO -- SO WHERE
THESE PROGRAMS -- HOW LONG HAVE
THEY BEEN ESTABLISHED -- IN --
IN THE STATE BUDGET.
SO THE CUSTODY TO COMMUNITY
TRANSIT TRANSITIONAL REENTRY
PROGRAMS BEGAN IN TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN THE MALE COMMUNITY
REENTRY PROGRAMS CAME ONLINE
YEARS EARLIER MAYBE.
WRITTEN RIGHT APARTMENT A
FINANCE THAT CUT TO THE CITY
TEAR PEAS THE WOMEN'S PROGRAMS
WITH TWENTY THIRTEEN AND M. C.
R. P. WAS.
TWENTY FIFTEEN OKAY -- WAS --
WHAT WAS A PROGRAM OF THE CENTER
LOSE STARTED? FOR WOMEN'S
REENTRY PROGRAM SHE'S CHAIR
PROGRAM.
WAS A PROGRAM.
THAT WAS THE ALTERNATIVE CUSTODY
PROGRAM THIS CALL THEIR FOR I'M
JUST GETTING ALL THE NAMES AND I
WON OKAY TELL ME ABOUT WHEN WAS
THAT ESTABLISHED.
IS HOME.
BECAUSE THE PROGRAM WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THAT AND THIS
AND OTHER PEOPLE IN THAT PROGRAM
SO I BELIEVE THAT WAS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT ALL THESE PROGRAS.
THAT'S ONE I BELIEVE THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED AROUND I'D WANT TO
SAY AROUND TWENTY ELEVEN AND
TWENTY TEN JONES SOMETIME IN
THAT -- IS AN AUTHOR THAT
PROPOSAL AND BY THE DEPARTMENT
MIGHT BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO IT
MORE -- THAN THAN I IN GREATER
DETAIL BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THE ALTERNATIVE CUSTODY PROGRAM
TYPICALLY WHAT ENDS UP HAPPENING
WITH THESE WOMEN -- AND NOW IT'S
AVAILABLE TO MEN AS WELL IF I'M
CORRECT -- THEY ARE ABLE TO STAY
IN THE COMMUNITY TYPICALLY IT'S
WITH FAMILY MEMBERS THAT THEY'LL
STAY.
AS OPPOSED TO BEING IN A
FACILITY WOULD LIKE TO SEE C.
TRP SO THAT IS THAT'S THE MAIN
DIFFERENCE DOES THAT PROGRAM
ELIGIBLE -- FOR MEDI CAL.
REIMBURSE YES YES THOSE MEN AND
WOMEN IN THE ALTERNATIVE CUTS
THE PROGRAM ARE ELIGIBLE.
SO SO IF WE HAVE THAT PROGRAM IS
ELIGIBLE IN THIS ONE ISN'T.
OF HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IN THE
ONES HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE ONE THAT.
OF HIS OLD ONE FOR THE MEDICAL
REIMBURSEMENT. SEVEN THAT ARE
ASKING FOR MORE MONEY FOR THIS.
ONE KIND OF WONDERING WHY YOU'RE
NOT ASKING FOR MORE MONEY FOR
THE OTHER.
ONE SO THE ALTERNATIVE CUTS THE
PROGRAM THOSE THOSE OFFENDERS
ARE ACTUALLY RELEASED OUT INTO
EITHER A PRIVATE RESIDENCE OR
INTO A PROGRAM -- AND AND SO WE
NO LONGER HAVE ANY OVERSIGHT --
ASIDE FROM PAROLES AND ARE
TYPICAL -- INTERACTIONS WITH
THEM ON A PAROLE BASIS AND
THAT'S WHY THESE CUSTODY TO
COMMUNITY TRANSITIONAL RIO
BRANCHER PROGRAMS THESE ARE OUR
RUN.
WITH BY US WE MONITOR THEM WE
HAVE PAROLE AGENTS AT THE
FACILITY AS WELL AS COUNSELORS
AT THE FACILITY AND THEN WE HAVE --
TYPICALLY AT A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT RUNS THE RE
AND HAVE BILL TATIAN PROGRAMS
AND SUCH I UNDERSTAND HOW MANY
HOW MANY -- PEOPLE ARE IN THE
OTHER PROGRAM ON THE OTHER
PROGRAM WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
FORTY WOMEN IN THE ALTERNATIVE
CUSTODY PROGRAM AND THEN FOR THE
MEN.
WE WE ARE NORMALLY BETWEEN ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY IS THAT ONE FULL.
CAPACITIES AT THE THERE'S NO BAD
NUMBERS THERE SO THAT REALLY IS
AS MANY AS QUALIFY WE COULD PUT
OUT THERE INTO THOSE PROGRAMS
BECAUSE THEY GO OUT EITHER TO A
FAMILY MEMBER OR A SPOUSE PARENT.
OR INTO A PRIVATE PROGRAM THAT
THEY ACTUALLY -- FINE IS THAT
THE PROGRAM WHERE THESE THEY GET
SENT TO A A RE ENTRY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION.
AND THEY CAN LIVE WITH THEIR
CHILDREN.
SO THAT'S A ACTUALLY A SEPARATE
PROGRAM THOSE A I'M TRYING TO
GET ALL THESE THINGS STRAIGHT
SETS  COMMUNITY PRISONER MOTHER
PROGRAM THAT'S A TWENTY FOUR BED
WAS ONES WHAT'S IT CALLED THE
COMMUNITY PRISONER MOTHER
PROGRAM IT'S IN POMONA
CALIFORNIA. TO TWENTY FOUR BED
FACILITY RIGHT SO IS THERE
PROGRAM -- LOS WERE -- EXPANSION
IS THAT -- THOSE PROGRAMS
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDI CAL.
THE OF THE WOMEN IN THAT
PARTICULAR PROGRAM ACTUALLY GO
BACK TO THE INSTITUTION FOR
MEDICAL SERVICES THE CHILDREN
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE ALL IN
THEIR TREATMENT IS PROVIDED THAT
WAY -- AND SO WE ARE CURRENTLY
AT TWENTY TWO WOMEN IN THAT
PARTICULAR PROGRAM -- THE
NUMBERS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR THAT ARE FAIRLY LOW --
BASED ON ON THE FACT THAT THEY
CAN'T HAVE ANY CRIMES AGAINST
CHILDREN AND I KNOW ENDANGERMENT
TYPE OF OF ISSUES AND SO.
WE ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE A VERY
LARGE PIPELINE FOR THAT
PARTICULAR FACILITY.
RISEN ASKING THIS IS YOU'RE
YOU'RE ASKING.
FOR THE EIGHT POINT FOUR MILLION --
IN THE GENERAL FUND FOR THIS
PROGRAM.
WHICH WE CAN GET REIMBURSED FOR
MEDI CAL BUT WE HAVE ALL THESE
OTHER PROGRAMS.
AND I KNOW THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
QUALIFICATIONS DIFFERENT TYPES
OF PEOPLE DIFFERENT YOU KNOW
LIKE THAT BUT I I I I I I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT.
WE GET THE FULL SCOPE OF ALL THE
THE RE ENTRY PROGRAMS.
SAID AND AND WHAT'S WHAT'S
WHAT'S THEIR ACTUAL SUCCESS AND
FOR THE TYPES OF PEOPLE THEY'RE
SERVING AND DO THEY DO THEY
MERIT -- SOME CONSIDERATION
EDITION OF THIS PROGRAM ARE AS
OPPOSED TO THIS PROGRAM AND SURE
OF A THAT'S THAT'S WHERE I
LOOKED AT THIS SO I THINK IT'S A
FAIR QUESTION.
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO PROMOTE --
THESE -- SUCCESSFUL REENTRY
PROGRAMS.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE SO
SO I LIKE TO HAVE THAT.
IN A WAY MAYBE WE HAVE SO MANY
AT ARE THEY MANAGED BY THE SAME
PEOPLE OR HE EXPLAINED OUT HOW
THE MANAGEMENT OF ALL THESE
REENTRY PROGRAMS.
SO IT THAT CUSTODY TO COMMUNITY
TRANSITIONAL REENTRY PROGRAMS
ARE ACTUALLY UNDER THAT FEMALE
OFFENDER PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
EACH OF THE PROGRAMS ON THE
COMMUNITY ARE RAN BY A DIFFERENT
ENTITY SO WE HAVE ON LA KATA
ALLEN THE LOS ANGELES AREA WE
HAVE WEST CARE.
SO I ST JOHN'S HERE IN
SACRAMENTO'S WITH DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HELP TO RUN
THOSE PROGRAMS AND THEIR
OVERSEEN BY OUR CONTRACT BED
UNIT WHICH FALLS INTO MY MY
MISSION.
THE MALE COMMUNITY REENTRY
PROGRAMS ARE ACTUALLY RUN BY THE
DIVISION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS AND SO THAT A SEPARATE
ENTITY FOR US OKAY -- I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT THAT'S ALL I'M
ASKING I'M ASKING.
FOR MAYBE -- A LOOK AT ALL THOSE
AND TO SEE WHICH ONES ARE.
THE THE WINNERS IN TERMS OF SIX
SIN.
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO LOOK AT THAT
WAY THANK.
FEDERAL.
MADAM CHAIR JUST A COUPLE BASIC
QUESTIONS.
IT IS A HISTORY OF PROVIDING
POPULATION ADJUSTMENTS IS THIS.
SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN DOING.
FOR NUMBER OF YEARS YEAH I'M
LIKE A OTHER DEPARTMENTS THAT
ARE DRIVEN STE MORE ON CASELOAD
OF LIKE OF THERE'S A LOT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE A
POPULATION ADJUSTMENTS LIQUOR
TWICE A YEAR -- WE HAVE A JUST
CONSIDER MADE.
BASED ON OUR INMATE AND KAROLI
LEVELS ARE BASED ON THE STAFFING
STANDARDS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT POPULATION.
VOTER MANPOWER MANAGEMENT
FUNCTIONS.
IT'S THAT AND IT'S OTHER THINGS
AS WELL IF THROUGH OUR
POPULATION PROCESS WE ALSO DO --
HOUSING UNIT CONVERSIONS AS WE
HAVE THE POPULATION CHANGES AND
SHIFTS.
AND WE NEED TO SHIFT THINGS
AROUND WITH OUR PRISON.
AND WE HAVE BEEN A COUPLE OF
NUMBERS OTHER WAY NO NUMEROUS
OTHER THINGS WE D THROUGH THAT
PROCESS BASED ON POPULATION.
AND I'M SEEING LEASE FOR THE
ADULT POPULATION THAT THERE'S
SOME DECREASES.
BUT BIG NUMBERS BUT THREE FORTY
ONE AND TWO SIXTY SIX DO YOU DO
PLAYOFFS OR YES IN FACT WILL NOT
LAY OFFS WE TRY NOT.
TO BUT IN THIS -- PARTICULAR
BUDGET WE HAVE.
WE'RE ASSUMING THAT ALL OF OUR
INMATES THAT ARE EVEN OUT OF
STATE FACILITIES WE CURRENTLY
USED TO HAVE -- INMATES IN -- A
FEW STATES WE NOW HAVE INMATES
ONLY LEFT IN ARIZONA.
THAT GROUP WILL BE -- GONE Y
THE END OF THE YEAR AND SO WE DO
HAVE.
A FEW POSITIONS WITHIN THE
CONTRACT AND UNIT THAT ARE
COMING DOWN WITH THAT AS WELL.
SO WHEN YOU HAVE AN INCREASE YOU
CAN GO OUT OF STATE.
AN OUT SOURCE.
THAT IS CORRECT THAT OUR GOAL IS
TO ELIMINATE THE USE OF THOSE
OUT OF STATE BEDS RIGHT BUT IT'S
A IT'S A STRATEGY WHEN YOU HAVE
AN INCREASING POPULATION THEN
AND SO TO A TEMPORARY SOLUTION
THAT.
BUT HOPEFULLY YOU'RE YOU'RE.
TRYING TO KEEP EVERYTHING CLOSE
BY OKAY.
AND THEN SINCE YOU BEEN PUTTING
A LOT OF NUMBERS.
DO WE HAVE A COST PER CAPITA.
FOR OUR PRISON POPULATION.
MAY I RECOMMEND HER TO FINANCE --
WE DO PUBLISH A PER CAPITA
DISPLAY WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET EVERY YEAR WE CALCULATE --
BASED ON VARIOUS FACTORS HOW
MUCH IT PROXIMALLY COST TO HOUSE
A PRISONER PER YEAR WE ALSO HAVE
PER CAPITA FOR PAROLE -- CAN AND
THAT'S DOES IT GIVE YOU PRIOR
YEARS AS WELL.
GRADE WERE WHEN I GET THAT JUST
ON YOUR WEBSITE.
SO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT WE
CAN CERTAINLY SENATOR STUFF
INDEED WE DO A CORRELATION WITH
OTHER STATES TO BE COMPARED AND
WE HAVE IN THE COMPARISON I
CAN'T THINK OF WHERE IT'S
PUBLISHED OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD
BUT I CAN LOOK INTO THAT FOR YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MANAGER.
CERTAINLY.
WHAT ABOUT TO THE -- COMMUNITY --
KASEY COMMUNITY TRANSITIONAL
REENTRY SO THESE ARE NOT LOCKED
FACILITIES.
OR AT THE LEAST THEY'RE NOT.
LOCKED IN THE SAME WAY THAT AS
THE FACILITY THAT THE INMATE
LEFT BECAUSE IT STATES RATE IN
THE ANALYSIS THAT THESE ARE
PARTICIPANTS THAT HAVE AN
ELECTRONIC MONITORING DEVICE.
WHICH MEANS THE LEAVE.
THEY ARE IN THERE'S MONITORING
OF THAT DEVICE OBVIOUSLY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY DON'T VIOLATE WE
HAVE POOL WE HAVE PEOPLE ON
PAROLE SELECT TRONIC MONITORING
DEVICES -- AND IT MENTIONS THAT
A PRO AGENTS AGENT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE INSTALLATION
AND MONITORING OF THE DEVICE.
SO I GUESS I JUST REALLY FEEL
THAT WE HAVE NOT BEEN THOROUGH
ABOUT THE PREMISE OF STARTING
THIS PROGRAM WAS BECAUSE OF THE
POTENTIAL WILL BOTH FIRST. TO
HELP INCREASE SUCCESSFUL REENTRY
BUT ADDITIONALLY BECAUSE WE
WOULD BE ABLE.
TO UTILIZE THE THE BET FEDERAL
BENEFITS AND OTHERS TO COVER
COSTS THAT WE OTHERWISE SINKER
IF WE HOLD THEM IN OUR STATE
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY.
SO IT IT'S IT WOULD BE VERY
SIGNIFICANT.
WHAT WE WOULD SAY THAT THESE
FOUR HUNDRED WOMEN WERE -- THAT
ARE CURRENTLY WITHOUT EVEN AN
INCREASE JUST THE FOUR HUNDRED
BEDS THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE WERE
AT IF IT IF THIS WERE DESIGNED
IN THE WAY THAT WE HAD INTENDED
WHEN WE APPROVED IN [inaudible]
TWENTY FIFTEEN A SORRY METAL
INGREDIENTS DESK FINANCE -- SO
IT ACTUALLY HAS TO DO WITH THE
IT'S CALLED THE THE MOVEMENT
ISSUE AND THAT THE THE PEOPLE
THAT THE WOMEN IN THESE
FACILITIES AND MANY FACILITIES
ACTUALLY HAVE TO COME BACK TO
THE FACILITY AT NIGHT AND STAY
THERE THEY HAVE -- A DESIGNATED
TIMES RIGHT THERE CHECK IN AND
SO IT'S THAT DESIGNATION ALSO
THAT THAT ARE DESIGNING SO I
GUESS WHAT I'M RAISING IS.
THAT WE BOB THRICE THIS
[inaudible]
UNDER THE PRETTY CATION THAT WE
WOULD HAVE A DESIGN.
THAT WOULD ENABLE US TO RECOVER
THOSE COSTS SO I WANT.
THE WHEN WHAT COMES BACK AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE NUMBERS AND
SUCH ADJUSTMENTS.
OWN MAKE SURE THAT THE ITEM
INCLUDES LANGUAGE.
THAT -- DIRECTS THE DEPARTMENT
TO LOOK AT THAT DESIGN.
IT'S SORT OF ONE OF THOSE WELL
WE'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT -- BUT WE
KNOW IT'S GOT TO COME BACK
BECAUSE THERE'S NUMBER
ADJUSTMENTS THAT HAVE TO BE MADE.
I AM SO APPRECIATE THAT WHEN IT
COMES BACK.
ALRIGHT SO IT'S WERE HOLDING IT
OPEN NOW.
AND WE'RE NOW GOING TO SEE IF
THERE'S YES AND THEN PUBLIC
COMMENT IF THERE IS PUBLIC
COMING TO HAVE THEM.
COME BACK SO. TO SOME BASIC
INFORMATION ABOUT ALL THOSE
TOGETHER REENTRY PROGRAMS AND
WHAT THEY DO AND HOW MUCH THEY
COST.
IS THE BASIC.
THESE ARE ALTERNATIVE CUSTODY
PROGRAM YEAH RIGHT ALL THOSE FOR
ME THE FOLKS THAT ARE.
OUR FULLY OUT OF OUR THANK YOU
YOUR ALTERNATIVE CASSIDY OKAY.
THANK YOU.
CERTAINLY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
ITEM.
OKAY WILL NOW GO.
TO THIS IS OUR LAST ITEM
[inaudible]
JUDICIAL BRANCH. ZERO TWO FIFTY
ISSUE TWENTY NINE JUDGESHIPS
[inaudible]
YEP [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THIS [inaudible]
YES.
THANK.
YOU YOU MAY BEGIN ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRS LINED
PRODUCER SOLVES FOR ASSEMBLY
CERTAINLY SLOT COMPUTER WHICH
BUDGET DIRECTOR FOR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL.
AND I'M HERE WITH ONLY A ROSE
COULD WIN AND THE NANCY EVERHART --
WE ARE HERE -- TO EXCITEDLY --
DOWNS THE THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL FOR TWENTY FIVE
JUDGESHIPS IT WAS A PRIORITY --
FOR THE THE BRANCH IN THE CHIEF
THREE ANNOUNCED EARLIER THIS
YEAR OUR FIRST HEARING IT IS
AGAIN THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN NINETEEN TWENTY RIGHT
RAISING TWO THIRTY SIX AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS.
ON GOING TO ALLOCATE A TWENTY
FIVE OF FORTY EIGHT JUDGESHIPS
ARE AUTHORIZED IN AB ONE FIFTY
NINE BACK IN -- TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN THE COSTING IS BASED ON
THE AMOUNTS THAT WERE APPROVED
LAST YEAR FOR TWO RIVERSIDE
JUDGESHIPS.
AND THIS CONTINUES THE PROCESS
THAT WAS APPROVED IN -- THE BILL
AS FAR AS OUR PROCESS TO
ALLOCATE -- THE JUDICIAL
RESOURCES -- WE APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT OF THE ADMINISTRATION ON
THIS A HIGH PRIORITY FOR THE
BRANCH AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORT AND WE HAVE STAFF HERE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
TECHNICALITIES OF THE OF THE
METHODOLOGY.
AND WE HAVE AGAIN AS HE EVER
HEARD HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF THE CHOCOLATES IF
YOU HAVE THOSE TYPES OF
QUESTIONS.
GO AHEAD YOU MAY PROCEED.
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AGAIN
I'M LEO ROSE GOOD WHEN I AM THE
MANAGER OF THE OFFICE OF COURT
RESEARCH AND THE OFFICE.
BY IS IN CHARGE OF THE
METHODOLOGY TO DETERMINE SHOULD
SHIP NEEDS.
AND THE PRIORITIZATION METHOD A
BY WHICH WE WOULD -- INDICATE
THE COURTS THAT WOULD QUALIFY
FOR NEW JUDGESHIPS SO JUST VERY
BRIEFLY AT THE USUAL NEEDS
ASSESSMENT IS A RUN A BI
ANNUALLY AND THE EVEN NUMBERED
YEARS.
IT IS BASED ON THREE DIFFERENT
FACTORS A THREE YEAR AVERAGE OF
FILENE'S IN CASES OF VARIOUS
TYPES.
WORKLOAD STANDARDS THAT MEASURE
THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT CASES OF
DIFFERENT TYPES TAKE FOR
PROCESSING.
AND A PRIORITIZATION METHOD A TO
DETERMINE IN WHICH ORDER THE
JUDGESHIP SHOULD BE ALLOCATED.
SO WE ARE RIGHT NOW IN THE MIDST
OF UPDATING THE WORKLOAD
STANDARDS -- WE AND THAT IS WHY
I THINK THAT SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE A CONCERNING THIS ITEM.
INDICATES THAT WE WOULD BE
MAKING ALLOCATIONS IN SEPTEMBER
ONCE -- AND AFTER -- AFTER THE
WORKLOAD STANDARDS ARE UPDATED.
SO IN TERMS OF THE USE OF A
PRIORITIZATION METHOD THIS IS
CODIFIED IN THE GOVERNMENT CODE
AND SIX NINE SIX ONE FOUR AND IT
REFLECTS COUNCIL PRIORITIES OVER
THE LAST DECADE -- WHICH INCLUDE
CONSIDERING COURTS WITH THE
GREATEST NEED FOR JUDGESHIPS.
IMPROVING ACCESS TO COURTS A
SAID THAT THE GREATEST NUMBERS
OF USERS CAN BENEFIT.
A KEEPING IN MIND THE
AVAILABILITY OF COURT FACILITIES
FOR NEW JUDGESHIPS.
AND ENSURING THAT SMALL CORDS
ARE ALSO ELIGIBLE A TO QUALIFY
FOR JUDGESHIPS.
SO SPEAKING JUST VERY QUICKLY
ABOUT THE PRIORITIZATION METHOD
THAT WE USE THE CHALLENGE THAT
WE FACE HERE IN THE BRANCHES
PROBABLY.
A SOMETHING THAT OTHER AGENCIES
HAVE TO DEAL WITH BUT IT IS A A
POINT TO FIND THE NEED FOR NEW
JUDGESHIPS WHEN YOU HAVE COUNTY
IS A VERY DIFFERENT SIZES.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN LOS ANGELES --
IT WITH THERE ARE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED JUDGESHIPS I NEED FOR
LET'S JUST SAY FORTY JUDGES IS
ABOUT 10% OF THEIR OVERALL BENCH
SIZE.
WHERE'S IN A SMALL CORD LAKE
LASSEN FOR EXAMPLE WHICH IS
TYPICALLY.
APPEAR ON THE LIST FOR JUDGESHIP
NEEDS.
ARE THEY ONLY NEED ONE JUDGE BUT
THAT REPRESENTS 30% OF THEIR
BENCH.
SO OUR METHODOLOGY ACCOUNTS FOR
THOSE BIG SIZE DIFFERENCES.
AND IT BASICALLY USES AB METHOD
THAT'S VERY SIMILAR TO HOW
CONGRESS A PORTION SEATS -- IT
USES A SET OF RANKINGS SCORES TO
HELP.
NORMALIZE THE NEED FOR
JUDGESHIPS OF ALL CHORDS AND
THEN IT GOES THROUGH THREE
DIFFERENT ITERATIONS TO ACCOUNT
FOR NUMERIC MEAN PERCENTAGE NEED.
AND RELATIVE NEED.
I AND SO THAT IS ALL I HAVE ON
THE TECHNICAL PORTIONS OF THE A
NEEDS ASSESSMENT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
BELIAU YOU READ SOME COMMENTS ON
THIS GO AHEAD.
I NEED TO LEAVE AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
SO WE WE DIDN'T HAVE CONCERNS OF
THE PROPOSAL BUT WE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE DIDN'T WANT TO
KNOW IS TO THE EXTENT THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE'S -- DESIRED
GOAL IS TO EQUALIZE OR TO
MAXIMIZE THE USE OF JUDICIAL
RESOURCES ACROSS THE STATE --
YOU DO HAVE A TABLE ON PAGE
TWENTY ONE THAT SHOWS THE NEEDED
THAT'S IDENTIFIED AND THAT'S
JUST THE POSITIVE -- THE SAME
STUDY ACTUALLY ON THE OTHER SIDE
SHOWS THAT THEIR NUMBER OF
COURTS THAT HAVE A SIMILAR
AMOUNT OF ADDITIONAL JUDGES
BEYOND THEIR WORKLOAD.
SO ONE THING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER IS
THAT IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING
NEW POSITIONS THEY COULD
CONSIDER REALLOCATING JUDGESHIPS --
FROM COURTS THAT HAVE MORE
JUDGES THAN THEIR SSE TO THOSE
THAT HAVE LASSEN THAT WOULD KIND
OF EQUALIZE FASTER THAT'S ONE
WAY TO THINK ABOUT IT.
OKAY.
CENTER BILL WELD -- I THINK MY
QUERY I A COUPLE QUESTIONS JUST --
WHAT IS WHAT IS HOW DOES THIS
AFFECT US SPECIAL CHORDS?
THAT ARE CREATED -- DO YOU
ALLOCATE MONEY FOR SPECIAL
COURTS SEPARATELY.
YOU KNOW LIKE DRUG CORDS -- YOU
KNOW.
THE SPECIAL THE COURTS YOU KNOW
THE MENTAL HEALTH COURTS
ETCETERA.
THEIR LITTLE MORE COSTLY YOU
KNOW.
SO -- WHAT IS THE POLICY ON?
HOW YOU SET UP THOSE KINDS OF
PORTS?
ROAD TO TO THE WHEN YOU YOU SAID
EIGHT X. NUMBER OF JUDGES AND
HELLO WHAT IS THAT MEAN
REGARDING THOSE COURTS.
IT CENTER BALLOT I THINK AT THE
FIRST HEARING HAD THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT
METHODOLOGY AND AT PRESENT THERE
IS A SPECIFIC ALLOCATION -- IT
IS -- BASED ON LOCAL PRIORITIES
pNANCY EVER ARE CAN TALK ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENS IN OUR LOCAL.
IT IS AGAIN IT'S A MATTER OF A
LOCAL NEED NOT EVERY COUNTY IN
COURT NEEDS THE SAME AND
COMMUNITY THE SAME TYPE OF
SERVICE THEY'RE GIVEN MONEY FOR
EACH [inaudible]
JUDGE.
BUT IF THEY WANT TO ESTABLISH
SOME SEPARATE SPECIALLY TOWARDS.
DO THEY HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO PAY FOR IT SOME OTHER WAY OR
OTHER THERE'S OFTENTIMES IT
COSTS MORE RIGHT IT DOES AND IN
IN THIS INSTANCE ARE THEY PAY
FOR THE THERE ARE OTHER.
THERE ARE INSTANCES WHERE THEY
HAVE USED THEIR RESOURCES
HISTORICAL RESOURCES AND PRIOR
INVESTMENTS LOCALLY TO SUPPORT
THOSE ARE ARE SO -- STATE FUNDS
FOR EXAMPLE THEY WERE --
INNOVATION GRANT FUNDS TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TWELVE
MILLION OF WHICH WAS EARMARKED
SPECIFICALLY -- FOR
COLLABORATIVE COURTS AND THERE
ARE TIMES SOME GRANTS EITHER
LOCAL OR EVEN FROM SAY EXAMPLE
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
RELOCATION TO ASSIST IN --
ADDRESSING RECIDIVISM SO IT'S A
COMBINATION OF FUNDS -- THAT
MAKE -- COURTS HAVE THAT THAT
FUNDING AVAILABLE.
AND IF IN IN NANCY LIKE TO DRESS
HOW THEY DEAL WITH IT AND SAN
BERNARDINO AND MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- THE
ALLOCATION COMES TO THE COURT
AND IN ONE LUMP SUM AND THEN
IT'S A A LOCAL COURT PRIORITIES
THAT AND SAID HOW WE WANT TO SET
UP CALENDARS.
SO THE THE PRICE IS THE SAME NO
MATTER WHAT TYPE OF COURT ROOM
YOU SET UP -- WE DO RECEIVE SOME
GRANTS LET'S SAVE A SUBSTANCE
ABUSE GRANTS WE CAN SOMETIMES
RECEIVE NATIONAL GRANTS FOR SOME
OF THE COLLABORATIVE COURTS MOST
OF THOSE ARE PASS THROUGHS --
THROUGH FOR COMMUNITY SERVICES --
SO THE COST OF A COURT ROOM IS
GOING TO BE THE SAME WHETHER
IT'S A SPECIALTY COURT OR LET'S
SAY A GENERAL CIVIL COURT ROOM.
ARE ARE YOU -- INCLUDING IN THIS
THE COSTS OF LEGISLATION THAT WE
PASSED OVER THE LAST YEAR.
THE AFFECTS THE COURTS LAKE --
YOU KNOW THE THE DIVERT TRUCK
CORD DIVERSION TITUS PROGRAMS OF
THOSE KID OF THINGS.
HOW DOES HOW DOES THE BUDGET
REQUEST FOR THE JUDGES FOR IS
AFFECTED THE BILL OF THE
EFFECTIVELY THE FACTOR WE ARE
REQUESTING A PORTION OF WHAT IT
IS THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED IS IN
NEED?
AND I CAN THAT TURNED OVERLY --
TO DESCRIBE WHAT PROCESS WE'RE
GOING INTO NOW WE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF UPDATING EXACTLY WHAT
YOU JUST DESCRIBED IN TERMS OF
FIFTEEN ALL OF THOSE THOSE -- SO
IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
JUDICIAL NEEDS ASSESSMENT IS IN
THE PROCESS OF BEING UPDATED.
UPDATED BY THE END OF THE SUMMER
TO REFLECT THE NEW WORKLOAD
THAT'S OCCURRED SINCE THE LAST
TIME WE DID THE UPDATE THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT TO ME AND THE INFORMED
ABOUT THAT ABSOLUTELY YOU YOU'LL
RECEIVE THAT REPORT -- AS A
LEGISLATIVE REPORT THANK YOU SIR.
CENTER MOORLACH THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I'M JUST CURIOUS.
THIS IS FIFTY NEW POSITIONS AND
ARE THOSE FULLY FUNDED.
THERE ARE TWENTY FIVE NEW
JUDGESHIPS.
SENATOR.
I'M SORRY I HAD TO FIFTY IN MY
HEAD.
THERE WERE PREVIOUSLY FIFTY
AUTHORIZED IN STATUTES TO WERE
RECENTLY APPROVED IN THE IN THE
PRIOR BUDGET TO GET US.
TO THE FORTY EIGHT OF THE MOST
RECENTLY AUTHORIZED THIS WOULD
BE TWENTY FIVE OF THOSE --
REMAINING FORTY EIGHT FROM THE
SECOND GROUP OF FIFTY THAT WERE
AUTHORIZED IN THE JONES BILL IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIX AND SO THIS THE
STAFFING COMPLEMENT THE THE THE
FUNDING IS THERE THERE'S A
COMPLIMENT FOR INTERPRETERS AND
THEN THERE'S THE JUDICIAL
COMPENSATION THAT'S INCLUDED AND
AND THE FUNDING.
ROOMS LAST TIME MORE JUDGES WERE
APPROVED LAST YEAR TO JUDGES FOR
RIVERSIDE WERE PROVED AT ONE
POINT.
NO THAT WAS AN ACTION BY THE
LEGISLATURE -- TO DO THAT
[inaudible]
THE BUDGET.
OKAY NO I'M JUST TRYING.
TO NUMBER AND ASKED BASIC
QUESTIONS AT THE TIME AND THE
TIME BEFORE THAT IN TERMS OF
AUTHORIZED FUNDED JUDGESHIPS WAS
WITH SB FIFTY SIX IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIX THAT'S IT
THAT'S IT YEAH.
SO WHAT'S THE OVERALL PLAN
BECAUSE RIVER OBVIOUSLY SHORT
RATE IN IN IN AND YOU'RE JUST
GIVING ME SEVENTEEN COUNTIES OUT
OF FIFTY EIGHT SO.
WELL NOT ALL COURTS HAVE NOT ALL
COUNTIES HAVE NEEDS THESE F THE
COURTS THAT ARE AT THIS POINT
HAVE JUDICIAL NEEDS THE PLAN IS
THAT WE GET THESE FIRST.
TWENTY FIVE APPROVED AND THEN
WE'LL WE'LL MOVE THERE WITH THE
THE ADMINISTRATION A LEGISLATURE
IN TERMS OF FOR FILL IN THE THE
THE REMAINING NEED WE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE AS I SAID AGAIN THE
UPDATING THE JUDICIAL NEED AND
WHAT COUNTIES WOULD BE.
OF NEED AND SO THIS IS A THINKER
A GREAT AND ACTUAL INVESTMENT IN
THAT -- GRADING KNOWLEDGE WEN
IN THE THE LARGEST INCREASES
SINCE THE FIFTY THAT OCCURRED IN
A YOU KNOW OVER A DECADE AGO.
WOULD YOU BE ASKING FOR MORE WE
ARE WE ARE PLEASED WITH THE
TWENTY FIVE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS INCLUDED.
WE WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT.
SERVICE YOU HAVE GOVERNOR THAT
HOPEFULLY WILL GIVE YOU SOME
JUDGES INDEED [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
CERTAINLY UPDATED [inaudible]
YEAH.
WE DID AUTHORIZE COURSE I WAS IN
LEGISLATURE THEN BUT HOPE WE
WERE VERY COGNIZANT THAT WE
NEEDED AT LEAST FIFTY MORE
JUDGES BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX WE'VE ONLY ADDED
TO SO NOW WE HAVE THE
POSSIBILITY TO ADD.
TWENTY FIVE BUT THE V. M..
ASSESSMENT OF WHERE THEY WOULD
BE PUT IS STILL.
WHEN -- THE STAFF JUST REFERENCE
THAT THEY'RE DOING THIS UPDATE
THAT THEY WILL BE FINISHED TILL
SUMMER.
WERE WERE SCHEDULED TO ADOPT THE
BUDGET BEFORE.
WE GET THAT -- SO I'M GONNA HOLD
OPEN RIGHT NOW.
WE MAY CLOSE AND ACT ON IT FOR
THE JUNE FIFTEENTH OR WE MAY IN
DISCUSSIONS FEEL LIKE WE NEED TO
HAVE THAT UPDATED BECAUSE
THERE'S ALWAYS ABILITY TO DO
BUDGET ACTIONS [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
IN.
AUGUST SEPTEMBER.
I AM NOT NECESSARILY ADVOCATING
WE DO THAT IN THIS CASE BECAUSE
CLEARLY THE NEED IS OBVIOUSLY
THERE.
IT'S MORE THAT -- SINCE THIS
UPDATE IS GOING TO BE FINISHED
SOON THERE MIGHT BE THERE MAY BE.
A COMPELLING REASON SO WE'LL
FIND OUT WE HAVE SOME MORE TALKS
WITH STAFF.
SENATOR MORE LIKE AS A TEMP
GOING FROM MEMORY THERE THE ROTH
BILL I THOUGHT WE VOTED FOR THAT
IT WAS AND VETO THEN BY GOVERNOR
BROWN.
I THINK ONCE THE BUDGET ACTION
WAS TAKEN.
ONCE THE BUDGET ACTION WAS TAKEN
I THINK THE BILL WAS.
JUST TELL TALK.
THANK YOU FOR REFRESHING MY
MEMORY.
RIGHT ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
VETERAN MEMBERS MIKE BELOW FOR
THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
DEFENSE COUNSEL AND NANCY TRAVEL
OUT ALSO ASKED ME TO SPEAK -- IN
THIS CASE FOR THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA I DON'T
HAVE A LOT TO ADD WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE FIRST MEASURABLE
INCREASE IN A DOZEN YEARS.
MUCH HAS CHANGED IN THE COURT
SYSTEM OVER THAT TIME ON THE
CIVIL SIDE BECAUSE OF THE
PRIORITY OF CRIMINAL CASES CIVIL
CASES HAD TO TAKE.
A LOWER PRIORITY SO WE HAD
TROUBLE GETTING CIVIL CASES
THROUGH THE SYSTEM BUT MUCH HAS
CHANGED IN FAMILY LAW
UNREPRESENTED LITIGANTS A GREAT
MANY STRUCTURAL CHANGES HAVE
OCCURRED IN THE COURTS.
WE THINK THIS IS LONG OVERDUE
WERE STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S ACTION AND ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ELIZABETH ESPINOSA TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I
ALSO HAVE THE PROXY OF THE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
YOU'RE WELL AWARE THAT OF THE
NEIGHBORING COUNTIES ARE NECK
AND NECK FOR THE TOP OF THE LIST
BOTTOM OF WILLIS DEPENDING ON
WHICH WAY YOU LOOK AT IT IN IN
TERMS OF HAVING THE HIGHEST
DEMONSTRATED NEED.
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO OTHER
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
WE WILL HAVE A ANOTHER BUDGET
HEARING ON THURSDAY.
AND WE'RE HOLDING THIS ONE OPEN.
BUT I THINK YOU'RE YOU'LL FIND
THAT THE THE LEGISLATURE IN THIS
COMMITTEE WELCOMES THE
ADDITIONAL JUDGES IT'S JUST.
AT WHAT POINT SO.
MEANING IF WE WANT TO SEE THE
UPDATE OR NOT AND WE'LL HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION -- THANK YOU
ALL END THIS ADJOURNS ARE SUB
FIVE A BUDGET COMMITTEE FOR
TODAY